EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE ARE GOING TO START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE -- SO WE JUST
WANNA MAKE NOTE WE HAVE THIRTEEN
ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA.
AND ACTUALLY CERTAIN CENTER
PORTANTINO LOOKS LIKE POINT TO
COME UP BUT I'M GONNA DO MY
INTRO FIRST IF YOU WISH TO BRING
YOU THE COME UP WITH YOUR OF
WITNESSES.
ITEM NUMBER TEN HAS THAT IS
BEING HELD OVER SO WE'RE NOT
HEARING ITEM NUMBER TEN SB --
FIVE THIRTY NINE TODAY THERE ARE
NO ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND SO -- WITH THAT AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
FIRST WITH THAT WE DO TAKE
THINGS AND FOLLOW ORDER BUT WE
ALSO HERE -- MEMBERS ARE NOW THE
COMMITTEE FIRST SUFFOCATION
PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING ALONG SO WE
CAN BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO
SP ONE SIXTY THREE BUT CENTER
PORTANTINO.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY THREE WILL ELIMINATE
SIGNIFICANT ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS
IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS THAT ARE
PREVENTING FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM.
RESEARCH HAS CLEARLY SHOWN THE
CHILDREN WITH ASD WHO RECEIVE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT EARLY
CAN SHOW REMARKABLE PROGRESS --
THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES
REQUIREMENTS FOR A QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROFESSIONAL AND
PARA PROFESSIONAL. TO INSURE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE --
STATISTICALLY TELL US.
STATISTICS TELL US THAT ONE IN
SIXTY EIGHT CHILDREN BORN TODAY
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM.
EARLY INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO
HELPING THESE CHILDREN LIVE UP
TO THEIR POTENTIAL AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT IS
CRITICAL TO THAT HEALTH OF THE
CHILD.
THE SAME.
ARE THEY RESPOND TO TREATMENT
DIFFERENTLY CHILDREN NEED
TREATMENT TAILORED TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS PRESCRIBED BY
THEIR PHYSICIANS OR PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO KNOWS THEM BEST NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL TREATMENT.
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT FIT SO EIGHT
YEARS AGO SB NINE FORTY SIX
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM.
IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS BUT MANY
OTHERS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS BECAUSE
OF A DRAFTING ERROR -- AN
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS NOT EVERY
CHILD IS RECEIVING COVERAGE FOR
THE TREATMENT THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER PRESCRIBES THEM.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED EVIDENCE BASED CARE.
THIS COVERAGE THEY OR THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAVE ALREADY PAID FOR
BUT IN TOO MANY CASES THE
PARENTS OR THE STATE ARE LEFT TO
COVER THE COSTS OF THIS CRITICAL
CARE.
ADDITIONALLY FOR MANY CHILDREN
THERE IS A SIX TO TWELVE MONTH
WAITING LIST FOR THE ONE
TREATMENT THAT HEALTH INSURANCES
COVER.
TREATMENT DELAYED HIS TREATMENT
DENIED IN A DEVELOPING MIND BY
EXPANDING THE TYPES OF QUALIFIED
ALREADY STATE CERTIFIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ELIGIBLE FOR
COVERAGE.
THIS BILL WILL BOTH ADDRESS THE
CRITICAL SHORTAGE AND ALLOW
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE TREATMENT
THEIR PHYSICIANS HAVE PRESCRIBED.
THE BILL ALSO WOULD DRESS
ROADBLOCKS TO COVERAGE FOR
PARENTS WHO FOR REASONS OF WORK
OR FAMILY PRESSURE CAN NOT FULLY
PARTICIPATE.
IN THEIR CHILD'S THERAPY SESSION --
OR WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AT SCHOOL OR
DAYCARE THE SITUATION SHOULD NOT
PRECLUDE COVERAGE FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENT.
AND WITH SP ONE SIXTY THREE THEY
WON'T -- IT ALSO SEEKS TO
CORRECT THE DRAFTING ERROR IN
NINE FORTY SIX TO MAKE SURE
EVERY PERSON WITH AUTISM HAS
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR THEIR
MEDICALLY PRESCRIBED TREATMENT
THE BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE RECEIVED OVER TWO HUNDRED
LETTERS FROM PARENTS IN SUPPORT
AND NUMEROUS AUTISM
ORGANIZATIONS AND PROFESSIONALS
IN ADDITION THE BILL IS CO
SPONSORED BY THE D. I. R. FOR
TIME COALITION OF CALIFORNIA AND
INTER.
COUNCIL OF DEVELOPMENT AND
LEARNING THE SPONSORS REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM THEIR
PARENTS AND THEIR TREATMENT
PROVIDERS I HAVE HERE.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT JIM LANDRY
FROM THE COALITION -- AND OF
CALIFORNIA AND CAITLIN WELSH A
PARENT OF A SON WITH AUTISM AND
THIS BILL PASSED THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR AND I KNOW THE CHAIR
IS VERY FAMILIAR AND WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH.
WITH MY STAFF TO GET IT AGAIN IN
A GOOD POSITION I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO AND
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING A STEP TO
STEP BEFORE WE TAKE A WITNESSES
JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
NAY ANALYSIS THE AMENDMENT THAT
YOU ACCEPTED WAS SIMPLY TO
REMOVE.
A HALF AND IT DID THAT
DEFINITION OF EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE THAT IT IN IN THE NEW
SECTION OF CODE I STILL EXIST IN
THE IN ITS CURRENT SECTION OF
CODE RIGHT.
OKAY TWENTY CLEAR ON THAT OKAY.
AND SO FOR WITNESSES -- JUST --
REMINDED THE WE ALLOW SIX
MINUTES -- OF YOU GUYS YOU CAN.
DECIDE HOW YOU DOING THIS TO BE
BETWEEN THE TWO DO SO I ALWAYS
REMIND THE PEOPLE SPEAK FIRST
REMEMBER THE PEOPLE FOLLOWING.
AND AND AND AND SAME WITH THE
OPPOSITION ALL THAT YOU DO NOT
ALSO HAVE TO TAKE ALL THE TIME
IF YOU DO NOT WISH.
TO SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND WELCOME AND
PLEASE PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES.
THANK YOU DOCTOR POUNDS SITE AND
ACTUALLY BEFORE WE BEGIN SORRY I
WE DICEY OF WITNESS A QUORUM
SAID IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL THE STATUS
QUORUM SO WE CAN ACTUALLY VOTE
ON THE BILL AND YOU'RE DONE.
THANK YOU PAN.
I'M HERE STONE.
STONE HERE DRAWS SO.
GROWTH HER TADO.
HER TITLE HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL'S HERE MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
SORRY FOR ALL THE BILL HAYES
THANK YOU THAT'S QUITE ALRIGHT --
DOCTOR VAN HAS CENTERS -- MY
NAME IS JIM LANDRY I REPRESENT
THE DR FLOOR TIME COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA -- THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE CULMINATION OF TWENTY YEARS
OF WORK THE LEGISLATURE --
ORIGINALLY ADOPTED -- THE MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY ACT BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH SAID
THAT THE HEALTH INSURANCE NEEDED
TO COVER AUTISM AS WELL AS OTHER
MENTAL.
HEALTH -- CONDITIONS IN THE SAME
MANNER AS PHYSICAL AILMENTS.
A HIGH AND TO SOME EXTENT --
THAT WAS DONE UNFORTUNATELY IT
WAS NOT DONE FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR REASONS
THAT THE INSURANCE COMPANIES --
CLAIMED IT WAS EDUCATIONAL IT
WAS EXPERIMENTAL AND WHATNOT NEW
NEWS TOOK -- SEVERAL -- LAWSUITS
HAND -- TO FINALLY GET THEM TO
BEGIN TO COVER IT -- UNTIL --
SENATOR STEINBERG PASSED SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY SIX EIGHT YEARS
AGO -- SO SENATE BILL NINE FORTY
SIX WAS PASSED AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES LOOK TO
BEND SAID OKAY WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING NOW -- BUT
WHAT YOU REALLY MEANT WAS THIS
AND IT.
WAS NOT WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
MEANT -- AS THE CENTER
PORTANTINO MENTIONED THERE WERE
SOME DRAFTING ERRORS AND EVEN
THOUGH THE BILL CLEARLY SAID IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO COVER ALL
PHYSICIAN AND PSYCHOLOGIST
PRESCRIBED EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT -- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT -- THAT WAS NOT THE
CASE AND SO WE'RE BACK AGAIN
HOPEFULLY IT THE CULMINATION OF
THISTWENTY YEAR EFFORT TO
FINALLY ACHIEVE THE NECESSARY
COVERAGE THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ASKED.
FOR THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DEMANDED THAT WE COVER EVIDENCE
BASED PHYSICIAN PRESCRIBED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM -- THAT
THEY HAVE PAID FOR AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL FINALLY COVER THAT
LOOP AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK CAITLYN WILSHIRE MOTHER
OF A YOUNG MAN WITH AUTISM.
WHO HAS A EXPERIENCED THIS? TO
TELL ABOUT HER SOME OF HER
EXPERIENCES.
THANK YOU.
MY SON IS TEN HIS NAME IS
SPENCER AT TWO HE BECAME VERY
AGGRESSIVE TOWARDS ASSN OTHERS
AND KAISER -- BASICALLY SAID HE
WAS VIOLENT.
WHEN HE WENT TO PRESCHOOL IT WAS
AN ISSUE?
AND THEY RECOMMENDED WE SEE A
CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST OUTSIDE OF
KAISER WITHIN THE FIRST SESSION
HIS HOUR AND A HALF RAGES WHERE
WE HAD TO RESTRAIN HIM WENT DOWN
TO ADD AND THAT WAS EVERY DAY.
WENT ON TO TWENTY MINUTE RAGES
EVERY OTHER DAY AFTER THE SECOND
SESSION IT WAS ONCE A WEEK.
AND AFTER THAT WE NEVER HAD TO
RESTRAIN HIM AGAIN.
IT WAS THAT EFFECTIVE IT WAS
THEN HE WAS OUT -- DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM AND SHE LET US KNOW
THAT WHAT SHE WAS DOING WAS D.
I. R. FLOOR TIME.
AND BECAUSE THEY SAID IT WASN'T
ABA AND SO WE'VE BEEN GETTING
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS OF DIR
THROUGH REGIONAL CENTER.
IT'S BEEN AMAZING AND HE WAS
DOING REALLY WELL AND WE DID A
FADE OUT BUT THERE'S STILL SOME
ISSUES HIS ARTISTIC.
SO I WENT TO KAISER AND I SAID
WE AND THE DEVELOPMENTAL
PEDIATRICIAN SAID.
HE REALLY NEEDS TO CONTINUE THIS
THERAPY IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR
HIM AND SHE RECOMMENDED DIR AND
THEY WE WERE ASKING FOR FOUR
HOURS A MONTH.
AND THEY DENIED IT WHAT THEY
SAID YOU CAN DO ABA.
AND SO NOW WE GET FORTY HOURS A
MONTH OF ABA AND IT'S KIND OF A
DISASTER FOR MY KID.
HE'S NOW HAVING TEMPER TANTRUMS
AND RAGES RAN OUT THE DOOR AND
DOWN THE BLOCK HIDING UNDER
BOXES.
AND THROWING THINGS AT WAL SO
WE'RE NOW IN A SITUATION YOU
KNOW MAY BE DIFFERENT KIDS NEED
DIFFERENT TYPE OF THERAPY I KNOW
ABA WORKS WITH A LOT OF KIDS BUT
IT DOESN'T WORK WITH OURS.
AND IT'S HARD THAT MY
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN WAS
NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR MY SON AND IT
WAS NOT ACCEPTED BY THE
INSURANCE COMPANY.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ACT MICROPHONE.
OPERATES LIKE A LOT OF ASIAN.
ALL EYES ARE ON ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU PLEASE REPEAT SORRY
REPEAT FOR THE RECORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA LEVY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
ARE SEEN OTHER WITNESSES AT THE
MICROPHONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- COME UP TO THE
TABLE.
COME UP WITH A LOOK AT HIM I
THINK WE HAVE. THREE CHAIRS
THERE WE HAVE THREE ALL RIGHT.
AND AGAIN I REMIND YOU SIX
MINUTES TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO THE
BETWEEN THE THREE OF YOU UNTIL.
ARE A GOOD.
DON'T LEAVE THE LAST ONE AM.
THANK YOU -- FOR HAPPINESS AND I
AM -- BOARDS AT MY NAME'S
MICHELLE HEIGHT AND I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS AND
I'M THE VICE CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC
POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL DUE TO THE EXPANSION OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR QUALIFIED
ARTISAN SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
IMPAIR PROFESSIONALS.
AND RESPECTFULLY JUST.
WISH THAT YOU WOULD VOTE NO AND
THAT WE WOULD HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSION WITH AUTHOR ON THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER ALI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS REVEREND
REPRESENTING. FORTY FIVE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE.%
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TWENTY TO
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT INCLUDES THOSE
WITH AUTISM.
I'M CAPS MEMBERS CURRENTLY
PROVIDE MEDICAL COMPLY BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS SERVICES TO THEIR
ENROLLEES WITH -- AUTISM -- SB
NINE FORTY SIX IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN MOVED AUTISM COVERAGE OUT
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
REQUIRED HEALTH PLANS TO CUT
COVER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THERAPY.
FOR PEOPLE WITH AUTISM -- AND
OUR EXISTING LAWS AND
REGULATIONS REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO MAINTAIN
ADEQUATE NET NETWORKS OF AUTISM
SERVICE PROVIDERS -- AND SINCE
THAT TIME AUTISM -- SERVICES ARE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS.
ON THIS BILL INCLUDES AN
EXTENSIVE PROVISIONS ABOUT THE
CRITERIA FOR PROP PROFESSIONALS
AND CARE PROFESSIONALS.
WHO MAY PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THERAPY IT'S IMPORTANT
REMEMBER THAT THESE PROVISIONS
OF LAW?
IN THIS BILL AMEND THAT THE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
MANDATE PROVISIONS AND DON'T
NECESSARILY INTEND TO DRESS
PROVIDER INDUSTRY STANDARDS --
THE SB NINE FORTY SIX TASK FORCE
ACTUALLY RECOMMENDED THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS WHICH MAY BE MORE
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM FOR
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING SUCH
STANDARDS.
OR OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT IT MAY DILUTE THE
QUALITY OF CARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVE BYRON RELEASE.
GENERALLY SPEAKING HEALTH PLANS
CONTRACTORS LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS. TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICES PROVIDED TO THEIR
BELIEFS ARE ROOTED IN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE.
SHEET IN REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE TO REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE SCOPE OF PROVIDER CHANGES
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL.
HEALTH PLAN COVERAGE DECISIONS
ARE ROOTED IN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE.
AND MEDICINE INTO STUDIES ONE
WITH THE SAMPLE SIZE OF TWENTY
TWO OR INSUFFICIENT FROM HEALTH
PLANS PERSPECTIVE TO BECOME
EVIDENCE BASED.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
NATIONAL AUTISM CENTER CAN BE TO
PANEL RESEARCHERS TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF BERRIES
BEHAVIORAL THERAPIES TO ADDRESS
AUTISM RELATED CONDITIONS.
THE REPORT INCLUDED A LIST OF
THIRTEEN AND STAMP UNESTABLISHED
INTERVENTIONS FOR CHILDREN.
AND INCLUDED T. R. OR FLOOR TIME.
AS AN UNPROVEN MODALITY -- SO I
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE HEARING
MULTIPLE MULTIPLE BILLS THIS
YEAR THAT WILL HAVE A SMALL
RELATIVE LARGE IMPACTS ON HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM COSTS.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF SIX SENATE
BILLS THAT WILL BE CONSIDERED.
FOR MANY POLICY ARGUMENTS CAN BE
MADE TO WITHOUT SOME OF THESE
BILLS WE WOULD URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT
ON THESE BILLS.
AND THE TRADE OFFS ASSOCIATED
WITH INCREASING HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS -- TO THE CONTEXT THAT
SOME OF THEM.
IT'S ADDING TO THE HIGHER COST
OF HEALTH CARE.
STEPHANIE WHAT CAN SOMEBODY HAVE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THEM AT
THAT THE COMMITTEE WENT FORWARD.
REGARDING EVIDENCE BASED
UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL I THINK IN
GENERAL WE HAVE A BIT OF A
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THE CHARACTER
ASIAN CHARACTERIZATION THAT AND
SB NINE FORTY SIX THAT IT WAS A
DRAFTING ERROR.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE -- WE'VE
ALWAYS LOOKED AT FLOOR TIME IS
POTENTIALLY NOT EVIDENCE BASED
NOTHING FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
ENROLLEES IN THE PRODUCTS THAT
WE PROVIDE THAT.
WE ENSURE THAT THE WHAT WE OFFER
IS EVIDENCE BASED IN IS QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND I THINK -- IF
THIS BILL BIT DOES MOVE FORWARD
TODAY I THINK WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO POTENTIALLY HAVING ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS WERE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY REMOVING -- THE
PARENT FROM THE PROCESS WE THINK
THAT THE KEY ELEMENTS -- WITH
RESPECT TO MAKING SURE THAT
SUCCESS OF THE CHILD AND THE
FAMILY UNITS -- SO FOR THOSE
REASONS REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR AND
STAFF AS IF THE BILL DOES MOVE
FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BACK BACK FROM NAME
ORGANIZATION DOES ON LINGER ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CAPITA CLICK THANKS
THANK YOU.
KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
SYDNEY JACKSON FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION OF CONCERNS -- THAT WE
HAVE STARTED WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSOR TO ADDRESS THAT
OUR MAIN ISSUE IS THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT INSURE SOME FORM OF
PARENT PARTICIPATION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
MEMBERS OFFICE OKAY THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH.
OKAY BEFORE YOU BRING IT TO YOU --
MEMBERS FOR SO I UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS A
MANDATE BILLET HATCH BERMAN
ALICE'S OR SOMEONE FROM TO
PURPOSE HERE.
IF -- ACTUALLY IF YOU CAN ASK
YOU TO JOIN US AT THE TABLE WE
MAY HAVE THERE MAY BE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP THAT YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO HELP ELIMINATE --
FROM YOUR ANALYSIS SO I'VE THREE
SHE YOU BEING HERE AND BEING
WILLING TO THE STATE THIS
CONVERSATION -- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE -- THAT -- AGAIN YEAH
CENTER PORTANTINO JUST ONE
MENTION I'M JUST SAYING THIS
BECAUSE YOUR BILL HAPPEN TO BE
THE FIRST ONE UP FOR THAT
RELATES TO A TO A MANDATE -- I
I'D DO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL MANDATE BILLS
WE ALSO HAVE -- BILLS TO REQUIRE
PEOPLE GET HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE SO WE ARE VERY
CONSCIOUS OF OF THIS -- I
AWESOME CONSCIOUS THAT -- WE
WILL BE SURE HEALTH INSURANCE IS
THERE WHEN PEOPLE NEED IT SO --
AND SO YOU KNOW HAVING COVERAGE
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY COVER WHAT
YOU NEED IS ALSO AN ISSUE TOO
BUT VERY MUCH ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE WANT TO TRY -- TO NOT
OVER BURDENING PEOPLE WERE GUY
ASKED TO BE COVERED -- DO THAT
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE AN
ANALYSIS -- THAT'S WHAT WE DO TO
RIP AND THAT'S WHY I ASKED TO
PROVE TO BE AT THE TABLE TO
ENSURE THAT MAY COME UP AND SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT MAY COME
UP.
SO WITH THAT CAVEAT I SAW
THROUGHOUT THEIR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS CENTER STEP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR FOR
MISS ALLI THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE FREE SHOOTER TESTIMONY --
AT IN MY LITERATURE -- MY STAFF
REPORTED SHOWS A FOR MENTALITIES
BASED ON DEVELOPMENTAL THEORY D.
S. P. -- THAT THERE IS A
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE THE D.
I. R. FOR TIME IMPROVES
COMMUNICATION ENGAGEMENT.
AND RELATIONSHIPS.
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
CAN.
I HAVE A SON MY FIRST BORN GRAND
CHILD IS SIX YEARS OLD.
A NON VERBAL -- THERE ARE SOME
SERVICES THAT ARE COVERED BY HIS
INSURANCE.
AND THERE ARE MANY SERVICES LIKE
THIS THAT ARE NOT COVERED BY
INSURANCE.
AND IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE IF YOU
HAVE AN AUTISTIC CHILD AND YOU
NEED TO GET THEM THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED HE SPENDING THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS -- OUT OF HIS POCKET.
TO TO A CANNY SEEING SOME
PROGRESS.
WITH -- THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS --
YOU KNOW WHAT WITH THAT WITH THE
SHORTAGE OF A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
IS SOME TREATMENT BETTER THAN NO
TREATMENT AT ALL BECAUSE THESE
KIDS THESE MILLENNIALS Là CAN'T
AFFORD -- TO PAY FOR A LOT OF
THESE SERVICES ON THEIR OWN.
AND THEN YOU KNOW HOW WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND I ANSWER MY SON WHEN
HE SAYS TO ME TONIGHT THAT --
WHY DIDN'T YOU HELP ME TO ALLOW
FOR SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT
ARE BANKRUPTING US? TO GET YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTER THE SERVICES SHE
NEEDS OF THE GOD WILLING SHE
SPEAKS ONE DAY SHE'S INTELLIGENT.
BUT SHE DOES HAVE NO VERBAL
SKILLS ON ALL.
SIDES WHEN IF YOU KIND OF
ANGELES QUESTIONS FOR ME TO
FURTHER THE THE PROVIDER HERE
THAT WE HAVE TODAY BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE PLANTS
HAVE AN INTERNAL ROBUST --
PROCEDURE TO EVALUATE THE
EFFICACY.
OF THE AFFECTED NYSSA VARIOUS
TREATMENT AND THAT INCLUDES FOR
ALL DISEASE GROUPS WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW A MEDICATION A
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION -- PHONE
CALL SHE TYPE OF TREATMENT IN
AND SO THEY HAVE THESE
COMMITTEES THAT REVIEW ALL OF
THE AVAILABLE -- MEDICAL
EVIDENCE AND TO THEIR ANALYSIS
FLOOR TIME CONTINUES NOT JUST
DOESN'T HAVE.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF RESEARCH AND
STUDIES AVAILABLE THAT DO EXIST
FOR APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS --
YOU KNOW THERE'S THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AUTISM CENTER
CONVENED INTO THEIR REVIEW OF
THE LITERATURE. TO BURP ALSO
REVIEW THE XISTING LITERATURE
AND IN IN THEIR REPORT IT IT.
IN A YOU KNOW HE CAN PROBABLY
SPEAK TO THIS BETTER THERE WERE
TO STUDIES THAT SHOWED THAT
FLOOR TIME -- WERE EFFECTIVE
THAT WERE CITED IN IN THAT.
THE TROOPER BUT ALSO IS BUT ONE
OF THEM ONLY HAD A A SAMPLE SIZE
OF TWENTY TWO PATIENTS IN SO
THAT'S A VERY SMALL AND SO WE
TALK ABOUT THE VOLUME OF
EVIDENCE BEING AVAILABLE. TO
KIND OF OUTLINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF A CERTAIN TYPE
OF TREATMENT UNFORTUNATELY FOR
FLOOR TIME IT'S JUST NOT THERE.
YOU KNOW WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
EVIDENCE TO BASE OUR COVERAGE
DECISIONS ON THE WE RELY ON OKAY
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE
COMPETING -- THEORIES AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS THE FACT
OVER NOT OUT I WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO HELP
MY GRANDDAUGHTER OUT.
WHEN I'M GOING TO DO PROBABLY
TODAY IS ON A LAY OUT THIS BILL
I WOULD LOVE TO TALK WITH YOU
MORE AND I WANT TO TALK TO THE
PROPONENTS MORE -- BUT THERE ARE
THERE ARE MANY -- KIDS LIKE MY
MY GRAND CHILD OUT THERE THAT
ARE -- NOT GETTING SERVICES
BECAUSE ARE NOT COVERED BY
INSURANCE AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE SERVICES BECAUSE
BEEN AS YOUNG KIDS JUST CAN'T
AFFORD THE COSTS -- AND MY SON
STRUGGLES THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
EVERY SINGLE MONTH THE TO GIVE
HOPE FOR HIS.
FIRST BORN.
THAT SHE COULD LEAD OF A
WONDERFUL PRODUCTIVE LIFE SO --
MAYBE WE CAN GET TOGETHER LIKE
TO LEARN MORE FROM YOU AND I'M A
LEARN MORE FROM THE PROPONENTS
IN THE BUT I PREACHY -- MY
COLLEAGUE FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND TRYING TO HELP THESE
FAMILIES OUT THAT ARE THAT ARE.
DOING THEIR BEST TO TRY TO HELP
HER AUTISTIC CHILDREN WHEN YOU
MENTION THE RATIO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LOT OF KIDS.
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW THERE THERE
ARE SKEPTICS OUT THERE THAT
WOULD SAY THAT THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES DON'T WANT TO ALLOW
THESE PROFESSIONALS IN THEIR WHY
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO INCREASE
THE COST.
US SIGNIFICANTLY WHEN YOU HAVE
THE RATIO OF KIDS ARE BEING BORN
TODAY WITH AUTISM BUT YOU KNOW --
THEY DESERVE TO BE TREATED LIKE
ANY OTHER DISEASE AND AND I'M IN
GERMANY IN MY POWER TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT.
AND AGAIN I THINK THE AUTHOR
BRING FORWARD.
AND OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF GETTING.
SO LET ME -- SO.
ACTUALLY ME POSE A QUESTION FROM
SUBURBAN HERE AND THEN MAYBE I
ALSO SENT HER TINO ASK YOU.
TO RESPOND TO THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS IF I MAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL PLEASE
PLEASE IT WHEN WE GO HEAD TO THE
WE JUST WANT TO GO AHEAD RESPOND
FIRST THE CENTER STONE IF THAT'S
ALRIGHT AND THEN -- WILL FALL TO
MY QUESTION YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YET SENATOR I I THINK
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT.
PATH TO MAKING DECISION ON THIS.
AND YOU HAVE IN ESSENTIALLY A
MONOPOLY.
AND AT THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF FAMILIES
STRUGGLING WITH CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM.
AND A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THOSE FAMILIES ARE FINDING THAT
THE ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT.
IS EFFECTIVE IF THEY DIDN'T.
TAKE THE FIRST TREATMENT WASN'T
THEY WOULD HAVE GONE TO THE
SECOND TREATMENT.
AND THE WAY WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE
AN ARBITER IN THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A
MONOPOLY YOU'RE GONNA SAY WERE
BETTER THAN THE OTHER ONE AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A MONOPOLY.
IS WERE IN POWER IN THE
PHYSICIAN. TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
THIS IS DOCTORPRESCRIBED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT.
AND SO.
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP OUT THE
FAMILY THAT YOU DESCRIBE.
BY SAYING IF THEY'RE FOR
PHYSICIAN THINKS THAT CHILD IS
GOING TO BENEFIT FROM FOR TIME.
THAT THE INSURER SHOULD COVER IT
AND THAT'S WHY THERE'S
OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO COVER IT.
BY AND WE WANT TO HELP THAT KID
JUST LIKE YOU WANNA HELP THAT I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE AND VERY
PROTECTIVE OF THE PHYSICIAN
PATIENT.
RELATIONSHIP.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT A LOT OF
THE SERVICES THAT MY SON IS
UNDERTAKING FOR MY GRANDDAUGHTER.
ARE BASED ON THE ORDERS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE PHYSICIAN
AND THAT'S EXACTLY -- TRYING TO
DO HERE I WAS ON THE FENCE AND
YOU PUSH ME ON YOUR SIDE OF THE
FENCE AND SO.
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY IN A AND
I WANT TO THE STILL ONE OF THE
UP PLEASE THANK YOU.
I STILL WANT TO MEET WITH THE
OPPONENTS -- AND RESERVE MY
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR BUT LET ME TELL YA.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN AUTISTIC
CHILD IN YOUR FAMILY IN C..
THE THE CHALLENGES.
OF THE THE CONFLICTS BETWEEN THE
HUSBANDS OF MY WIFE'S AND WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD -- YOU KNOW WE ALL WANT A
BETTER LIFE FOR OUR CHILDREN OUR
GRANDCHILDREN WE HAVE FOR
OURSELVES AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED AUTISM LEASE.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP WE DIDN'T
CALL IT AUTISM NOR DO I?
RECOGNIZE THE SYMPTOMS OF WHAT I
SEE TODAY BACKGROUND -- BUT LET
ME TELL YOU IT'S LIFE CHANGING
LIKE CHANGING I WOULD GIVE
EVERYTHING I HAVE.
SO THAT MY GRANDDAUGHTER --
COULD HAVE A A A GOOD LIFE A
FAIR LIFE -- A LIFE WITH THE
FEAR BEGINNING TO COMPETE IN THE
WORLD AND SO -- CENTER
PORTANTINO WHO I RESPECT YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- IN A
POSITION CERTAINLY ORDERS THIS
KIND OF TREATMENT THAT SHOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THANK YOU AND I
I'VE NEVER SAID THIS BEFORE BUT
YOU MADE ME CRY.
THANK YOU SO I JUST A REMINDER
FOR THE AUDIENCE -- THE THE
RULES OF THE HOUSE ARE THAT NO --
NO VERBAL RIGHT NO VERBAL --
DEMONSTRATIONS BECAUSE AGAIN
RESPECT TO THE THEY NEED A HOUSE
SO -- DOUBT WHETHER IT'S SO
VERBAL EXPRESSIONS ARE SNAPPING
FINGERS BUT WE LIKE YOU LIKE
SOMETHING TO THIS.
OKAY THAT'S FINE.
GOOD YES THERE YEAH YOU CAN DO
THIS IF YOU LIKE SOMETHING.
RIGHT -- SO -- THIS IS JUST A
REMINDER FOR EVERYONE -- SO.
I GUESS MY QUESTION I KNOW THAT --
I DID HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
THAN ALICE'S FROM SUPER
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK YOU DID
CAN YOU JUST PERHAPS SPEAK TO
THE EVIDENCE THAT YOU SAW IN IN
THE STUDY -- IN YOUR EXAMINATION --
OF THIS ISSUE.
BUT IN TERMS OF THIS THE
EVIDENCE IS AVAILABLE THAT OUR
FACULTY CONSIDERED -- WHILE
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL A GREAT
DEAL IS ALSO OBSERVATIONAL WHICH
IS COMPARING COURSE AGAINST.
NOT SO SPECIFIC AS THE
MODALITIES WERE DISCUSSING HERE.
THE STRONGER EVIDENCE IS NOT AS
COMMON FOR ANY OF THE MODALITIES
AND OUR FACULTY CONSIDERED AT
ALL AND THOUGHT THAT IT WAS A
PREPONDERANCE.
FOR NOT ONLY DEVELOPMENTAL AND
THE BEHAVIORAL BASE BUT THE THE
HYBRIDS IS REALLY SOMETHING OF A
MIX BETWEEN THE TWO INTERESTED
IN BOTH OF THE THEORIES IN TERMS
OF HOW IT WORKS.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- DIE A TO
THE IN A CENTER PORTANTINO I AND
I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
THEIR TO ME BECAUSE THE EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICINE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN PART OF MY CAREER --
THE I HAVE A BACKGROUND IN.
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THIS INTO MY
MASTERS PUBLIC HEALTH IS ON
FOCUSED ON ON CLINICAL QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT SO EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES OR SOMETHING THAT IS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO ME.
I THINK I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
AMENDED BECAUSE THE DEFINITIONS --
CAN BE A LITTLE CHALLENGING AND
ACTUALLY I WANT TO BE SURE WE
DIDN'T PUT A DEFINITION CODE
THAT WASN'T BUT THE SAME TIME I
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS WE DO IN MEDICINE.
THAT WE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE DOING
BIG STUDIES IS EXPENSIVE SO BIG
STUDIES HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN DONE
I MEAN WE LOOK AT NEONATOLOGY
I'M PEDIATRICIAN.
WHAT OF THOSE STUDIES ARE VERY
IS -- THE UPDATE INVOLVED TO
TWENTY PATIENTS OR TWELVE
PATIENTS OR SOMETHING AND DEAL
WE WE DON'T WANT WHAT WE CALL
EVIDENCE BASED MEDICINE -- SO
THAT SOUNDS EXAMINE EXPERT BUT
SAME TIME WE ALSO TO TAKE THE
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE AN
EXISTENCE AS A WILL WHICH
DIRECTION IS A LOOK LIKE NOW
SOMETIMES IT'S WRONG AND WE HAVE
TO CHANGE DIRECTION.
BUT WE CAN'T SAY WELL IF WE
SOMEONE DIDN'T DO A BIG STUDY WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING AND WE'RE NOT%
GOING TO PROVIDE CARE RIGHT WE
HAVE A PATIENT WHO NEEDS HELP.
AND SO THEY NEED TO GET CARE AND
THAT'S SO I THINK IF WE IT IS
NOT A CASE WHERE A PHYSICIAN IS
WILLFULLY -- JUST TRYING TO AND
HAS A CONFLICT AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING THAT
THERE'D YOU EXERCISING THE BEST
CLINICAL JUDGMENT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO THERE ISN'T
RESEARCH ON EVERY SINGLE ASPECT
OF CARE.
THEY'RE USING THE BEST CLINICAL
JUDGMENT USING THE BEST
AVAILABLE EVIDENCE.
I THINK WE HAD AN IDEAL THAT WE
COULD TALK ABOUT MEDICAL
NECESSITY DEFINITIONS AND ALL
THAT WE'LL GET INTO THAT BUT I
MEAN I'VE FUNDAMENTALLY I DON'T
SEE HOW WE CAN'T SAY THAT WELL
WE NEED TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON
THAT.
AND AND I THINK WHAT YOU HEAR IS
THAT YOU HAVE A BEHAVIOR
DEVELOPMENTAL TOO SO IT'S NOT
LIKE SOMEONE.
YOU KNOW JUST GOT ANY FOUND THE
DOCTOR TO TELL THEM WHAT THEY
WANT TO HEAR DAVE STATE THAT
THEIR OWN BE GIVEN DEVELOP THE
FUTURE IS A SPECIALIST IN THE
FIELD SAID.
YOU KNOW WHAT BASED ON
EVERYTHING I SEE WITH YOUR CHILD
IN MY KNOWLEDGE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY BENEFITS.
SIGNIFICANTLY.
I FIND IT HARD TO SAY WELL GUESS
WHAT WE'VE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
ARTISAN BENEFIT BUT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO COVER THAT.
I MEAN THIS IS NOT SOMEONE WHO
HASN'T BEEN EVALUATED FAIRLY
THOROUGHLY AND AND SO -- SO I AM
YEAH I I UNDERSTAND AND AND DOES
THE SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND
WHERE WE ARE TRYING TO PUT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PIECES TOGETHER
BUT AND ADMIT I TRAINING
BEHAVIOR DEVELOPMENTS -- NOT
FORMAL BE INDIE DR BUT I I DO I
DO THINK THAT -- WE WE NEED --
TO THAT -- THAT WE WE NEED TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO HOW. TO TO TO TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THESE FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE --
TREATMENTS THAT -- THE BILL
PROVIDES EVIDENCE SHALL BE GREAT
WE HAD BETTER BIGGER STUDIES AND
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE CONDUCTORS
BIGGER STUDIES BUT I AND I AM
NOT SURE WE SAY WELL UNTIL THAT
HAPPENS WE DON'T.
WE DON'T KNOW WE WE CAN'T.
COVER IT SELL -- THAT I HEAR A
MOTION ON THE BILL OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY JUST IN THE MOTION SIR
PORTANTINO DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IBM.
OKAY RIGHT SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO HUMAN
SERVICES AND EMOTIONS BEEN MADE
BY CENTER MITCHELL SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FAN HI AND I STONE.
STONE I DORADO.
DRUGS SO I GROW.
HER TADO.
HER TITLE I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT THE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
FOR TWO THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS -- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE I SEE SAYS CENTER ARCHULETA
HAD IT THERE YOU GO ALRIGHT SO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TWO EIGHTY
NINE BUT CENTER ARCHULETA
WELCOME.
NICE ON THE AUDIENCE.
GET THE PODIUM THE WITNESSES GET
THE TABLE.
AND I SHOULD DIE I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THEY'RE ALL BEHIND ME.
THE WELCOME PLACE AGAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF HAD
AND MY COLLEAGUES SLATED AND
GENTLEMAN.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT -- SENATE
BILL -- TWO EIGHTY NINE I AM SO
PROUD HONOR TO PRESENT THIS
BECAUSE IT MEANS A LOT TO ME AND
ALL THE VETERANS.
WHO SERVED THIS GREAT COUNTRY --
IT PERTAINS TO CONSIDERING
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE
WHICH PERTAINS TO THE MEDI CAL
NINETEEN FIFTEEN SEAT WAIVER
PROGRAM.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK.
EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES VARIOUS
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT
SERVICES UNDER MEDICARE OUT
NINETEEN FIFTEEN C. WAIVER
PROGRAM.
THE SERVICES ENABLE INDIVIDUALS
MEMBERS OF MILITARY SERVICE
FAMILIES WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE
PLACED IN A LIVE IN FACILITY. TO
LIVE AT HOME WITH THEIR FAMILIES
AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS CAN
RECEIVE TRANSFER ORDERS AT ANY
TIME WHILE THEY'RE SERVING.
AND OFTENTIMES THESE ORDERS MOVE
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
RIGHT OUT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER CURRENT LAW WITH THIS MOVE
HAPPENS THE FAMILY LOSES THEIR
BENEFITS AND OR THE POSITION ON
THE WAITING LIST.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR FAMILIES
WHO PLAN TO RETURN TO CALIFORNIA
AFTER THEIR SERVICE BUT WHEN
THEIR ASSIGNMENT IS COMPLETED
AND FOR FILLED OUT OF STATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A FAMILY WOULD
HAVE TO RE RE APPLY FOR BENEFITS
UPON RETURNING TO CALIFORNIA AND
START ALL OVER AGAIN ON THE
MEDIC KILLED NINETEEN FIFTY SI
WAIVER PROGRAM.
AND THE WAITING LIST.
IN TURN THIS DELAY AND THE
DELAYS IT BECAUSE BY THIS -- IT
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE NEEDED
SERVICES.
AND THESE FAMILIES ARE THEY JUST
NEED TO GET BACK IN THE SYSTEM
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY LAW IN ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS UPON
RECEIVING ORDERS TO TRANSFER OUT
OF THE STATE. TO MAINTAIN THEIR
ELIGIBILITY STATUS AND ORDER
PLACED ON THE WAITING LIST.
THE ONLY REQUIREMENT IS THEY
MAINTAIN RESIDENCY IN CALIFORNIA.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE
WOULD ALLOW MILITARY PERSONNEL
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO APPLY FOR
THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN C. WAIVER.
PROGRAM WHEN THEY RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION OF THE PENDING
TRANSFER. TO THE STATE OR OUT OF
THE STATE.
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE WOULD NOT
HAVE A NEGATIVE EFFECT ON
FAMILIES CURRENTLY RECEIVING
SERVICES OR ON THE WAITING LIST
NOW.
INSTEAD IT WAS SHOULD REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT RESOURCES
REQUIRED OF THE STATE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR DEPENDENTS IN
THE SERVICE MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WILL INCLUDE
CALIFORNIA WITH THE OTHER THIRTY
FOUR STAGE THAT HAVE ALREADY
PASSED SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENSURE THESE
MUCH NEEDED BENEFITS REMAIN A
VIABLE OPTION FOR A MILITARY
FAMILIES WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO
SETTLE AND THRIVE DURING AND
AFTER THEIR MILITARY SERVICE.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS.
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL LAYS ON FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE STATE
LEADS ON OFFICE AS WELL AS NED
MECHANIC.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR OF
THE MARINE CORPS INSTALLATION
WEST TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND I
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
WITNESSES SUPPORT UP TO SIX
MINUTES BUT YOU CAN DO LESS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIRMAN STONE -- MY NAME IS
KELLY MAY DOUGLAS AND AS THE
SENATOR SAID I'M OF THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL LIAISON FOR A
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE WE COVER
QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUES -- FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS THEIR FAMILIES --
IN THE END I COVER THE THESE
FIVE STATES.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA -- THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY SUPPORT OF
SB -- TWO EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE
FOUND THAT INDIVIDUAL STATE
MEDICAID WAIVER ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND LENGTHY WAITING
LISTS HANDER MILITARY FAMILIES
FROM OBTAINING SOME SUPPLEMENTAL
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE DURING
CRITICAL PERIODS OF TRANSITION
INCLUDING WHEN THEY'RE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF THE
MILITARY.
WITH POTENTIALLY UNCERTAIN
MEDICAL COVERAGE AND GAPS IN
SERVICES.
ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA
OBTAINED FROM THE DEFENSE
MANPOWER DATA CENTER.
THERE ARE OVER ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DEPENDENTS
OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND OF THOSE DEPENDENT OUR
OF SERVICE MEMBERS WHO ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF SEPARATING FROM
SERVICE AND OR RETIRING AND ARE
LEGAL RESIDENTS OF THE STATE
[inaudible]
I ALSO AT TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
DOD COMMISSION SURVEY OF OVER
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND MILITARY
FAMILIES WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
FOUND THAT 16% OF MILITARY
MEMBERS WHO RESPONDED TO THE
SURVEY.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE A LOSS OF
THEIR WAIVER ELIGIBILITY
ENROLLMENT OR WAITING LIST
STATUS.
DUE TO A MILITARY MOVE 11% HAD
CHOSEN TO LIVE SEPARATELY FROM
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS DURING ON
ASSIGNMENTS -- FOR FEAR OF NOT
WANTING TO LOSE THEIR WAITED WE
WEAVER STATUS AND 71% HAVE
STATED THAT THEIR DECISION TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOME STATE AFTER
LEAVING THE MATCH THE MILITARY
SERVICE WAS INFLUENCED BY.
A DESIRE TO MAINTAIN THE WAIVER
STATUS FOR THEIR DEPENDENCE.
A MILITARY PARENT INTERVIEWED AS
PART OF A TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE WEST
VIRGINIA UNIVERSITY PROJECT TEAM
ENTITLED MEDICAID AND MILITARY
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS
ACCESSING MEDICAID AND WAVERED
SERVICES.
SEATED IF I DECIDE TO TAKE MY
CHILDREN WITH ME MY DAUGHTER
AUTOMATICALLY LOSES HER MEDICAID
WE ALREADY WENT THROUGH THE
AGONY OF WAITING SEVEN YEARS
UNTIL SHE GOT THE WAIVER NOW I
WOULD HAVE TO FACE EIGHT MORE
YEARS I MIGHT HAVE TO LEAVE MY
FAMILY BEHIND IT'S A CATCH.
TWENTY TWO SITUATION -- AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED SB -- THE
POLICY IN SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
DOES NOT CREATE A SPECIAL GROUP
OR PRIORITY PROGRAM -- AND DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE STATE TAKES
SPEND ANY RESOURCES TO HOLD
SLOTS FOR ME -- EMPTY FOR
MILITARY FAMILIES WHILE THEY'RE
OUT OF STATE IT WOULD ONLY BE --
INSTEAD PROVIDE THEM EITHER WITH
A CREDIT TOWARDS YEARS THAT
THEY'VE SPENT ON THE WAITING
LIST.
IF THERE IS ONE OR ALLOW
ELIGIBLE DEPENDENTS TO RESUME
SERVICES UPON RETURNING TO THE
STATE.
WITH THE WITH SPACE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING UP THIS
ISSUE FOR YOUR CAT AND A AND FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION WE SPECIALLY
THING SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR
SPONSORING THIS INITIATIVE.
OKAY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR I THANK YOU -- NET
BECAME THE MARINE CORPS
INSULATIONS WEST -- JUST A
COUPLE OF QUICK COMMENTS I'M
GONNA GIV -- ONE EXAMPLE IN
RECORD FAMILY IN THE STATES
THERE WAS ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES
FOR A CHILD WITH SERIOUS
DISABILITIES THEY WERE IN THE
STATE FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
TRANSFERRED OUT CAME BACK AFTER
THREE YEARS THEY HAD TO RE APPLY
FOR THE WAIVER -- WAITED SIX
YEARS BEFORE THE CHILD TURNED
EIGHTEEN GOT SERVICE ON HIS OWN
SO AN EXTRA FOUR AND A HALF YEAR
GAP.
AND IT'S TRYING TO MEET YOUR
RATE THOSE KINDS OF HARDSHIPS
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE BECAUSE OF
THEIR MOBILITY.
THEY WERE SEEKING TO FIX WITH SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SOME OF THE MICROPHONE.
A MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AND THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER
LEYVA -- CENTER ACTUALLY WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES I THINK THE THE
CHAIR AND IN MY COLLEAGUES AND I
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
AND THE MOTIONS BY CENTER LEYVA
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND I AND AYE STONE AYE STONE
AYE THE RAZA.
TORONTO I GROWTH.
GROWTH I HER TADO.
I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO HI.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES FOR THE
WHOLE THE ROLE OPEN TRAPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK RECALLING EXCELLENT
[inaudible]
THE PERSON [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO -- CENTER LEYVA YOU
PREPARED OKAY THANK YOU I I KNOW
YOU ARE BUT I JUST WANT TO ASK.
ALRIGHT SO.
SINCE CENTER BATES IS A I THINK
STOCK BY THE OTHER COMMITTEE
WILL -- WILL GO AHEAD WITH THE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB 24% -- LEYVA
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
RIGHT OVER THEM GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL MUCH APPRECIATED.
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS AS MANY OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER CIVIL OVER YOU SAW A
SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS BILL
LAST YEAR SB.
THREE TWENTY UNFORTUNATELY AFTER
PASSING BOTH HOUSES FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN VETO THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION SAYING
THAT STUDENTS HAVING TO TRAVEL A
GOOD DISTANCE OFF CAMPUS. TO
ACCESS MEDICATIONABORTION IS
NOT UNREASONABLE.
AS A WOMAN AND AS A LEGISLATOR
THAT STRONGLY BELIEVES IN THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT
TO ACCESSIBLE OR XIN I BOTH
RESPECTFULLY AND PROFOUNDLY
DISAGREE.
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES BEFORE
THIS ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
COUNTLESS UC AND CSU STUDENTS
BUT I WILL NOT REST UNTIL
BECOMES LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS SB TWENTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE ALL ON CAMPUS STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION FOR EARLY PREGNANCY
TERMINATION FOR THEIR STUDENTS
BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ACCORDING TO
THE GUTTMACHER INSTITUTE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES.
HAVE TERMINATED EARLY
PREGNANCIES THROUGH THE USE OF
MEDICATION ABORTION AND TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WOMEN AGE
TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR ACCOUNTED
434% OF ABORTIONS.
THE LARGEST FOR ANY AGE GROUP
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A TWO
STEP PROCESS WHERE A PATIENT
TAKES TWO SETS OF PILLS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO DAYS DURING THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO A UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY MEDICATION ABORTION IS
VERY SAFE WITH MAJOR
COMPLICATIONS OCCURRING AND ONLY
ZERO POINT 3% OF CASES.
WHICH IS LESS THAN TYLENOL AND
BY AGRA.
IN A MOMENT YOU WILL HEAR MORE
FROM DANIEL GROSSMAN A CLINICAL
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCHER ON
ABORTION AND CONTRACEPTION.
WHO WILL FURTHER DISCUSS SOME OF
THIS IMPORTANT RESEARCH?
THOUGH MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS PREGNANCY
OPTIONS COUNSELING AND
CONTRACEPTIVES.
NONE CURRENTLY OFFER ACCESS TO
MEDICATION ABORTION ON CAMPUS
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND IS CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAT MUCH OF THE CARE
ALREADY OFFERED A COLLEGE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS.
SUCH AS DIABETES MANAGEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE ANDDIAGNOSIS
SLASH TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES.
IF A STUDENT HAS TO GO OFF
CAMPUS. TO FIND A PROVIDER THAT
DOES NOT ACCEPT THEIR STUDENT OR
OTHER HEALTH PRIVATE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE PAYING FOR
MEDICATION ABORTION MAY BE A
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDEN.
IN TOTAL TWENTY TWO UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES ARE MORE THAN THIRTY
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE CLOSEST
ABORTION PROVIDER VIA PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
THIS CARE REQUIRES TWO TRIPS TO
A HEALTH CLINIC MEANING TWO
HOURS OF TOTAL TRAVEL TIME.
THESE BURGERS OR WORSENED SINCE
ONLY 15% OF THE CLOSEST OFF
CAMPUS ABORTION PROVIDERS ARE
OPEN ON WEEKENDS BEING THAT
STUDENTS MAY HAVE TO MISS CLASS
MISS EXAMS.
AND WORK TO ACCESSIBLE OPTION
WHICH THE SUPREME COURT HAS
DETERMINED TO BE A PROTECTED
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE WOMEN MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY'RE PREGNANT TO THE FIFTH OR
SIXTH WEEK OF PREGNANCY.
MEMBERS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ISN'T JUST A SLOGAN BUT RATHER A
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE TRUE
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS AT
UC'S AND SEE ISSUES.
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AS DR DANIEL CRESSMAN
PROFESSOR AND DIRECTOR OF
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND JUST THE WAS ALL AS A RECENT
GRADUATE OF UC RIVERSIDE I WILL
DEFER TO MY WITNESSES MISTER
CHAIR.
I THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA WITH
THE SUPPORT OF BETWEEN THE TWO
OF YOU SIX MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
AS SENATOR LABOR MENTION I
DIRECT ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE PUBLISHED TWO
STUDIES IN PEER REVIEWED
JOURNALS RELATED TO THE COLLEGE
STUDENT RIGHT TO ACCESS ACT.
THE FIRST LOOKED AT HOW OFTEN
STUDENTS SEEK ABORTION CARE AND
WHETHER THEY FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE THIRTY FOUR
UC AND CSU CAMPUSES OBTAIN
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
THIRTY EIGHT ABORTIONS EACH
MONTH.
WE ESTIMATE THAT AS MANY AS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO TO
FIVE HUNDRED NINETEEN MEDICATION
ABORTIONS WOULD BE PROVIDED
MONTHLY ON CAMPUSES.
IF STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS
OFFERED THE SERVICE.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT ACROSS ALL
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES
CONSIDERING THAT THE SERVICE
REQUIRES TWO VISITS THE MEDIAN
TIME BY PUBLIC TRANSPORT TO THE
CLOSEST PROVIDER IS AN AVERAGE
OF TWO HOURS ROUND TRIP FOR
MEDICATION PORTION.
AND UP TO FOUR HOURS FOR
STUDENTS ON SOME CAMPUSES.
THE STUDENTS HAVE A LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES DO NOT HAVE
A CAR ON CAMPUS AND MUST RELY ON
PUBLIC TRANSPORT TRANSPORT IN
ORDER TO GET TO THESE VISITS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA CODE
OF REGULATIONS TRAVELING MORE
THAN THIRTY MINUTES FOR HEALTH
CARE RENDERS THAT CARE IN
ACCESSIBLE.
GIVEN THESE FINDINGS I BELIEVE
THAT ABORTION KAREN CAMPUS IS
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND
DECREASED BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS.
FOR THE SECOND STUDY WE STUDY
THE CAPACITY OF STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS TO PROVIDE MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS AND WHAT THEY
WOULD NEED IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE.
ALL UC AND CSU STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES THE
EMPLOYEE OR CONTRACTED WITH AT
LEAST ONE PHYSICIAN AND OR
ADVANCED PRACTICE CONDITION --
THEY HAVE THE NEEDED PHYSICAL
SPACE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THE
SERVICES THEY WOULD ALL NEED
TRAINING -- IF NEEDED ULTRASOUND
MACHINE IF THAT'S NEEDED TO
DETERMINE THE TRUSTEE TIONAL AGE
TO TO DATE THE PREGNANCIES.
SOME SOME OF THEM WOULD NEED
TWENTY FOUR HOUR TELEPHONE
SUPPORT TO TRIAGE SERVICES IF
THAT'S NOT ALREADY AVAILABLE.
TAKING A RESEARCH INTO ACCOUNT
ALONG WITH WHAT THE SENATOR LIVE
ALREADY.
SAID ABOUT HER MEDICATION
ABORTION HAS BEEN CLEARLY PROVEN
TO BE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE IN
CLINICALLY SIMPLE TO PROVIDE.
I BELIEVE THAT WITH THE FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN COMMITTED IT WOULD
BE VERY FEASIBLE TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION AT STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS.
THERE'S REALLY NO REASON IC TO
EXCLUDE MEDICATION ABORTION FROM
THE SERVICES THAT ARE ALREADY
PROVIDED AT STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
MY NAME IS JUST YOUR SALAS AND I
AM A CAMPUS COORDINATOR -- WITH
THE JUST CARE CAMPAIGN AT THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THE JUST CARE CAMPAIGN MOBILIZES
STUDENTS TO EXPAND REPRODUCTIVE
EQUITY ON CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
THIS INCLUDES LIFTING BARRIERS
TO ABORTION CARE.
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR IS
DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ME.
EVERY MONTH AS DOCTOR COSSMAN
ALREADY SHARED HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR CAMPUSES
FOR ABORTION CARE.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET
AT THE ON CAMPUS STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS.
JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
I WAS ONE OF THE STUDENTS.
IN MY THIRTY YEAR AT UC
RIVERSIDE I DISCOVERED I WAS
PREGNANT.
AS MY DOCTOR AT MY STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER WENT OVER MY
OPTIONS I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO
GET AN ABORTION.
BECAUSE I COULDN'T GET MY
ABORTION ON MY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER I WAS FORCED TO NAVIGATE
CUMBERSOME CONFUSING REFERRALS
TO OFFSITE CLINICS THAT
ULTIMATELY DELAYED.
MY CARE FOR THREE MONTHS.
DURING WHICH IT BECAME
INCREASINGLY MORE DIFFICULT TO
LIVE MY LIFE.
AS A WOMAN OF COLOR.
CHILD OF IMMIGRANTS AND LOW
INCOME STUDENT I DID NOT
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE
TO NAVIGATE THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
OR INSURANCE POLICIES.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
GET THE CARE I NEEDED OFF CAMPUS
SUCH AS MONEY.
AND A CAR.
AND THIS IS JUST MY STORY.
ONCE A STUDENT HAS DECIDED TO
END A PREGNANCY THEY SHOULDN'T
BE FORCED TO GO OFF CAMPUS TO
SEE A PROVIDER THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE CARECAN EASILY BE
PROVIDED ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
LEAVING CAMPUS CAN MEAN TAKING
AWAY TIME FROM CLASS AN
INTERNSHIP FAMILY TIME OR YOUR
JOB.
IT CAN BE HARD TO RAISE THE
MONEY OR FIND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION TO A FARAWAY
CLINIC -- OFFERING ABORTION CARE
ON CAMPUS HELPS TO ENSURE THESE
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE TO ALL
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT NEED THEM AND
IT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD
ACHIEVING TRUE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AND EQUITY FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
RIGHT -- WITNESSES OTHER --
WITNESSES SUPPORT AT THE BANK
MICROPHONE PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND I ASSUME
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT BUT YOU CAN
SAY GO AHEAD AND SAY THAT.
WELCOME HERE IN MEMBERS ROXY IN
GOLD REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ANGIE MINETTI REPRESENTING
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
STRONG BE HALF OF THE OVER
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MILEY'S AT ALL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M IDEAS LEBRON OF THELEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GEN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT YOU.
KAREN HUMPHREY NATIONAL WOMEN'S
POLITICAL CAUCUS OF CALIFORNIA
IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OBGYN THIS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAKE AN ORIGAMI HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VARYING UC DAVIS MEDICAL STUDENT
IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
MOLLY COHEN WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A LIVE
A HANSON I'M A STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY AND I STAND WITH
STUDENTS UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE -- THE FOUNDERS OF THIS
BILL AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MAYBE DAVIS A RECENT GRADUATE
OF UC BERKELEY A MEMBER OF
STUDENTS UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN I WAS IN OFTEN GOT ME AS
SOON IN THE UC BERKELEY AND WITH
THE SINS OF THE STUDENTS UNITED
REPAIR OF JUSTICE AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAPTION FINAL OF UC BERKELEY IS
ON SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
A SUMMIT SEALS DIDN'T SACKS
STATE FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WITH ACT FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RUTH SO SIDE GO TO
SAKS STATE I'M FROM TULARE
COUNTY AM FROM ACTFROM ONE AND
I'M WITH ACTOR MONNING GIRLS AS
WELL.
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME DRAWS ON THE GUYS
MINOR FROM BY TELLY CALIFORNIA
TO THEIR COUNTY -- I SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN NAME YOUR WITH
ACTOR MEANING.
THANK YOU.
HI SIR HUTCHINSON WITH ACT FOR
WOMEN GIRLS A CO SPONSOR AND
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOCTOR MEANT TO LET ME DO AN
ABORTION PROVIDER UC DAVIS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NO ALL JONES I'M A
STUDENT CO SPONSOR I'M
REPRESENTING STUDENTS UNITED
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAISY THIRD YEAR
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KAREN WHAT IS ALL THE MEDICAL
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DIANA HOW FOURTH YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT THE CITY OF A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I MILLENNIA BUT A HAS A GRADUATE
OF UC SANTA CRUZ IN A PART OF
ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH JUSTICE
AND I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER.
THANK YOU.
RACHEL HELLO WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE CO SPONSORED WE
URGE I THOUGHT THANK YOU.
CAN YOU PUT IT ALL ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I'M KATHLEEN SAYING GRADUATE OF
UC BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY SON FRANCO CALIFORNIA ****
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE PALCO
SPONSORING STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PHILIP BURLINGAME WITH THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
SHE LED TINY RESIDENT POSITION
EASIEST FAILING -- MEDICAL
CENTER AND ALSO A UCLA GRAD IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MERCY INVOLVES ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WESLEY NHNG WITH A FINE HOW
THE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
INITIATION AT UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
LAW AND STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL NG WITH UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA A. S.
HUMAN RIGHTS PORT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM A STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA AND INSTALL
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI THERE GREECE PAYING -- FROM
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
LIVVIE BENEDICT PROUD UCLA BRUIN
CLASSES SEVENTY SIX IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIFFANY DANG STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
PHOEBE ABRAMOWITZ WESTON'S
UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
AT BERKELEY CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
FRANK HERNANDEZ STUDENT AT MILLS
COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FELIPE AVAILABLE STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LOSE JACOBSON STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'M CHERYL **** STUDENT UC DAVIS
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I AM SEVEN A WRITER I'M USING A
UC DAVIS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORTS
BILL THANK YOU.
WE KIND OF MARTY MEDICAL STUDENT
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AN ALUMNI OF CAL POLY SLOW AND
UC DAVIS INSTRUCTS PART GIVE.
HI MY NAME IS SANTIAGO JOB A
LAMB A GRADUATE OF UC SANTA CRUZ
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS COMMON OPTION
WHICH COOPER AND I'M STERN AT
THE REST OF CONFERENCE HOW
BARBARA AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TOM STILL CULTURE OF UCSB LOBBY
CORPS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'M MORE SHY STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
AND FOUNDE OF THE STUDENTS
REPRODUTIVE FREEDOM IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAKE WHEN I HUMAN RIGHTS BOARD
EASY SANTA BARBARA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEARN LOWER STUDENTS
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AT UC DAVIS
IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
TERESA ROMAN FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A MOMENT ALL THE TOLL FREE FROM
UC SANTA BARBARA AND STUDENTS
GET SEXUAL SOUL AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAISY ARIANNA UC SANTA CRUZ GRAD
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
SO A MURRAY STUDENT OF UC SANTA
BARBARA AND ALSO PART OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
W. LOLZ PARTITIVE SINCE PREPARE
JUSTICE AYE ECS PIECE INSTRUCT
THE PART THANK YOU.
WIENER MALIK WITH STUDENTS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AT UC SANTA
BARBARA AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M RIVER ELIZABETH CHRIS WALT
ORDAINED CHRISTIAN MINISTER WITH
PARKS I COMMUNITY CHURCH UNITED
CHURCH OF CHRIST.
ALSO A UCLA GRAD TWO THOUSAND
AND SOMEONE WHO HAS USED THIS
MEDICATION I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CASPER CONCUR WITH THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY FOUNDATION FUTURE UC
STUDENT INSTRUCTS APART.
ELIZABETH KALYANI ON WITH PLAN
PARA GENERATION ACTION AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ISABEL ABOUT TEASE THE FROM UC
SANTA BARBARA WITH THE HUMAN
RIGHTS BOARD AND STUDENTS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
THANK YOU. TO BE A MAN CHIU
STUDENT FROM UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE AND APART
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD GENERATION
ACTION I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERICA CASEY I'M A
STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
EMILY ESCOBAR WITH THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY FOUNDATION AND RECENT
CAL STATE LONG BEACH GRADUATE
REBEL UC DAVIS LAW STUDENT OF
FORMER UC SANTA CRUZ STUDENT AND
PART OF IT IF NGUYEN HOW LAW
STUDENTS FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AT UC DAVIS.
I SUPPORT THE SPELL.
PM THERE ARE YOU UC RIVERSIDE
STERN I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AFTER YOUSEF AND
I'M A UC BERKELEY STUDENT A PART
OF THE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
COMMISSION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M EMMA CLIO HERE WITH
STUDENTS UNITED FOR REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE I UC BERKELEY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M CRISTINA TANGUAY STUDENTS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AT UC SANTA
BARBARA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HANNAH HELL AND
I'M A STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI THERE AMBER ARE THERE FROM
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO IT IS ALL OF US GUESTS THE
FROM UC BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
INTUIT TURBO WITH PUMP IN A
GENERATION ACTION AT RIVERSIDE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY LEASE STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE ALSO PART OF PLAN HAD
A PET.
CAMPAIGN INTO GENERATION AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AND NOW I'M DATING MYSELF CLASS
OF THREEIN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI SHANNON HOVIS NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA WE ARE CLOSE
FUNDS ON THE BILL STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI BE A V. -- EIGHT WITH THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA --
SPONSOR OF THE BUILDING STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARCH PLUM REPRESENTING THE
FUNDERS FOR SB TWENTY FOUR
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CASEY NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONES -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COME UP TO THE TABLE HERE.
SENATOR PIANO OKAY UNIVERSE JUST
CALIFORNIA -- HERE JUST TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND WE'RE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSED TO
SO WE'RE WE'RE HERE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS OKAY.
WIENER ALL RIGHT WINGERS.
OKAY YOUR BILL FOR QUESTIONS I
MAY HAVE SOME FOR YOU LATER OKAY
WILL.
ALSO SEE OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT.
BEFORE WE BEGIN YES.
THERE'S ANOTHER PERSON TO MAKE
FUN.
YES.
I MEAN TAKEN AWAY AYE MAGGIE
WHITE WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SIGNED IT TO BRIEFLY
SAY WE CURRENTLY HAVE A PENDING
POSITION ON THE BILL.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS OF THE BILL WHICH
PRIMARILY INVOLVED
IMPLEMENTATION ON GOING COSTS.
I EXCITED TO SEE A POSSIBLE
MINUTES COMING THROUGH FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THOSE IN PRINT AND
JUST ONE EXPRESS OUR THANKS FOR
THE ON GOING DIALOGUE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING IT THANK
YOU.
OKAY SO THAT'S A TWEENER.
EIGHT AT THE DEMEANOR THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT.
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT CELL PHONE
AND YOU HAVE. TO TO BE ALRIGHT
SO YOU HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES
THANK YOU WELCOME [inaudible]
RIGHT RIGHT [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S.
ARE YOU THAT DID YOU I JUST
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT I'M OPPOSED
OKAY ALRIGHT WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM THE
WITNESSES ARE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS TRACK
POSITION AFTER THEIR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SURE THE INTERRUPTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARY
LEE SHRIDER I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF RIGHT TO LIFE OF
KERN COUNTY AND POLITICAL
ADVOCACY CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIANS
FOR LIFE. FOR THE TWO YEARS IT
TOOK SB THREE TWENTY TO MAKE ITS
WAY THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WE WERE TOLD THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WAS TO
ENSURE IMMEDIATE ACCESS FOR
PREGNANT STUDENTS. TO MEDICATION
ABORTION OSTENSIBLY TO LIMIT
TIME AWAY FROM ACADEMIC PURSUITS.
THE RESURRECTED VERSION WE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT TODAY SB TWENTY
FOUR IS A COPY OF ITS
PREDECESSOR ERRONEOUS ASSERTIONS
AND ALL.
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON SB THREE
TWENTY FOCUSED ON STUDENTS
ALLEGED IMPEDIMENTS TO ABORTIONS
AND UNIVERSITIES RELATED COSTS
AND LIABILITY CONCERNS.
HOWEVER AT NO TIME.
HAS ANYONE POSE THE MOST
RELEVANT QUESTION IS MEDICATION
ABORTION THE MOST EFFECTIVE
METHOD. TO MEET SB TWENTY FOUR
STATED GOALS.
RESEARCH AND RECOMMENDATIONS BY
RECOGNIZED X. EXPERTS IN OF
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY
STRONGLY INDICATE IT IS NOT.
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE OF SB THREE
TWENTY GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
DISMISSED THE BILL AS A
NECESSARY BUT HE WAS ONLY HALF
RIGHT.
MEDICATION ABORTIONS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARE NOT ONLY
UNNECESSARY THEY ARE CONTRA
INDICATED.
MY COLLEAGUE HERE WILL SPEAK
FURTHER ON THAT BUT AS I SAID SB
TWENTY FOUR LIKE IT'S
PREDECESSOR CONTAINS RONI'S
INFORMATION.
AND FAILS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY BOTH LIFE ADVOCATES
AND THE UNIVERSITIES.
PROPONENTS OF LAST YEAR'S SB
THREE TWENTY ASSERTED THAT
STUDENTS SEEKING EARLY PREGNANCY
TERMINATION OFTEN FACE HOURS OF
TRAVEL FROM THE CAMPUS CITY
COUNTY OR EVEN GEOGRAPHIC REGION.
THIS NOTION WAS SO THOROUGHLY
DEBUNKED THAT IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE GOVERNOR BROWN CITED THE
ACTUAL AVERAGE DISTANCE BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE FUNDED
UNIVERSITIES AND THEIR NEAREST
MEDICAL ABORTION PROVIDERS.
OF ONLY SIX MILES YET SOMEHOW
THE RONI'S LANGUAGE APPEARS
AGAIN IN SB.
TWENTY FOUR YOU FIND ADDITIONAL
EXAMPLES OF STILL ON ADDRESS
CONCERNS ON PAGE FOR THE REPORT
YOU HOPEFULLY HAVE THE FOR YOU.
OUR GREATEST CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL IS IT'S INDIFFERENCE TO THE
SERIOUS ADVERSE AFFECTS
ASSOCIATED WITH MEDICATION
ABORTION USE.
SINCE APPROVING MIFEPRISTONE IN
TWO THOUSAND THE US FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION AS
ADMINISTRATION REPORTED MORE
THAN.
ONE THOUSAND A SKEWS ME REPORTED
MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND CASES OF
SERIOUS ADVERSE EVENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DRUG.
OF THOSE MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
WOMEN REQUIRED HOSPITALIZATIONS
INCLUDING FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT TO EXPERIENCE BLOOD LOSS
SO SEVERE THEY REQUIRE
TRANSFUSIONS.
AND A TWENTY SEVENTEEN SUMMER
THE FDA ALSO REPORTS THAT TWENTY
TWO WOMEN HAVE DIED AFTER USING
THE DRUG.
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT BEFORE
YOU IS A LEGAL OPINION OF THE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY AND EXPENSE
OF UNIVERSITIES WILL FACE IF SB.
TWENTY FOUR IT'S PAST IN SUMMARY
THE OPINION FINDS THERE'S NO
CONSIDERATION IN THE BILL FOR
POTENTIAL LIABILITY EXPOSURES.
AND OTHER EXPENSES THAT CLINICS
MAKER SHOULD SB TWENTY FOUR
BECOME LAW.
IT ALSO FINDS IT'S COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY TO REQUIRE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
THAT CREATES SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
INJURY OR EVEN DEATH.
COMMITTEE WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO TO VOTE NO ON SB
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR HELLO.
MY NAME IS MONICA SNYDER AND I'M
ONE OF THE ATHEISTS WHO CO LEADS
THE GROUP SECULAR PRO LIFE.
IRON MY BACHELORS FROM UC
BERKELEY IN TWENTY ELEVEN AND MY
MASTER'S FROM UC DAVIS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND I'M HERE TO
TALK VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SB.
TWENTY FOUR ADMINISTRATORS
INDICATED SB TWENTY FOUR IS NOT
ONLY UNNECESSARY BUT ALSO
CONTRAINDICATED.
IN SENATOR LATEST PRESS RELEASE
REGARDING THIS BILL SHOULD
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF TIMELY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE AND
ABORTION CARE WITHOUT DELAY.
BUT IT'S UNCLEAR HOW SB TWENTY
FOUR WOULD ACCOMPLISH THESE
GOALS BECAUSE MEDICATION
ABORTION IS NOT.
TIMELY.
EVEN IF OFFER DIRECTLY ON CAMPUS
MEDICATION ABORTION IS MORE TIME
CONSUMING GENERALLY THAN OFF
CAMPUS SURGICAL ABORTIONS
SURGICAL ABORTION TYPICALLY
REQUIRES A SINGLE APPOINTMENT
WITH NO FOLLOW UP.
MEDICATION ABORTION USUALLY
REQUIRES A FIRST APPOINTMENT TO
RECEIVE MIFEPRISTONE IN MICE
ACOSTA ALL AND TIME SET ASIDE IN
THE DAY OR TWO AFTER TO ENJOY
THE BLEEDING CRAMPING KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPULSION OF THE EMBRYO.
AND THEN A FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENT
DAYS OR WEEKS LATER TO ENSURE A
COMPLETE ABORTION.
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGIST
ORGANIZATION OF OVER FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND OBGYN WHICH SUPPORTS
ABORTION RIGHTS.
EXPLAINS THE MEDICATION ABORTION
QUOTE TAKES LONGER TO COMPLETE
REQUIRES MORE ACTIVE PATIENT
PARTICIPATION AND IS ASSOCIATED
WITH HIGHER REPORTED RATES OF
BLEEDING AND CRAMPING AND QUOTE.
IF THE MEDICATION ABORTION IS
UNSUCCESSFUL THE WOMAN WILL NEED
TO EITHER DO OR THE PROCESS
AGAIN OR RECEIVE SURGICAL FOLLOW
UP.
AND MEDICATION ABORTIONS ARE
FREQUENTLY UNSUCCESSFUL FTA
GUIDELINES STATE MEDICATION
ABORTION CAN BE OFFERED UP TO
TEN WEEKS INTO PREGNANCY BUT THE
EFFICACY RATE DECREASES AS THE
PREGNANCY PROGRESSES.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN MEDICATION
ABORTION AT NINE WEEKS HAVING
EFFICACY RATE AS LOW AS 85%.
MEANING THAT UP TWO OR MORE THAN
ONE OUT OF SEVEN WOMEN AT THAT
STAGE WOULD NEED SURGICAL FOLLOW
UP THERE'S NOTHING TIMELY ABOUT
THAT PROCESS.
GIVEN HOW COMMON IT IS FOR WOMEN
WHO SEEK MEDICATION ABORTION TO
REQUIRE SURGICAL FOLLOW UP.
FDA GUIDELINES AND CALIFORNIA
REQUIRE THAT MEDICATION ABORTION
PROVIDERS.
QUOTE MUST ALSO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ANY NECESSARY SURGICAL
INTERVENTION OR HAVE MADE A
RANGERS FOR OTHERS TO PROVIDE
SUCH CARE AND QUOTE.
SO UNLESS THE UNIVERSITY HEALTH
CENTER START PROVIDING SURGICAL
ABORTION ON SITE.
THEY WILL NEED TO PARTNER OFTEN
WITH THE SAME FACILITIES THAT
THE BILL'S SPONSORS ADJUSTER TO
DISTANT -- AN ACCESSIBLE FOR
THIS PATIENT POPULATION.
GIVEN ON AVERAGE ABORTION
PROVIDERS ARE ABOUT SIX MILES
FROM OUR CAMPUS UNIVERSITIES THE
BILL IS A NECESSARY BUT GIVEN
THE TIME CONSUMING NATURE OF
MEDICATION ABORTION THE BILL
SEEMS CONTRADICTORY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
BILL'S SPONSORS GIVE A MORE
COMPELLING RATIONALE THAT WOULD
JUSTIFY MANDATING.
THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES TAKE ON
THESE RESPONSIBILITIES EXPENSES
AND LIABILITIES THANK THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
OKAY THANK YA THINK BOTH SIDES
FOR KEEPING THE TIME --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION -- NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
THAT BY LIKE PHONE.
BRIAN BRECHT ME UC SANTA BARBARA
CLASS OF NINETEEN EIGHTY IN
OPPOSITION.
IT HAS TO BE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR AB PRICHARD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TULARE KINGS RIGHT
TO LIFE RECORD ARE REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN THOSE TWO
COUNTIES.
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
ALEXANDRA SNYDER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LIFE LEGAL DEFENSE
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RACHEL HEARING.
AT CAL STATE [inaudible]
LONG BEACH.
REPRESENTING US.
STUDENTS. FOR LIFE.
IN STE.
DONNA POSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TO MICAH BASSMAN
THE CURRENT CO PRESIDENT OF
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AT UC BERKELEY
STRONGLY OPPOSING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M COMEL CISNEROS PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COORDINATOR
WAS STUDENTS FOR LIFE
REPRESENTING OVER NINETY STUDENT
GROUPS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JONATHAN CHAVEZ STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THERESA MCILVAINE IRAQ ATHEIST
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS FOUNDER PRO
LIFE SAN FRANCISCO REPRESENTING
THEM TODAY IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH HAGEN REPRESENTING FEAR
PREGNANCY AND HEALTH I TO HAVE
UTILIZED MEDICATION ABORTION AT
LEAST THE FIRST HALF.
YOUR YOU FORTY SIX ABORTION
HELLO NAME IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CARE WILL **** EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR SIR PREGNANCY AND
HEALTH AND I'M IN A POSITION TO
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD SOCIAL
MEDIA COORDINATOR FOR PRO LIFE
SENTENCES GO AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOHN DIRTY WITH RIGHT TO LIFE IS
SUCH A CALIFORNIA AND FRESNO ON
BEHALF OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
SUPPORTERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
JULIA CLAIR POTTER FRESNO STATE
SINCE FOR LIFE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
RICHARD MORRISON -- FRESNO STATE
SOON FOR LIFE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
JOHN SPEROS IN OUR REPRESENTS
STUDENTS FOR LIFE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CLARENCE LOUIS ST MARY'S
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN VACAVILLE UC
DAVIS GRAD WE ARE STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HARLEY HOW WITH ST MERRY'S OF
VACAVILLE AND RESPECT FOR LIFE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BREAK BIRD WITH A CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNSELING OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JUST CARRIER HAS
I'M A PARENT INCIDENT AT FRESNO
STATE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AS FAR AS I OF RECENT RECENT
PRESENTS TO GRADUATE AND I'M
ALSO A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT.
AND I'M AN EMPLOYEE OF RIGHT TO
LIFE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AN OF OUR QUESTIONS FOR LIFE OF
AMERICA REPRESENTING TWELVE
HUNDRED STUDENT GROUPS
NATIONALLY.
UP IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
RICKY SILVER FROM GILROY
PRESIDENT OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE
IT SOUNDS THE STATE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
W. R. I'M PUBLIC RELATIONS
OFFICER OF STUDENTS FLIGHTS IN
AS A STATE AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARIA JOSE FERNANDEZ FLOORS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CURRENT HAND FROM UC DAVIS AND
NINE POSTS.
THANK YOU.
WHEN IT SETTLES DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE WITH
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ISSUE FROM BAKERSFIELD WHO
HAS ANY SAY CAL POLY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
M. FRANCIS WITH BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO LIFE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
NORMALLY I GET IT FROM HER THEIR
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOU ALL TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL ALSO
STUDENT FOR FOR THE STATE.
JONATHAN KELLER PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY ALLIANCE I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE RESPECTFUL DIALOG
CHAIRMAN.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
DISCUSSION AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ROSEMARY INTO HELLO.
OUR OUR IN. THIRTY SEVEN YEARS.
TWENTY FOUR YEARS IN LABOR AND
DELIVERY.
AND ARE FIVE YEARS AS A COLLEGE
NURSE AND FIVE YEARS DOING
LITTLE THE ULTRASOUND ON FIRST
TRIMESTER PATIENTS.
TAKE THIS BILL OUTTA HERE THIS
IS.
A STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BASED ON ALL THOSE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK.
IF THEY HAVE A FEW FOR THE
PERSONS WHO WHO -- SAID THAT
THEY COULD ANSWER OKAY WELL WHAT
WOULD I TELL YOU WE HAVE
WITNESSED HERE WHEN WE GET
QUESTIONS.
THIS IS THE THE DAY SO WHAT
WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU GOOD SEEING
YOU AGAIN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO -- QUESTIONS.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF THE JOB OF YES -- CENTER
GROVE YOUR QUESTION YES SIR OKAY
YES SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MISS LEYVA FRANCINE ON THE
QUESTIONS -- SO BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
REGARDING THE FUNDING I REALIZE
THAT THERE'S A PRIVATE FUNDING
AVAILABLE ABOUT TEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS BUT AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DO YOU KNOW HOW THE
SPENDING IS GONNA.
BE IMPLEMENTED IF YOU DO CAN YOU
LET ME KNOW IF NOT IF IT'S AN
ONGOING THING I NEED TO KNOW
THAT AS WELL.
AND THEN ALSO IF YOU CAN ANSWER
THE SAME FUNDING QUESTION.
BASED ON THE INFORMATION AND
THAT THE WITNESS I APOLOGIZE AND
I REMEMBER YOUR NAME MA'AM.
MONICA THAT MONICA PROVIDED
ABOUT THE DATA.
ABOUT FOLLOW UPS ABOUT A
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SURGICAL PROCEDURES
AFTERWARDS -- IS THAT GONNA BE
PART OF THAT FUNDING AND IF SO.
HOW'S IT GOING TO CONTINUE INTO
PERPETUITY I GUESS VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION A
PUBLIC DR GROSSMAN ANSWER THE
SECOND QUESTION -- ABOUT -- THAT
THAT HOW OFTEN IT IS ACTUALLY
NOT DOES NOT WORK BUT INCOME
RESPONSE YOUR QUESTION SB.
TWENTY FOUR AIMS TO PROVIDE
PRIVATE GROUNDS FOR THE COST OF
EACH STUDENT HEALTH CENTER TO BE
READY FOR THIS SERVICE.
BUT IS NOT PRESCRIPTIVE AND HELP
EACH STUDENT HEALTH CENTER
DECIDES TO FIND IT ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THE SERVICE SHOULD BE PROVIDED
AND FUNDED IN THE WAY THAT ALL
OTHER HEALTH SERVICES ARE PAID.
FOR JUST BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ABORTION DOESN'T MEAN IT
SHOULD BE TREATED ANY
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY OTHER
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PROVIDED ANY
OF THE HEALTH CARE STUDENTS.
CENTERS -- UC'S ALREADY.
USE THE STUDENT INSURANCE AND
THE HEALTH OF SEE ISSUES BILL
MEDI CAL FOR FAMILY PACK SO THIS
WOULD BE THE SAME AS WHAT
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING.
THANK YOU YOU WELCOME.
DR CHRISTIAN.
I'M JUST BRIEFLY IN TERMS OF HOW
EFFECTIVE MEDICATION ABORTION IS
ABOUT 95298% EFFECTIVE IF YOU
LOOK A THE LABELING FOR MISTER
PROXIMATE SUPPRESSED ON IT SAYS
ABOUT. TWO AND A HALF PERCENT OF
WOMEN WHO USE THIS TREATMENT UP
TO TEN WEEKS WILL NEED TO HAVE
AN ASPIRATION PROCEDURE -- ME AS
A PROVIDER I CAN SAY THAT.
USUALLY WHEN WHEN A PATIENT USES
HER INSURANCE THAT SHE PAYS THE
INSURANCE COVERS ALL THE
SERVICES INCLUDING THE CASE OF
NEEDING AN ASPIRATION ALSO IN
CASES WHEN A PATIENT SELF PAYS
FOR THE PROCEDURE SHE DOESN'T
PAY ANYMORE.
IF SHE NEEDS TO HAVE A SO THE
ASPIRATION PROCEDURE DONE.
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS A TWO MORE QUESTIONS I
APOLOGIZE -- STUDENT HELP
PHYSICIANS OR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THAT TEND TO WORK
IN THESE CLINICS ARE FACILITIES
THAT ARE ON CAMPUS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BASED ON
DATA THAT THEY HAVE LITTLE
EXPERIENCE IN JUDGING JUST
STATION ONLY EACH AND THIS --
BASED ON YOUR OWN TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY THAT THE JUST STATION
LATER THIS PILL THAT IS TAKEN.
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN.
BETWEEN EIGHT TO TEN WEEKS OF
JUST STATION -- THE AUTHORS ON
STATEMENT MOST WOMEN DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY'RE PREGNANT FOR FORTY
FIVE WEEKS.
AND THAT PUTS YOU AT FOUR TO
FIVE WEEKS AND THE BILL HAS TO
BE TAKEN WITHIN EIGHT TO TEN
WEEKS.
AND SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
WHO'S GOING TO JUDGE THE JUST
STATION ONLY AGE -- BUT I KNOW
IT'S DONE BY PELICAN EXAM
USUALLY OR ALTER SOUND OR THEIR
OLDER SOME FACILITY --
ULTRASOUND EQUIPMENT ON THESE
CAMPUSES [inaudible]
AND A WHO IS A IN D. WHO'S GONNA
JUDGE THE JUST STATION ONLY EACH
OF THE BABY GREAT QUESTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO EACH CAMPUS
WILL BE PROVIDED WITH TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET
THEIR HEALTH CENTERS UP AND
RUNNING WHAT WE FOUND WE FIRST
INTRODUCED THIS BILL.
IS THAT OUR HEALTH CENTERS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE AT C. ISSUES
AND UC'S RANGING FROM A LITTLE.
A LITTLE CLOSET AND YOU GO IN
AND SAY HELLO HERE'S AN ASPIRIN
GOOD WILL AND GOT SPEED TO FULL
BLOWN BEAUTIFUL MEDICAL CENTERS
THAT'S WHY WE ORIGINALLY MADE
THE BILL A TO YOUR BILL SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
FUNDING.
SO WE CAN GET EVERY CAMPUS UP
AND RUNNING BECAUSE EACH CAMPUS
WILL NEED TO HAVE A SONOGRAM
MACHINE SO THAT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT WILL BE PROVIDED
TO EACH CAMPUS WILL BE FOR THAT.
ADDITIONALLY EACH UCC EACH
SYSTEM WILL BE PROVIDED WITH TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE
WHAT WE HEARD IS THAT THEY WANT
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR HOTLINE.
SO THEY WILL GET THAT IN
ADDITION TO THAT -- SO
PHYSICIANS BOTH EMPTIES INDIOS
CAN ADMINISTER THIS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS CERTIFIED MIDWIVES
A PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
A CENTER MITCHELL THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SINCE THIS IS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE NOT THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE I'M GONNA FOCUS MY
QUESTIONS ON THE POLICY.
I'M READING THE OPPOSITION THAT
WAS DISTRIBUTED TO US TODAY --
ONE PAPER REALLY FOCUSES ON
ABORTION AND ITS SUBSEQUENT
IMPACT ON MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO ADDRESS IT
BECAUSE WHAT'S NOT UP FOR DEBATE
TODAY IS.
THE LEGALITY OF ABORTION IT IS
STILL A CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED RIGHT SO I'M NOT GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT.
I AM GOING.
TO LOOK AT THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
ABORTIONS CHECKING AN
IDEOLOGICAL BOX.
THE DOCUMENT THAT WAS JUST
SHARED WITH ALL OF US.
CAN I THINK IT GOES TO ONE OF
THE OPPONENTS.
POINTS ABOUT.
REFERENCING THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION'S VETO MESSAGE
ABOUT YOU'LL CHALLENGING WHETHER
OR NOT OR MAKING BASICALLY A
JUDGMENT CALL ABOUT -- WHAT THEY
DEEMED AN ACCEPTABLE DISTANCE
VERSUS SOMEONE ELSE AND WHAT
STRIKES ME WHEN I LOOK AT THE
CHART THAT WAS PROVIDED UNPAID
PAGE?
FOR ALL OF THE CLINICS THEY
REFERENCE OUR PLAN.
KßT CLINICS.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINICS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING CHALLENGES
FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN TERMS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
BE MEDI CAL PROVIDERS -- BECAUSE
OF THE NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS -- GAG RULE IN A
NUMBER OF THINGS SO AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT NONE OF THESE CLINICS
COULD BE AVAILABLE -- TO PROVIDE
ANY SERVICE MUCH LESS ABORTION
SERVICES SO I'M NOT SURE.
IF IT'S APPROPRIATE OR FAIR TO
EXPECT -- THAT THESE CLINICS
WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE SO
ABSENT THAT -- WHAT WITH YOUR
COMMENTS BE IN TERMS OF?
ME EXERCISING.
MY CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT TO AN ABORTION -- IF
INDEED THIS CLINTON CELLS IN A
LONGER AVAILABLE.
IF IF IF YOU'RE A WHOLE ARGUMENT
IS [inaudible]
GEOGRAPHY.
YOU FOLLOW ME.
YES MA'AM MY VOLUME ALL RIGHT.
I WOULD SAY THAT.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING I WOULD
LEAVE TO PEOPLE THAT ARE MARKS
HAS MUCH MORE EXPERTISE HAN
PASSING LEGISLATION BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT.
IT'S VERY RISKY TERRITORY TO
PASS LEGISLATION ON POTENTIAL
FUTURE PROBLEMS THAT HAVE NOT
OCCURRED.
AND SO WHETHER IT'S ABOUT
ABORTION OR ANYTHING ELSE REALLY.
IF THE IDEA OF THE ARGUMENT AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING YOU BUT IF THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT WE SHOULD MAKE
SURE OUR UNIVERSITIES PROVIDE
ABORTIONS IN CASE ABORTION
CLINICS ALREADY EXISTS THESE.
TWO THAT I THINK THAT GOES WELL
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY SINCE THIS BILL HAS
FOCUSED VERY.
CLEARLY AND CAREFULLY ON HOW WE
ARE NOT PROVIDING SURGICAL
ABORTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WHICH PART
OF MY ARGUMENT WAS THAT WOULD
MAKE MORE SENSE IN TERMS OF
SAVING STUDENTS TIME.
AND I THINK THAT.
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO ANSWER.
I THINK IT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ANSWER FOR IT FOR THE KIND OF
SPECULATION YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
I GUESS.
IF IT WERE ME.
I WOULD LOOK AT ALL THE
PROVIDERS NOT JUST BECAUSE WE
KNOW PLAN PARA HAS NOT THE ONLY
ABORTION PROVIDER I'M READING
FROM YOUR CHART AND SO YOUR
CHART LISTS.
THE WHOLE COLUMN WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD PROVIDERS.
ALL WHO ARE WITHIN SIX MILES YES
MA'AM I AGREE BUT I'M SAYING IF
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
HYPOTHETICAL SITUATION THAT I
WOULD LOOK AT WHAT LEGISLATION
YOU THINK IS GOING TO PREVENT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD PREVENTING
ABORTION PROVIDING ABORTION.
IF IT APPLIES TO ALL THE CLINICS
WERE TALKING ABOUT AND UNDER
THAT LANDSCAPE WHAT IT WOULD
MEAN FOR THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT HAS MUCH
TO DO WITH WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY BECAUSE THAT HAS NOT.
OCCURRED IN TO MY KNOWLEDGE IN
CALIFORNIA IS UNLIKELY.
TO SO.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
SO I GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
I WOULD HAVE.
TO I WOULD HAVE TO SEE THAT
SITUATION AND AND THEN CONSIDER
THE ARGUMENT.
I I APPRECIATE THAT AND I ONLY
RAISED IT BECAUSE I'M READING
THE CHART THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
ME BY THE OPPOSITION.
THAT AN ARBITRARY NOTION THAT
SIX MILES WAS DEEMED ACCEPTABLE
I THINK THE FUNDAMENTAL POINT OF
THE BILL THAT IS BEFORE US.
IS THAT IT SHOULD BE A SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS ON THEIR
CAMPUS -- I APPRECIATE THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION --
OPINED [inaudible]
THAT.
CLINICS WORK CLOSE ENOUGH AND
THE POINT I'M RAISING IS I THINK
IT IS A VERY -- TROUBLING BUT
POTENTIAL LIKELIHOOD -- BASED ON
THE CURRENT -- CONSISTENT ACTION
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
THESE CLNICS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THESERVICES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
THAT HAS BEEN A CONSISTENT
ATTACK IN MESSAGE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WE ARE CURRENTLY
FIGHTING A TITLE TEN GAG ORDER
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE THAT THAT CATEGORY.
I HOPE TO SHARE YOUR OPTIMISM
BUT I'M VERY CONCERNED.
BUT I JUST THINK IF THAT'S THE
ARGUMENT YOU'RE GONNA RAISE THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE BE REALLY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT IS ON THE TABLE AND
WE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION ON A
REGULAR BASIS INCLUDING THE
BUDGET.
IN TERMS OF OUR EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT PROSPECTIVE ACTIONS WE DO
IT ALL THE TIME SO THAT.
CLEARLY WITHIN OUR LANE.
IT WAS -- IS OKAY IF I RESPOND
WITH THE ONLY IF YOU HAVE TO
CHECK DO WE SHOULD RESPOND YES
THANK YOU A YES PLEASE.
THE ONLY OTHER THOUGHT I HAD IS
THAT IT'S NOT I THINK IT'S
INHERENTLY AND IN THE I'M GOING
TO BE.
A MATTER OF OPINION DECIDING
WHAT IS OR IS NOT AN ACCEPTABLE
DISTANCE AND I AGREE UP FOR
DEBATE I AGREE BUT I DON'T THINK
THE ARGUMENT IS SOLELY WHAT IS
AN ACCEPTABLE DISTANCE THIS
ISN'T.
A SITUATION OF INFINITE TIME AND
RESOURCES AND I THINK PART OF
THE ARGUMENT AND THIS HAS.
THIS IS NOT SPEAKING TO PRO LIFE
OR PRO CHOICE AT ALL IN MY
OPINION IT'S SIMPLY.
WE'RE GOING TO REQUIRE THE
UNIVERSITIES TO TAKE ON
SOMETHING THAT THEY HAVEN'T
ELECTED TO TRY TO DO ON THEIR
OWN.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
IT'S GOING TO COST SOME NON ZERO
AMOUNT VERY LARGE NON ZERO
AMOUNT.
OF TRAINING IN EXPENSES AND
RESOURCES AND THEN.
THERE HAS TO BE A BALANCE OF
CONSIDERATIONS OF FOR EXAMPLE IF
LET'S SAY THE NEAREST ABORTION
CLINIC WAS.
ON AVERAGE THIRTY MILES AWAY
THEN WE MIGHT START TO BE MORE
LIKE WELL THAT'S THAT'S VERY
STRONGLY IN THE ARGUMENT THAT
YOU'RE MAKING OR IF IT WAS ON
AVERAGE A BLOCK AWAY THEN IT
WOULD SEEM.
LESS COMPELLING SO I THINK IT
DOES MATTER TO LOOK AT AVERAGE
DISTANCE AND LOOK AT WHAT THE
BILL IS GOING TO COST WHAT
LIABILITIES THAT MIGHT OPEN THE
UNIVERSITIES UP TO OR NOT IT'S
WORTH DISCUSSING.
BUT IT'S NOT SIMPLY ONE SIDE OF
THE EQUATION BECAUSE IF THIS WAS
SOLELY ABOUT.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
ABORTION NO MATTER WHAT THE COST
THEM I AGREE THE RENO POINT
LOOKING AT THE GEOGRAPHY IF THAT
MAKES SENSE BUT IT IS ALWAYS
GOING.
TO WELL YOU KNOW IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE A BALANCE OF
RESOURCES AND RIGHT THAT WAS
PART OF THE I THINK THAT WAS THE
PART OF THE THOUGHT PROCESS WHEN
IT WAS VETOED.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND THIS
IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE THE
RESOURCE CONVERSATION TAKES
PLACE IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SO I'M REALLY FOCUS ON
THE INTEGRITY OF THE POLICY
ITSELF.
ANOTHER WITNESS WANTED TO
RESPOND TO MY POINTS TO THE
CHAIR IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK PLEASE.
YEAH I JUST -- REGARDLESS OF
DISTANCE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THE THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IS
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ACCESS.
AND ACCESS TO MY RATES AND IN
THAT THREE MONTH PERIOD THAT I
DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO MARS I
HAD NO RIGHTS ESSENTIALLY SAID
THIS IT IS ABOUT ACCESS.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IT'S SIX
MILES TEN MILES THIRTY MILES IT
SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO ANYONE
NO MATTER THE DISTANCE AND MAKE
IT CLOSER AND MAKE IT MORE
CENTRAL TO OUR STUDENTS LIVES
ARE AT OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL A
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER TERROR AND
FIRST I WANT -- TO THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT CAME HERE TO SPEAK
ON THIS ISSUE TODAY ESPECIALLY
ALL OF OUR YOUNGSTERS -- THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT LESSON AND AND
DEMOCRACY.
AND SAYING HOW WE CAN
COLLEGIATELY DISCUSS ISSUES.
ISSUES THAT WE AGREE WITH THIS
TO USE THAT WE DISAGREE WITH AND
SO I WON APPLIED YOU ALL FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE TODAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IT TALK ABOUT
TWO THINGS AND WE DID HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE UC HERE.
WHILE I'M GETTING SOME SOME
CONCERNS IF SHE CAN MAKE HER WAY
UP I'D LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
YOUR PLEASE COME TO THE TABLE SO
MY CONCERNS ARE TWO OF THE FIRST
IS -- SAFETY CONCERNS AND THE
SECOND IS LIABILITY.
THE PROPONENTS CLAIM THAT.
ABORTION MEDICATION TECHNIQUES
ARE EXTREMELY.
SAFE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE AND COST
EFFECTIVE.
AND MAYBE FOR MOST WOMEN THAT'S
TRUE.
BUT FOR MANY THIS IS NOT THE
CASE.
STUDENT HEALTH CARE CENTERS ARE
GENERALLY NOT EQUIPPED. TO
HANDLE MEDICAL EMERGENCIES A
COME WITH THE ADVERSE REACTIONS
THE COME FROM ABORTION PILLS.
SINCE MY FIRST PAYMENT METHOD
PRESS STONE WAS APPROVED IN TWO
THOUSAND BY THE FDA AS WAS
MENTIONED.
THERE'S BEEN MORE THAN FOUR
THOUSAND CASES WERE SEVERE
REACTIONS OF A CLEARED INCLUDING
A THOUSAND WOMEN THAT HAVE BEEN
HOSPITALIZED.
AND FIVE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
WOMEN THAT IF NEEDED BLOOD
TRANSFUSIONS BECAUSE OF PROFUSE
BLEEDING.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE
BEEN TWENTY TWO DEATHS.
DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE.
TO THE MEDICAL PROCEDURE.
THE NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF
MEDICINE IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT CONCLUDED THAT ONE OUT OF
SIX CASES.
THE TERMINATION OF PREGNANCY
WHEN THE MEDICATION IS TAKEN.
IS IN COMPLETE.
SO WHEN THE ABORTION PILL
DOESN'T WORK THE FIRST TIME.
A LOT OF TIME WE WERE WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THAT THERE'S IS LAID
BEFORE THE WOMAN UNDERSTANDS
THAT IT'S HAS NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE.
WHICH MEANS THAT SHE'S OFTEN
HAVING TO TAKE IT A SECOND TIME
WHICH IS PUSHING AGAINST THE TEN
WEEK WINDOW.
AND THE REST OF THE MOTHER A
MUCH GREATER SINCE THE LAST TIME
BEFORE BETWEEN -- TAKEN THE PILL
THE SURGICAL ABORTION -- THAT
MAY BE NEEDED HAS ALLOWED THAT
BABY TO MATURE EVEN FOR TO A
FURTHER STEP MAYBE CAUSING MORE
COMPLICATIONS.
IF THE MEDICATION ABORTION FAILS
TO TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY THE
TIME COMMITMENT AND COSTS RISE
EVEN FURTHER AS A PATIENT NEEDS
ANOTHER ROUND A MEDICATION
ABORTION OR IF TOO LATE A
SURGICAL ABORTION.
IF THE MEDICAL ABORTION DOESN'T
WORK AFTER TEN WEEKS THE WOMAN
WILL HAVE TO UTILIZE A SURGICAL
ABORTION.
SECOND TRIMESTER SURGICAL
ABORTIONS PROCEDURES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE AND
CARRY A MUCH GREATER OVERALL
RISK TO THE MOTHER.
THESE RISKS INCLUDE HEAVY
BLEEDING CRAMPING AND NAUSEA.
M. A LOT OF YOUNG WOMEN THAT ARE
HERE COLLEGE BOUND WOMEN OFTEN
LIVED IN IN DORMITORIES OFTEN
AND COMMUNAL.
SITUATIONS IN APARTMENTS WERE
BEDROOMS ARE NOT PRIVATE.
THE HOUSE IS EXPENSIVE YOU HAVE
ROOMMATES.
ABORTION IS A HIGHLY PERSONAL
DECISION THAT MUST BE MADE BY
WOMAN AND THERE IS AMPLE
AVAILABILITY TO ABORTION OPTIONS
SIR ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
AND QUALIFIED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
HAVING CAMPUSES PROVIDE THE
ABORTION PILL GIVES A FALSE
SENSE OF SECURITY. TWO YOUNG
COLLEGE WOMEN THAT ARE SEEKING
AN ABORTION.
AND SO FOR MY UC OUR COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS POTENTIAL
LIABILITY? FOR THE CURE CAMPUSES.
IF THE ABORTION PILL IS
UNSUCCESSFUL.
ANY COMPLICATIONS ARISE THE
CAMPY.
MITIGATED IF YOU WILL.
WITH YOUR ON CAMPUS CLINIC.
WHERE YOUR PATIENTS MAY HAVE TO
GO TO HOSPITAL?
SURGERY CENTER.
TO MAYBE EVEN SAVE THEIR LIFE.
WELL SENATOR STONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION AND I I I WANT TO
BACK UP A LITTLE BIT IN MY HASTE
TO SAY I WAS A TWEENER DID NOT
INTRODUCE MYSELF AND I WANT TO
DO THAT NOW MANY.
ANGELA KELLY I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
STATE HEALTH POLICY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SYSTEM.
AT THE UNIVERSITY DOES NOT HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
I THINK VERY EFFECTIVELY AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WE CONTINUE WE
WANT TO CONTINUE.
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
I I KNOW IT MIGHT SEEM ODD BUT I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE BIT BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY AT STUDENT NOW CAN
GO IN THE COMMUNITY AND GET THE
SERVICE DONE.
AND STILL HAVE TO GO BACK TO HER
DORM ROOM.
AND STILL MIGHT HAVE THOSE SIDE
EFFECTS NOW WHILE I'M NOT
PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT THE
NUMBERS OF THE SIDE EFFECTS AND
SO FORTH WHEREVER SHE GETS THIS
MEDICATION IF THERE IS GOING TO
BE -- A A SIDE EFFECT -- BAD
SIDE EFFECTS SHE IS GOING TO
FACE THE SAME.
ISSUE AND SO IT'S IF IT'S AN
EMERGENCY IT'S GOING TO BE AN
EMERGENCY WHETHER OR NOT.
THE UNIVERSITY HEALTH SYSTEM
ADMINISTERS THE FIRST BILL OR
WHETHER IT'S DONE TWO MILES AWAY.
SO I I I I WHILE I'M NOT
PREPARED TO TO TO COME IN AND I
DO FEEL IF WE LOOK AT IT FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF WOMEN ARE
GETTING THIS OUTSIDE OF THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS ARE GOING
BACK ON CAMPUS NOW IT.
IT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THIS BILL.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE A A WOMAN IS GOING
ONTO A CAMPUS FACILITY.
AND THEY'RE BEGINNING AND
INITIATING A MEDICAL TREATMENT
THAT HAS COMPLICATIONS.
AND THOSE COMPLICATIONS CAN
INSTANCES ALBEIT RARE.
CAN BE THAT THE LIFE OF THE
WOMAN.
ALL FOR HOSPITALIZATION
[inaudible]
TO MITIGATE HEMORRHAGING.
I BELIEVE THERE CAN BE A
LIABILITY ON THE CAMPUS THAT
INITIATED THAT TREATMENT SO.
YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION I
APPRECIATE THAT.
MY MY CONCERN ABOUT THE
LIABILITY OF COLLEGE CAMPUSES --
IT REMAINS AND I'M HOPING THAT
THE AUTHOR WILL WILL WORK
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND
ASSUMING THE BILL GETS OUT WHICH
I'M SURE PROBABLY WILL --
BECAUSE THIS COULD BE OF A LOT
OF EXPOSURE -- THE YOUNG AND THE
LIVES OF YOUNG WOMEN WHO MAY
FACE SEVERE COMPLICATIONS IS
ALSO A MAJOR CONCERN OF MINE
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF WOMEN ON OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND
GIVING THEM A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY WITH AN EASY FIX. TO
THE ABORTION NEEDS DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A WISE COURSE OF ACTION TO
TAKE SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
I'M NOT GONNA BILLS FOR THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU THINK THE IS QUESTION
OF LIABILITY IS A FASCINATING --
ONE MISS KILL YOUR COULD YOU
EDUCATE THOSE OF US WHO'VE NOT
BEEN ON A CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
CAMPUS IN RECENT DECADES.
WELL I WAS REFERRING TO MYSELF
BUT I THOUGHT YOU WERE FOR IT TO
ME BUT SINCE YOU CALLED THEM
YOUNGSTERS AND THEIR YOUNG
ADULTS THAT MAKES ME YOU KNOW I
COULD ADJUST MINE.
BUT REMIND ME HELP ME --
UNDERSTAND THE KIND OF RANGE OF
MEDICAL SERVICES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY -- PROVIDED IF YOU
COULD SPEAK GLOBALLY SO THE FEE
ISSUEREPRESENT DOESN'T HAVE
DOESN'T HAVE TO COME FORWARD.
BECAUSE OF THE TALK ABOUT
LIABILITY -- I WONDERED HOW YOU
HANDLE LIABILITY ON UP ON ANY OF
THE SERVICES THAT YOU PROVIDE ON
CAMPUS.
SO I AM AT SIX IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR MITCHELL THE
THE UNIVERSITY SELF INSURED SO
FOR LIABILITY WE IT DOES IT IS A
DIRECT COSTS.
THE UNIVERSITY TO FIVE MILLION
OVER FIVE MILLION -- WE HAVE --
I'M UMBRELLA INSURANCE APOLOGIZE
AND ASK YOU TO TRY TO SPEAK INTO
THE MIKE FIGHT SERVICES BEHIND
YOU FOR THE RECORD YES OKAY SO --
THE LIABILITY -- IT WILL
CURRENTLY THE SERVICES PROVIDED
ARM AT THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS RANGE DEPENDING UPON THE
LOCATION AND THE HOW THE
STUDENTS TO HEALTH CENTERS
STAFFED.
THE UNIVERSITY DOESN'T STAFF ALL
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CENTERS THE SAME THEY EACH HAVE
THEIR OWN LOCAL ABILITY TO
DECIDE WHICH EXPERTISE --
EXISTED THERE CENTER WAS
SERVICES THEY'LL PROVIDE THERE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE COMMON
ACROSS THE SYSTEM -- BUT I WOULD
SAY IF IN THE EVENT OF LIABILITY
IT IS AN INTERESTING QUESTION IF --
EVEN ONE CASE IN THREE YEARS FOR
EXAMPLE OR ONE CASE IN FIVE
YEARS COULD BE -- A WITH A
EXPENSIVE TO THE UNIVERSITY WE
HAVE NOT PROVIDED A RISK
ASSESSMENT -- AS PART OF OUR
ANALYSIS -- BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S ZERO BUT I DON'T KNOW --
THE AMOUNT AND I DON'T KNOW WITH
THE FREQUENCY AND THE STATISTICS
IT COULD BE. ONE IN TEN YEARS OR
COULD BE NEVER RIGHT I JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT.
EXPERTISE OR ANALYSIS AND BUT
BUT MY IF I MAY THROUGH THE
CHAIR BUT MY QUESTION IS TO
REMIND ME OF THE NATURE OF THE
SERVICES CURRENTLY APPLIED.
AT THE OFFER I'M CLEAR THAT THEY
RANGE YEAH -- AS IN ANY HEALTH
CARE FACILITY BASED ON GEOGRAPHY
WHATEVER BUT JUST GIVE ME A
SENSE -- OF WHAT THEY ARE SO IN
TERMS OF THERE'S REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES SO BIRTH CONTROL --
THERE'S SOME ARE YOU D.
IMPLANTATION THAT SOME OF THIS
IS THAT THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS THERE'S ES T..
D. TESTING -- THERE'S A VARIETY
AB DEPENDING UPON THE LOCATION
SO -- THERE'S OPTOMETRY SERVICES
THERE'S PRIMARY CARE SERVICES AT
EACH -- STUDENT HEALTH CENTER --
THERE'S TWENTY FOUR HOUR NURSE --
AVAILABILITY EACH AND THERE'S A
LOT -- I THINK A FAIRLY ROBUST
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE AVAILABLE
AT EACH -- STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
SO ABOVE BEYOND THAT DOES OF THE
THE CORE -- SERVICES AND YOU'LL
THERE THERE WILL BE SOME
SPECIALTY AT VARIOUS DIFFERENT
PLACES YEAH I KNOW THE I KNOW
YOU'RE TWEENER.
I DON'T KNOW THE NATURE OF KIND
OF YOUR DISCUSSIONS BUT BUT I'M
CURIOUS FROM THE UNIVERSITY'S
PERSPECTIVE.
IF THIS -- US SERVICE IS OUTSIDE
OF THE REALM.
OF THE KINDS OF SERVICE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERED IN TERMS OF
THE MEDICAL.
INTRICACIES FOR THE LACK OF A
BETTER TERM IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU
CURRENTLY PROVIDE.
SO I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR BECAUSE OF BOMB.
FOR WHERE TWEENER BUT WE ARE NOT
A TWEENER WHEN IT COMES TO
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO CHOOSE SO WE HAVE
STUDENT HEALTH INSURANCE THAT
PROVIDES FOR THE INSURANCE.
THAT ALLOWS A OUT A WOMAN TO GO
TO COMMUNITY PROVIDERS AND HAVE
THAT INSURANCE COVER -- I THINK
WHAT HAPPENS AS A MATTER OF
CALCULATION IT EACH STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER THEY DECIDE WHICH
SERVICES AS A MATTER OF COST
ISSUE TAKEN HOUSE IN WHICH ARE --
AVAILABLE ARE POTENTIALLY
AVAILABLE -- BY A LOCAL --
PHYSICIANS -- AND OR CLINICS SO
THIS ASSESSMENT IS REALLY AROUND
COST MORE SO THAN IDEOLOGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SOLD
MATURE LET LET ME SAY THAT I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
WHAT I AM MOST INTERESTED IN IS
REALLY KIND OF THE?
HOW IT'S OPERATIONALIZED HOW WE
IN THE SYSTEM THAT'S NOT
CONSISTENT THAT PIECE -- THE
ARGUMENT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
ONE IS ANTI CHOICE OR PRO CHOICE
IS MOOT TO ME.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL --
FOR THOSE WHO -- DON'T BELIEVE
IN ABORTION.
DON'T HAVE.
ONE AND SO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT I SHOULD
HAVE FULL COMPLETE ACCESS TO
WHATEVER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES I DEEP APPROPRIATE FOR
ME SHOULD BE LEFT UP TO ME.
AGAIN FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
NOT THE ISSUE HERE UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S WHAT.
MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION IS
FOCUSED ON WHICH IS OFTEN THE
CASE WE HAVE THIS.
THIS DISCUSSION SO I'M NOT WE'RE
NOT DEBATING MY RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
AW AGAIN I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL.
AND I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
THAT WE FIGURE OUT THE WAY IN
WHICH IT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
SYSTEM IN WHICH WE ARE ASKING --
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE OTHERWISE
LEGAL AND AVAILABLE.
A MEDICATION.
I THINK IT IS -- UNFAIR -- WHEN
WE HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE FOCUS EXCLUSIVELY OR VERY
NARROWLY ON COMPLICATIONS AS YOU
KNOW MISTER CHAIR I'M CARRYING A
BILL -- THAT THAT IS IT
KNOWLEDGE IN THE REALITY OF THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH RATE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN MATERNAL
MORBIDITY IN THE STATE.
SO WE DENY THE REALITY OF THE
DANGERS WHAT THAT CARRYING A
BABY TO TERM.
THAT THEY EXIST SO FOR GONNA
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW --
STATISTICS AND RISK TH WE WE
SHOULD PRESENT THE FULL SPECTRUM
BECAUSE THEIR RISK ASSOCIATED ON
BOTH ENDS OF THE SPECTRUM -- BUT
AGAIN I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THAT LINE OF
QUESTIONING BECAUSE IT IT
BROUGHT SOMETHING TO LIGHT SORRY
SINCE WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY ERE I'D -- I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT.
THESE NORMAL SCOPES OF
OPERATIONS THAT TAKE PLACE RIGHT
NOW IN THESE MEDICAL FACILITIES --
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH -- ID
IMPLANT STD TESTING CITY -- I'M
ASSUMING PREGNANCY TESTING UNDER
THESE ISSUES THAT YOU DID
METION THAT BUT JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY -- DO THOSE AND I
REALIZE YOU'RE NOT A MEDICAL
EXPERT BUT DO THOSE IN YOUR
POSITION THAT YOU HAVE AT THE
UNIVERSITY -- LET ME PARTY
DIFFERENTLY AS A BUSINESS OWNER
I KNOW THAT IF I DO.
X. IT CREATES A CERTAIN
LIABILITY.
I KNOW IF I I PROVIDE TO
STAFFING RIGHT IF I STAFF
SOMEBODY IN A CLERICAL OFFICE I
HAVE.
THIS PIECE OF LIABILITY.
THERE'S A CHANCE THEY'LL GET
INJURED.
NOT REALLY IF I PUT A REFER ON A
ROOF THERE'S A HIGHER RISK OF
LIABILITY.
DO YOU SEE THAT THE THIS BILL IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL ON A
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS IS IT THE SAME.
LIABILITY EXPOSURE OR DO YOU SEE
IT AS A HIGHER OR LOWER.
OR LIABILITY EXPOSURE -- THIS
BILL HAS STORE THIS CONCEPT HAS
BEEN LOOKED AT FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND WE JUST HAVE NOT HEARD
A LOT OF RINGING FROM THE
UNIVERSITY AND WE'RE NOT A QUIET
GROUP TYPICALLY.
BUT ABOUT THE LIABILITY THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE'S NONE
BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN IS PART OF
OUR ANALYSIS.
RAISING THAT IT REALLY HAS BEEN
A MATTER OF STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS ARE NOT HOSPITALS AND SO
HOW DO THEY MANAGE THEIR BUDGETS
AND HOW DO THEY DETERMINE WHICH
ARE WHICH SERVICES ARE BETTER
OFFER ON WAS NOT NECESSARILY A
DECISION ABOUT LIABILITY -- IT
WAS MORE OF A DECISION ABOUT --
WE WE FOR OTHER SERVICES OFF
CAMPUS AS WELL SO WE DON'T HAVE
ALL SERVICES.
IN THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER
BECAUSE THE GOAL OF THE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTER IS TO HAVE IS LOW
OR NO COST AS POSSIBLE SO
WHEREVER WE CAN.
FIND A COMMUNITY PROVIDER WE DO
AND WHENEVER WE CAN DO IT IN
HOUSE WE DO SO IT REALLY IS VERY
MUCH A LOCAL DECISION AND IT'S
IN IN IT AND AND THE DECISION
HASN'T BEEN.
LET'S LOOK AT THE STRANDS OF
LIABILITY AND DECIDE THIS VERSUS
THAT SO RIGHT.
AT THAT THAT'S NOT BEEN -- TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THE WAY THE DECISIONS
ON BRINGING SERVICES ON OR OFF
HAVE BEEN MADE.
BUT I'M ASKING YOU IS SOMEBODY
THAT REPRESENTS THE UNIVERSITY.
IF YES M. THIS BILL GOES FOR
WOMEN I GUESS I SHOULD SAY THIS
BILL GOES FORWARD.
AND YOUR MANDATED IN THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE MANDATED TO
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE.
DOES IT CREATE A GREATER RISK OF
YOUR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
SELF FUNDED INSURANCE BEFORE IT
GOES OUT TO RE INSURANCE.
OR IS IT JUST A SIMPLE AS GIVING
SOMEBODY A STICK TO URINATE ON
TO SEE IF THEY'RE PREGNANT
[inaudible]
I I DON'T AND I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW I THINK IT WILL
DEPEND ON AND THE THAT THE RISK
IS IS ABOUT NUMBERS IT'S ABOUT
HOW MANY POTENTIAL CASES AND THE
LIKE SO -- AND SO I I I REALLY
DON'T KNOW I I DON'T WANT TO I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU.
AFTER THE HEARING -- BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION.
AND MAYBE I COULD ASK IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO BAD GEE I REALLY I'M NOT I'M
JUST TRYING TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION OR MAYBE -- THAT
REBEKAH IT IF YOU HAVE SORRY
MONICA I APOLOGIZE ISSUED A
WRITTEN YOUR NAME DOWN
[inaudible]
AND I GUESS I'M NOT ASKING IT
RIGHT NOW I APOLOGIZE I MEAN I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT ASKING RIGHT I
GUESS.
IF IF THE STUDENT A MEDICAL
FACILITY ON CAMPUS WAS --
ISSUING A PREGNANCY TEST.
AND WHETHER IT'S I DON'T HATE
YOU ANYMORE EPT I DON'T KNOW
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW I'M NOT I I
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE SO FAR FROM
MY COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE BEEN OUT
FOR A LONG TIME I DIDN'T GO.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S THERE AND
AVAILABLE ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND
SO.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IF IF
SOMEONE COMES IN AND SAYS I WANT
THIS TEST ADMINISTERS
ADMINISTERED SEE IF I AM
PREGNANT.
AND THEN THEY TAKE A PREGNANCY
TEST.
WHAT'S THE RISK OR LIABILITY FOR
ISSUING THAT PREGNANCY TEST LIKE
IS THERE A RISK OF BLEEDING IS
THERE A RISK OF POST SURGICAL.
DO YOU SEE JENNIFER EVERYTHING
IN YOUR QUEST OKAY A BIT BETTER
NOW OKAY GOOD I'M SO WE
ROUTINELY TEST FOR PREGNANCY WE
HAVE EIGHT HUNDREDS OF TESTS
THAT ARE PERFORMED A MONTHLY.
AND WE ROUTINELY -- COUNCIL
WANTS A TEST HAS BEEN.
IF IT'S A POSITIVE TEST.
WE COUNSEL ON VARIOUS OPTIONS
AND SO FORTH SO THAT'S A VERY --
LOW THRESHOLD I WOULD SAY KIND
OF SERVICE THAT ROUTINELY
PROVIDED BY EVERY STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER -- IN TERMS OF FOR THE
PREGNANCY TESTING DO YOU SEE
THAT TED DO YOU SEE THAT PROVIDE
SERVICE THAT YOU PROVIDE AN
IMPACT YOUR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF AND FUNDED OR FUNDED SELF
FUNDED.
LIABILITY I HAVEN'T SEEN I
HAVEN'T HEARD IT THAT --
PERFORMING PREGNANCY TESTS HAVE
LIFTED IT I HAVE HAVE CAUSED ANY
KIND OF BEING MANDATED TO PUT
THIS BILL ON THE STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS DO YOU THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE A WRIST HERE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF PRE
FUNDED [inaudible]
AND MORE OF A RISK.
SO I AM I AM A LITTLE CONFUSED
BECAUSE WE'RE ALREADY DOING
PREGNANCY TEST THAT WON'T CHANGE
THIS BILL DOESN'T MANDATE THAT
IS NOT THE QUESTION IT'S IT'S A
BILL IS MANDATING YOU FOR TO
PROVIDE A COPY A HILL.
THAT AT TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY
WHICH COULD IN SOME CASES CAUSE
BLEEDING CRAMPING SURGICAL
PROCEDURES THAT ARE NEEDED.
DOES THAT CREATE A GREATER RISK
OF LIABILITY TO YOURSELF FUNDING
MECHANISM IN THERE FOR YOUR
REINSURANCE MECHANISM IF.
SOMEONE I DON'T KNOW. TO AN WHAT
I AM CENTER STONE COLD AT THE
NUMBERS AND I DIDN'T WRITE HIM
DOWN AGAIN AND MY MEMORIES JUST.
I THINK THERE'S MAYBE A
POTENTIAL BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
SPEAK WITH -- SOME EXPERTS ABOUT
RISK ASSESSMENT IN UTILITY TO
THE UNIVERSITY THANK YOU MA'AM --
FOR MOVE ON THIS THIS ONE'S
ACTUALLY PHYSICIAN.
PERSON -- SO I APPRECIATE THE
BACK AND FORTH -- AND I HAD A
MONTH AND THE DROSS OF OF PLEASE
SAVE DIED COLLEGE EYES OF A
MONTH BE SURE WE GET TO YOUR
QUESTION TO AYE.
AGAIN I GUESS.
I A HEAR THE CONVERSATION AND
AND AND CERTAINLY I THINK IS YOU
SAID THERE'S STILL A TIME YOU DO
SOME PROCEDURE THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
UNIQUE.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO SEE HOW
THE THEN SOVIET DIALOGUE WITH
CENTER MITCHELL AND APPRECIATE
CENTER.
GROVE -- WHAT YOU ALSO BROUGHT
OUT -- YOU'RE GOING.
TO END STAND TO FIRST OF ALL I
UNDERSTAND.
UC AND CSU I KNOW YOU'RE
STANDING BACK THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THE AUTHOR CORRECT
ALL RIGHT.
AND THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THIS BILLS COME BEFORE NOT LIKE
HEARD IT CORRECTLY IF YOU'RE ROB
I'M WRONG.
THAT.
IN MANY WAYS AT LEAST THIS WAS
LIKE IN PREVIOUS ITERATION THE
BILL'S THE LIABILITY WAS NOT AN
ISSUE THAT ROSE TO THE POINT
WHERE.
PEOPLE OF THE I KNOW THERE'S
LOTS OF ATTORNEYS THAT YOU SEE
I'VE I'VE BECAUSE I WAS FACULTY
MEMBER THERE WHO CAME BACK AND
SAID OH BY THE WAY WE'RE WHERE
IT REALLY WHAT ABOUT THE
LIABILITY I MEAN THERE MAY BE
OTHER ISSUES PEOPLE WORRY ABOUT.
OKAY I I JUST.
I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON THE
TABLE BECAUSE BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
THE FIRST TIME THIS BILLS BEEN
BEFORE -- THE LEGISLATURE AND
YOU SEE HAS BEEN AND I ASSUME
CSU HAS ALSO LOOKED AT THE BILL
AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND THAT THAT
<c.magenta>AY COME FROM AND I UNDERSTAND</c>
YOUR CLEANERS BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES.
BUT I KNOW THERE'S A LOT FOCUS
ON THE LIABILITY PEACE BUT THAT
I'VE Y. HEARD YOU SAY JUST TO
CLARIFY WAS IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
AT LEAST AND SO I CAN BE ZERO AS
YOU SAID BUT IT'S NOT LIKE THE
BIG THING THAT RUNS WORRIED
ABOUT.
WELL FROM THE UC PERSPECTIVE I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR CSU RIGHT AND I
KNOW IT UNLOCKS IKIZI FOR UC'S
YOU THAT'S WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY
FOR YOU SEE.
OKAY AND DISEASE YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT THING OR NOT.
THE KKK COME UP BUT AT THE END
TO KEEP A VERY BRIEF SO I'LL BE
SURE SENATOR OTHER BANKS ONE
CLEAR BY THIS POINT EXISTS WE
SEEN THAT GUN AROUND A FEW TIMES.
ABOUT THAT SO SO IF I CAN ASK
YOU YOU HAVE LIKE A ONE SENTENCE
ANSWER THAT HAD.
LIKE YES OR NO.
I WOULD SAY -- LIABILITY IS IS A
CONCERN FOR ANYTHING IS NOT OUR
GREATEST CONCERN WITH THIS OKAY
CONVERSATION WITH AUTHOR AND
WORKING FULL OKAY.
OKAY GOT IT EXIT YES THE ANSWER
IS GREATER THAN ZERO BUT NOT SO
BIG THAT THAT'S THE MAIN THING.
SENATOR ALSO.
ANOTHER EACH THE WAY YOU
DESCRIBE IT THERE SO MANY
MEDICAL SERVICES EVEN IF THEY
NOT IDENTICAL AT EVERY CENTER I
ASSUME SAID.
DEPENDING ON WHAT'S MORE NEEDED
OR WHATEVER THEY DECIDED AT THAT
CAMPUS.
YOU KNOW I WOULD HATE TO SEE
LOOKING AT WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES -- AS A GREATER RISK.
OR SEEN REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
UNDER A MAGNIFYING GLASS ANDVERSES ALL THE OTHER MANY.
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED AND
I'M SURE BEEN MEDICAL SERVICES
THAT THERE ARE ALWAYS RISKS AND
LIABILITIES ATTACHED TO THAT SO--
I JUST YOU KNOW.
I HOPE THIS ISN'T YOU KNOW A WAY.
TO CREATE MORE OBSTACLES FOR
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES
THAT WE REALLY WOMEN FACE ENOUGH
OBSTACLES AS IT IS -- BT I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO JUDGE THIS
ON THE FACT THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS AND THE REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES NOT LOOKING FOR A WAY
THAT'S GONNA.
GET IN THE WAY OF THEIR OF THOSE
RIGHTS THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS --
JUST ACTUALLY I'M SORRY THANK
YOU AND YOUR NAME AGAIN.
AT TO SEE SAYS JESSE -- AND
FIRST OFF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE CHAMBER A PERSONAL
STORY -- BUT INDEED YOU DON'T
HAVE TO ANSWER THIS IF YOU DON'T
WANT -- TO BUT YOU MENTIONED IT
TOOK YOU THREE MONTHS.
RATE.
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
SIX MILES THANKS MILES WHATEVER.
DO YOU MIND SHARING WITH US --
WHAT WHY DID TAKE THREE MONTHS I
MEAN WHAT?
WHAT WHAT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
READER YOU WISH TO SHARE THAT
WITH US I KNOW IT'S VERY
PERSONAL?
YEAH SURE -- SO.
SO THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS IS
THAT I GOT PREGNANT AND I WENT
TO MY STUDENT HEALTH CENTER
WHERE THEY TOLD ME THAT I WAS
PREGNANT -- OUT AGAIN I WAS A
GRADUATE ARE I AM A GRADUATE OF
UC RIVERSIDE SO AT THE UC
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER -- THEY
THEN SET UP ANOTHER APPOINTMENT
WITH AN OB GEIN -- WHERE THAT OB
GYN TOLD ME ABOUT THREE
DIFFERENT PLACES I COULD GO TO
STEP THREE DIFFERENT REFERRALS --
THE FIRST FACILITY THAT I WAS
SENT TO DIDN'T OFFER ABORTION
SERVICES -- AND SO THAT DELAYED
A LOT OF MY CARE -- THE SECOND
FACILITY THAT I WAS THAN REFER.
TO THEN TOLD ME -- I WAS ABLE TO
SCHEDULE MY APPOINTMENT THERE.
BUT AFTERWARD THEY YOU KNOW
AFTER YOU KNOW DEALING WITH THAT
THEY SAID THAT THEY COULD.
GIVE ME AN APPOINTMENT ABOUT A
MONTH AND A HALF OUT -- FROM
THAT TIME THAT I CALLED -- AND
AS YOU ALL OF MENTIONED.
HAVING AN ABORTION IS A DEEPLY
PERSONAL DECISION BUT ONCE
SOMEONE HAS MADE THAT DECISION
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT -- AND SO
SO ONE IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER HERE AS YOU DISCUSS
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE RIGHTS AND OUR
BEAR YEARS ARE BARRIERS ARE
RATES EXCUSE ME ARE EXACERBATED
BECAUSE WE ARE YOUNGER PEOPLE --
SO.
THAT SO FROM THERE -- I CAN GET
MY APPOINTMENTS AND BRINGING UP
ANOTHER BAY AREA THE STIGMA.
YOU KNOW AS YOU MENTIONED CENTER
YOUR ALSO PUTTING.
YOU KNOW PUTTING A REPRODUCTIVE
ON HEALTH CARE UNDER THIS
MAGNIFYING GLASS -- I HAD
REMAINED SILENT THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE TIME AND THEN FINALLY
BROKE MY SILENCE WHEN -- I
FINALLY WENT TO A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD BECAUSE I OPENED UP
AND I TOLD SOMEONE ABOUT IT.
BUT DIAZ OF THOUGHT IN A
NUTSHELL IS WHAT HAPPENED.
OKAY I HEAR MOTION FOR THE BELT --
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
IT AND ACTUALLY SO LEYVA.
SOUNDS THAT SOUNDS LIKE ONE OF
THE ISSUE SO ASIDE FROM LACK OF
AVAILABILITY ON CAMPUS IS ALSO
AND THAT AND FRANKLY -- I COULD
ASK YOU THE QUESTION I KNOW WHAT
THE ANSWER IS IS THAT ANY
FACILITY INCLUDING SOON HEALTH
FACILITY SHOULD ALSO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER
PROVIDERS ALTHOUGH IN THIS CASE
WHAT I HEAR IS THAT THEY THEY
REFERRED -- FOR YOU TO A PERSON
THAT DIDN'T ACTUALLY WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE OR SOMETHING WE
NEED SOME IMPROVEMENTS THERE.
TOO AND I AND I KNOW THAT YOU
SEE ALSO OPERATES LOTS OF
MEDICAL CENTERS AS WELL SINCE I
USED TO PRACTICE AT ONE DID YOU.
SAY SOMETHING YES IF I MAY
SENATOR JUST BRIEFLY THIS IS
BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION I THINK FOR THE
PAST YEAR OR SO -- ON THIS ISSUE
AND ONE OF THE RESULTS OF HAVING
THIS ISSUE WAS TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS AND
WE'VE DIRECTOR ARE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS TO MAKE SURE --
THAT THEIR THEIR THEIR LISTS ARE
ACCURATE INTO NOT JUST REFER BUT
TO DO MORE OF A WARM HAND OFF TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDENT GETS
THE APPOINTMENT THAT THEY
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF
THING YOU GIVE THEM A SHEET OF
PAPER AND SAY GO.
AND DO AN EVEN IF THIS BILL
PASSES IT DOESN'T ENSURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT IS GOING TO WANT
TO HAVE THE PROCEDURE THERE ON
THE STUDENT HEALTH CAMPUS.
SO WE STILL NEED I THINK FROM
THE UNIVERSITY'S PERSPECTIVE TO
PROVIDE THAT SERVICE OF A MORE
WARM HAND OFF SO YOU'RE NOT.
THREE MONTHS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT INSURANCE AND IS THIS THE
RIGHT PROVIDER AND DOES IT WORK
AND THAT WAS MAY I IN IN MEDI
CAL IS A WHOLE NOTHER ISSUE
BECAUSE CALORIE.
IN RIGHT WELL YOU YOU YOU YOU
SIGNED UP FOR YOUR HOME COUNTY
OKAY SO GOT IT OKAY SO I THINK I
THINK THE POINT'S WELL MADE I
THINK WE SEE LAW THE CHALLENGES
I THINK CENTER LEYVA IS OFFERING
A SOLUTION I HEAR A MOTION --
CERTAINLY WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR PAN THANK YOU TO ALL
OF THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IS GREATLY APPRECIATED
THERE'S TO THINGS.
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS ONE
WE TALKED WE HEARD -- FROM THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT ACCESS.
CURRENTLY TWENTY TWO UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES ARE MORE THAN THIRTY
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE CLOSEST
ABORTION PROVIDER.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT IF YOU
READ ALL OF MY REBUTTALS AFTER
WE RECEIVED THAT VETO MESSAGE
FROM THE GOVERNOR.
I VEHEMENTLY AS STRONGLY
DISAGREED WITH HIS ASCERTAIN
SHIN -- THAT HE DID NOT THINK IT
WAS INCONVENIENT SO HE MAY IT
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN HIS VETO
MESSAGE I CERTAINLY DID NOT
THINK THAT IT WAS APPROPRIATE
NOR DID MANY OF THIS THAT THE
SUPPORTERS.
SECOND I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT LIABILITY.
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY WE
LIVE IN A VERY LITIGIOUS SOCIETY
AND IF WE ARE GOING TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT COULD HAPPENED WHICH
I DO THINK THAT'S LEGITIMATE
CONCERN.
WHAT HAPPENS AT THE U. S. C.
RIGHT NOW WHO TREATS A STUDENT
WITH DIABETES IN THE STATE AND
THE STUDENT GOES INTO A DIABETIC
COMA?
IS THE IS THE UC ARE THIS ISSUE
LIABLE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY'RE
TREATING SOMEONE FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS AND THEY TRY TO HARM
THEMSELVES IS THE USE YOUR THE
C. ISSUE LIABLE.
WHEN MY DAUGHTERS WERE IN
COLLEGE THEIR FRESHMAN YEAR --
OF ONE OF THE TEAMMATES STUMBLED
INTO THE ROOM SO DRUNK THAT SHE
WET HERSELF AND PASSED OUT.
MY GIRLS CALLED ME AND I SAID
DEAR GOD HANG UP AND CALL 911-
WHICH THEY DID AND LATER THE
MOTHER OF THE STUDENT TRIED TO
TRIED TO SUE US BECAUSE SHE LOST
HER SCHOLARSHIP.
AND TRIED TO SQUISH ARE TRIED TO
SUE THE THE COLLEGE.
SO I THINK THAT WE CAN'T ALWAYS
WORRY ABOUT LIABILITY IT IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE THERE IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY THE WORLD THAT WE
LIVE IN.
BUT I WILL END WITH THIS.
WHEN I GOT ELECTED IN CAME TO
SACRAMENTO I FOUND OUT VERY
QUICKLY THAT I'D KIND OF BEEN
RAISED IN AND LIVED IN A BUBBLE?
I LIVED IN THIS VERY WARM
ENVIRONMENT WHERE MY PARENTS
TALKED TO ME ABOUT MY RIGHTS
WHERE I KNEW THAT A WOMAN HAD
THE RIGHT TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
THAT WE COULD TALK ABOUT IT AND
THERE WAS NO SHAME AND THEN I
GOT HERE AND I WAS JUST
ABSOLUTELY DUMBFOUNDED.
AND THIS HASN'T HAPPENED TODAY
BUT DUMBFOUNDED BY HOW THE
OPPOSITION SHAMED WOMEN FOR
ACCESSING THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT HOW WOMEN FEEL STIGMATIZED
AND SO I SAID TO MYSELF I SAID
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN ANYMORE.
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN WANT TO SAY
THE WORD ABORTION IS LIKE A
PORTION YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS PART
OF LIFE EVERYWOMAN HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO ACCESS
IT IS YOUR BODY YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DECIDE NO ONE ELSE HAS
THAT RIGHT.
SO FOR ME THIS IS THIS IS
PERSONAL IN THE SENSE THAT I
GREW UP IN A HOUSEHOLD WHERE WE
COULD HEAR THE WORD ABORTION WE
COULD TALK ABOUT MY FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS AS A WOMAN.
AND NOW AS A LEGISLATOR I THINK
IT IS MY JOB TO TRY AND HELP
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS
THAT CHOICE THIS BILL DOES NOT
MANDATE ANYONE HAS AN ABORTION.
THIS BILL SAYS THAT WOMEN HAVE A
RIGHT AND THEY HAVE A CHOICE AND
THAT SHOULD BE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO EDUCATION AND
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR MITCHELL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I AND II STONE.
STONE NO DORADO.
DRAWS -- AYE GROVE GROVE KNOW
HER TADO.
HER TOTAL AYE.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THINKING MEMBERS.
THE BILL IS A SIX TWO WILL NOT
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN -- FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
I SEE CENTER BATES HERE --
CENTER BATES WELCOME.
ANISE AND YOU HAVE TO BILLS --
IT DO YOU I JUST TAKEN THE FILE
ORDER.
WHAT DID YOU DO I TAKE THEM IN
THE ORDER THEY ARE IN THE FILE?
IT'S GOING ON WELCOME.
OUR US CENTER BASIS AS I COULD
IF I DID YOU WANT TAKE THEM IN
THE ORDER AND THEY ARE THE FILED
IN OKAY.
THANK YOU SO WE ARE GOING TO
FIRST -- HERE ITEM.
OKAY WILL FIRST YEAR ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU AND
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
SAW THEM GOOD AFTERNOON SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE PER PROHIBITS AN
OPERATOR.
OF THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF
FACILITIES FROM PROVIDING ANY
FORM OF FALSE ADVERTISING OR
MARKETING SERVICES THE LICENSE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY A
CERTIFIED ALCOHOL OR OTHER DRUG
PROGRAM HE RECOVERY RESIDENTS OR
AND OR ANOTHER THIRD PARTY.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED THAT
CONSUMERS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS HAVE DISABLING
CONDITIONS AND THAT THESE
CONSUMERS.
AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
VULNERABLE HOWEVER THERE ARE NO
PROVISIONS IN CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE. TO CONTROL AN
ETHICAL MARKETING PRACTICES THAT
PREY ON DISTRESSED FAMILIES OR
INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS WHO ARE
SEEKING TREATMENT.
AS A RESULT PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN BE MISLED
MISDIRECTED MISDIAGNOSED BY AND
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
THE GOAL OF SB EIGHT FIVE EIGHTY
NINE IS TO PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH ADDICTION.
FROM BEING TREATED ADVERSELY AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY ARE
PROMISED MARKETERS WHO KNOWINGLY
AND WILLFULLY MAKE MATERIALLY
FALSE STATEMENTS.
WHETHER AN ADVERTISING OR BY
DIRECT COMMUNICATION WITH
CURRENT OR POTENTIAL PATIENTS
SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE SB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE AUTHORIZES ALSO
AUTHORIZES DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS.
OF MISCONDUCT AND IMPOSE
SANCTIONS ULTIMATELY THIS
MEASURE SEEKS TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO ARE AT THEIR MOST VULNERABLE.
AND SEEKING TREATMENT THE BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
ADVOCATES FOR RESPONSIBLE
TREATMENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND STAMP CORBIN
PRESIDENT OF THE ADDICTION
TREATMENT ADVOCACY COALITION.
WE THANK YOU CENTER BATES --
WITNESSES SUPPORT MAXIMUM SIX
MINUTES TOGETHERAND YOU CAN DO
SHORTER THAT BE GREAT.
HI MY MY NAME IS CORBIN AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT.
OF THE ADDICTION TREATMENT
ADVOCATES ADVOCACY COALITION.
AND WE GIVE OUR FULL THROATED
SUPPORT TO THIS BILL OUR
INDUSTRY LIKE MOST INDUSTRIES --
SUPPORTS.
ELIMINATING FALSE ADVERTISING
AND MISLEADING STATEMENTS IN
ADVERTISING AS ALL INDUSTRIES
SHOULD.
F. ARBEL CHAIR CENTER SURE
DALE'S CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENT OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND ADDICTION FORCES
FOCUSED FRACTIONAL THE STATE OUR
FIVE HUNDRED PROGRAMS IN
RECOVERY RESIDENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JUST GOT ANOTHER COMPLAINT
YESTERDAY WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THE NEXT TO PATIENT BROKERING IS
THAT THESE COMPANIES ARE
SCRUBBING THE WEBSITES OF
LEGITIMATE PROVIDERS FOR
INSTANCE ARE VICE PRESIDENT OR
BOARD YESTERDAY JUST CALLED --
SHE HAS A NUMBER OF TWO PROGRAMS
THAT WERE OUT WATER MERCED AREA
I GOOGLED ADDICTION TREATMENT
FOR ATWATER AND I HAVE WEBSITE
CAME UP IT HAD A PICTURE OF HER
PROGRAM.
HER INFORMATION ACTUALLY HER
NAME AS THE OWNER AND DIRECTOR
OF THE PROGRAM I CLICKED ON IT
FOR MORE INFORMATION IT OPENED A
NEW PAGE AGAIN WITH HER LOGO
FROM HER COMPANY ON IT.
AND A TELEPHONE NUMBER PLEASE
CALL NOW I WAS DIRECTED TO A
COMPANY IN FLORIDA THAT IS WELL
KNOWN FOR PATIENT BROKERING HAS
OVER 90% OF ITS PATIENTS COME
FROM -- OUT OF NETWORK AND THEY
OFFERED ME ON THE PHONE WITH IN
FIVE MINUTES.
A AN INDUCEMENT TO SEND MY
FICTIONAL CHILD -- TO FLORIDA
WITH FREE AIRLINE AND IT WAS
JUST DISGUSTING THAT THEY ARE
THEY ARE SO RAPIDLY DOING THIS
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO STOP ANY.
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WERE DOING
THIS TO OTHER.
FAMILIES LOOKING FOR CARE AND
OTHER STATES AND ARE PUMPING AND
DUMPING PATIENCE -- INTO OUR
TREATMENT CENTERS IT'S A GREAT
BILL AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS TOM
RENT FREE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THIS IS ABOUT
PROTECTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM THE DISEASE OF
ADDICTION.
THAT KEEP THEM FROM BEING
EXPLOITED BY UNSCRUPULOUS
OPERATORS ARE YOU KNOW WHO ARE A
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HIM AND AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO TO REALLY
GOOD TREATMENT -- QUALITY
TREATMENT WHICH MOST OF OUR
PROVIDERS WHO DO PROVIDE WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THESE PEOPLE
TREATMENT THEY NEED THANKS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITH THIS IS A
SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SIR MOTIONS.
OKAY AS CENTER LABEL THIS MOVE
THE BILL US CENTER BATES WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES JUST THANK YOU
I THINK OF THIS IS REALLY A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL -- TO ENSURE THAT
OF THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING
TREATMENT AND IN PARTICULAR THE
PARENTS THAT SEND THEIR CHILDREN
TO THESE FACILITIES WITH HIGH
HOPES AND NOW THERE BEEN SOME
HORRIFIC.
OUTCOMES WIND OF THESE
FACILITIES ACTUALLY WERE
MARKETEERSVERSUS -- HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SO I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU AGAIN THANK AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS IS
BEEN SECOND BY CENTER LEYVA.
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL.
IN HI AND I STONE.
STONE I DORADO [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HER TITLE.
HER TOTAL FIVE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MORNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WHAT'S THE TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB [inaudible]
SIX OH FOUR THANK YOU.
ALLERGIES GETTING TO ME TODAY --
SB SIX OH FOUR REQUIRES THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
I TO ESTABLISH CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE REVISED COUNTIES WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND BEST
PRACTICES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION.
SIXTY THREE AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT WAS ENACTED
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE THAT
PROVIDED THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY
IN MANY YEARS. TO EXPAND COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS FOR ALL
POPULATIONS CHILDREN TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH ADULTS OLDER ADULTS
FAMILIES AND UNDERSERVED.
IT ALSO DESIGNED. TO BE WAS ALSO
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE
OF PREVENTION.
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT SERVICES INCLUDING THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
TECHNOLOGY AN ENHANCEMENT OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORK FORCE TO
SUPPORT IT.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION IS TASKED WITH
OVERSEEING THE IMPLEMENTED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT
RECENTLY HAS BEEN PROACTIVE IN
WORKING TO PROVIDE MORE
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTY SO
STAKEHOLDERS.
OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS FOR THE
COURSE OF THEIR CONVERSATIONS.
LOCALS HAVE A HOUSE THE
COMMISSION TO APPROVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ON HOW COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY DELIVERING SERVICES.
MODEL APPROACHES TO SERVICE
DELIVERY AND ACCESS TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY OF CARE NOW SUCH SB.
SIX OH FOUR DIRECTS THE
COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH CENTERS
OF EXCELLENCE TO PROVIDE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
COLLABORATE.
WITH COUNTIES ON BEST PRACTICES.
THE BILL WILL IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF CARE THAT INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE THAT IS TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TODAY WITH ME OF THOUGHT TOBY
EWING WITH THE COMMISSION AND HE
IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
ON THIS PROCESS.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIGNATURE CHAIR MEMBERS TOTALING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WHEN I THINK THE
SENATOR FOR INTRODUCING THE
LEGISLATION -- AS I THINK WE'VE
TESTIFIED BEFORE YOU IN THE PAST
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
REALLY BEEN WORKING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S WORKING IN THE
COUNTY IS WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND
WHAT KINDS OF STRATEGIES THE
STATE CAN PUT IN PLACE TO HELP
THE COUNTIES.
AS FOR REFLECT IN THE ANALYSIS
LAST YEAR WE UNDERTOOK A WHOLE
SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH COUNTIES
TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE.
AN OVERWHELMINGLY WHAT WE HEARD
IS THEY STRUGGLE TO LEARN WHAT'S
WORKING IN OTHER COUNTIES WAS
WORKING IN OTHER STATES.
AND THAT OFTEN THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TIME OF THE CAPACITY TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES AND TO SECURE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IT'S OFTEN
AVAILABLE.
NOPE THROUGH OBTUSE FOR
CONSULTANTS -- WHAT THEY'VE SAID
IS THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IF
THE STATE COULD PUT IN PLACE
STRATEGIES?
AND I WOULD AND I WOULD HAVE TO
CLEAN FOCUS ON ISSUES OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH REDUCING CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVEMENT REDUCING CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT HOMELESSNESS.
THE COMMISSION IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
SIGNALS THAT IS THAT OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM REALLY IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE COUNTIES AND IF THE
STATE CAN AND INVEST IN
STRATEGIES TO HELP THE COUNTIES
IMPROVE.
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
MEETING OUR STATEWIDE GOALS AS
WELL AS COUNTY GOALS AND SO --
BECAUSE THE BILL RELEASED LAYS
OUT AN AGENDA THAT SAYS HOW CAN
WE BEGIN TO WORK WITH A COUNTIES
TO UNDERSTAND KEY PRIORITIES BUT
PUT THAT STRATEGY IN PLACE AND
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
THE IT AND THIS WAS RATES A
LITTLE BIT IN THE ANALYSIS.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A CONCRETE
PLAN OF WHAT THE TACKLE SYSTEM
TRIED IT WOULD LOOK LIKE BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE DIFFERENT IN
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH THAT
WOULD BE IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT AND SO WHAT
WE APPRECIATED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY ENGAGE WITH THE
COUNTIES TO DESIGN A T..
A STRATEGY IT'S GOING TO BE
SPECIFIC ON INDIVIDUAL TOPICS AS
YOU KNOW AS A PHYSICIAN OF THE
VERY DIFFERENT WORKING WITH THE
HOSPITAL'S THAN WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS.
WITH THAT VERY MUCH ASK YOUR
IPHONE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TEAM
OR THE MICROPHONE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NO ONE OF BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE AND A CENTER MITCHELL.
HAD A QUICK QUESTION MY HAVE A
STAFF NOTE THAT SAYS THAT --
THIS WOULD BE ALLOWED TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO ESTABLISH
THE CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE.
IS IT ARE WE TAPPING PROP FIFTY
THREE DOLLARS OR GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS PROP SIXTY
THREE OKAY THAT WAS MY
ASSUMPTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES CHECKING WITH MY STAFF TO
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SIR MOTION OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER STONE.
AND I THINK THAT ANOTHER
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK A AND
TRYING TO BE SURE WE SPREAD BEST
PRACTICES ABOUT THE CENTER BATES
WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES.
I JUST -- TO CLEAR FIND GIVE
MORE COMFORT I LEAVE THE
EXISTING LAW ACTUALLY PUT THAT
INTO THE EXISTING LAW THAT THE
THAT FUNDS PROP SIXTY THREE WAS
THERE TO PROVIDE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THROUGH THE IN APP.
YEAH.
ALTHOUGH THE BUILDING THANK YU.
OKAY SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE A SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AND I AND I STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
GROVE HER TADO THE TOTAL I AM
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'M SORRY.
MONNING MONNING AYE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE.
OKAY SO THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES -
IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER BATES.
SIR TAHOE HE FARED.
A YEAR NEXT UP.
SO AND A SYMBOL TAKE THEM AND
FOLLOW ORDER NUMBER CENTER RIGHT
OKAY SO -- FIRST WILL SURVIVE
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TWO OF THE
SEVEN QUE.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU WISH.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START
OFF BY A STEP IN THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED ON PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SB TWO ZERO SEVEN ONE WHAT
INSURANCE AND PARDON ME ENSURE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
ACCESS TO ASTHMA PREVENTION
SERVICES BY A LOT ALLOWING MEDI
CAL. TO REIMBURSE FOR ASTHMA
EDUCATION AND HOME TRIGGER
ASSESSMENTS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS THE
HIGHEST ASKED MY RATE FOR
CHILDREN IN THE NATION OVER FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND VALLEY
RESIDENTS HAVE ASMAN OF THOSE A
HUNDRED AND FIVE ARE. HUNDRED
FIVE THOUSAND OUR CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HAS THE HIGHEST RATES OF ER
VISITS PER CHILDHOOD ASTHMA IN
THE STATE.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN ALMOST 90% OF
ALL PEDIATRIC ASTHMA EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS IN CALIFORNIA
WERE CHILDREN COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE
IN MY DISTRICT NEED BETTER
ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE ASTHMA
PREVENTION STRATEGIES LIKE AS MY
EDUCATION AND ACCESS TO HOME
VISITS FROM QUALIFIED COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS WHO CAN HELP
FAMILIES MANAGE THEIR ASTHMA.
AND PREVENT ASTHMA ATTACKS.
HOME VISITATION FOR PEOPLE WITH
POORLY CONTROLLED ASTHMA CAN
HELP BOTH MINIMIZE THE RISK OF
ASTHMA ATTACKS FOR LOW INCOME.
FAMILIES AND HELP REDUCE COSTS
TO THE STATE.
MEDI CAL SHOULDERS A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE ASTHMA BURDEN
WITH THE ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS AND ROLLED MEDI CAL
WHO HAVE POORLY CONTROLLED
ASTHMA.
HAVE BEEN REPORTED IN EMERGENCY
ROOM.
VISIT URGENT CARE VISIT FOR IT.
TWENTY TEN TOTAL CHARGES FOR
ASTHMA HOTTEST HOSPITALIZATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA WERE OVER ONE
BILLION.
PRINCE LOST TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE MILLION AND WE JUST TO
CARE FOR CHILDREN WHO MISSED
SCHOOL DUE TO ASTHMA.
AND SCHOOLS LOST OVER THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION IN ATTENDANCE
REVENUE.
SB TWO ZERO SEVEN WILL HELP
INSURE OUR MOST VULNERABLE HAVE
ACCESS TO ASTHMA MANAGEMENT
EDUCATION AND PREVENTION
TECHNIQUES TO HELP REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF AN ASTHMA ATTACK.
AS WELL AND SURE COST SAVINGS TO
THE STATE.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME AND JOEL.
OUR OFFICE WITH THE REGIONAL
ASTHMA MANAGEMENT AND PREVENTION
AND EMILY LOPEZ WITH THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA AS A COLLABORATIVE.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER TACO --
WOULDN'T SUPPORT TO MAXIMUM SIX
MINUTES TOGETHER.
MAYBE YOU HAVEN'T AS THEIR TO
MENTION MY NAME IS DELIVERS WITH
RAMP REGIONAL ASTHMA MANAGEMENT
AND PREVENTION AND WERE WHEN THE
CO SPONSORS OF SP.
TWO SEVEN AS MRS SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM AND DRIVER
OF HEALTH CARE COSTS LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS LIKE THE NEARLY TWO
MILLION MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
DIAGNOSIS ASTHMA.
HAVE HIGHER AS A SEVERITY POR
ASPEN CONTROL AND HIGHER RATES
OF ASTHMA EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
AS MY EDUCATION AND TRIGGER
MEDIATION HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
REDUCE HAS AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND IMPROVE
OVERALL HEALTH OUTCOMES.
BUT REDUCING MORE COSTLY MEDICAL
USE STUDIES HAVE ALSO
DEMONSTRATED THESE INTERVENTIONS
PROVIDE A RETURN ON INVESTMENT
THAT CAN REACH OVER TEN DOLLARS
FOR EACH DOLLAR INVESTED.
BUT THE NATIONAL ASTHMA CLINICAL
GUIDELINES AS WELL AS THE
NATIONAL COMMUNITY PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TASK FORCE RECOMMEND
THESE SERVICES.
MEDICAL BENEFICIARIES OF POORLY
CONTROLLED ASTHMA NEED MORE
SUPPORT.
AND INCREASING ACCESS TO AS A
PREVENTIVE SERVICES IN THE HOME
IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO PROVIDE
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU HONORABLE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
EMILY LOCUSTS AND I'M A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER --
PROVIDING AS MY HOME VISITS FOR
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASK MY
COLLABORATIVE.
THIS IS ON ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES ADMONISHMENT IN A
NUMBER OF COLONIES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
I DON'T KNOW TO REGULARLY --
PERFORMING HOME VISITS WHERE
SOMEONE IS STRUGGLING WITH FOR
THE CONTROL ASTHMA -- IN MANY
CASES THEY HAVE A FOR ANY VISITS
WITH EMERGENCY THE PHARMACY OR
BEING HOSPITALIZED FOR US Mà --
DANCE MOSCOW'S THAN TO ME SCHOOL
OR WORK -- MY JOB IS TO HELP.
GATHER ICELANDER CONTROL I DO SO
BY PROVIDING AS MY LOCATION.
THE RAIN FORCES THE CLINICAL
GUIDANCE THEY'RE GETTING FROM
THE DOCTOR'S.
I ALSO HELP IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
ASTHMA TRIGGERS AND IN THEIR
HOME BY PERFORMING A HOMER FROM
AN ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT.
AND PROVIDING RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW TO REDUCE THEM. FOR EXAMPLE
I CAN GIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
ASTHMA AND WHAT HAPPENS IN A
LOANS DURING THE LAST MY TACK.
I CAN ALSO EXPLAIN THE ROLE THAT
TREE GETS PLAY.
AND I WILL LOOK AROUND THE HOME
AND SEE WHAT TRIGGERS ARE
PRESENT -- I ALSO PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT LINK TO PATIENT LINK
TO PATIENTS A DOCTOR FOR EXAMPLE%
IF A PATIENT FILLED HER EYES
MIGHT BE GETTING WARS.
I WILL HELP THEM.
AGAIN RECONNECT THE WOULD HAVE
PHYSICIANS FOR ADDITIONAL HELP --
I RECENTLY I RECENTLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH FOR A
FAMILY MERCED CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE FATHER AND HIS THREE
CHILDREN HAVE ASTHMA.
DAD AS MY WHAT I'M GOING TROLL
AND HAD NO MEDICATION FOR
HIMSELF OR THE XIN ALI HE HAD
MISSED THREE WEEKS OF WORK --
DUE TO HIS ASTHMA AND EVEN
THOUGH HE VISITED THE EMERGENCY
APARTMENT IN ORDER CAN RECENTLY --
HE WASN'T ABLE TO EXPRESS HIS
CONCERNS DUE TO LANGUAGE VERY
USED -- TO AND HE WAS -- THREE
TO DURING EMERGENCY WON'T BAD
MEDICATION WERE NOT PROVIDED FOR
US MONTH.
AFTER ONLY IN OUR HOME VISITING
PROGRAM.
I WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE THE FAMILY
WITHOUT MEDICATION TO HELP THEM
OVER COLIN WHICH FOR A REAR BACK
UP BY TAKING THEM TO THE DOCTORS
IN INTERPRETING FOR THEM.
AND A SPRING IN THE DOCTOR'S THE
FINDINGS IN THE HOME -- AS A
RESULT THE FAMILY IMPATIENT UP
NOT HE'S IMPROVING HIS IN HIS
HEALTH.
HOME ENVIRONMENT AND
COMMUNICATION WITH HIS PHYSICIAN
AND THE PATIENT HAS RETURNED TO
WAR IN THE SODOMITES FULLY
CONTROL.
BECAUSE OF THESE HE HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY HE WAS HE
PRESENT THE LAST SESSION.
ABOUT HE HAS PROVIDED OFF THE
FOLLOWING STATEMENT WHICH I WILL
REACH OF FAST. FIVE UP FIRST THE
NUMBER IS I'M A PART I'M A
FATHER OF MY FAMILY OF FIVE IN
WHICH FOUR OF US HAVE ASTHMA.
AND THIS IS MY STORY BECAUSE OF
I BECAUSE OF A DECLINE IN MY
HEALTH I AS UNABLE TO WORK FOR
THREE WEEKS AFTER MEETING EMILY
LOPEZ IN.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASK MICHAEL
NUMBER T. IN PROGRAM.
CHECK COMMA SHE ACCOMPANY ME TO
THE CLINIC I DO NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AND SHE WAS ABLE TO
INTERPRET FOR ME THE DOCTOR
PRESCRIBED MEDICATION IN MY
CONTROLLING HEALERS.
AND EMILY SHOW ME HOW TO USE IT
PROPERLY AND NOW I FEEL VERY GO
AND I HOPE THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
THESE.
GROW BIGGER ARMY SUPPORT OFFICE
PROGRAM IN THIS BILL BECAUSE HE
HAS HELPED ME SO MUCH AND I'M
VERY GRATEFUL.
I'M PROUD OF MY WORK -- IN --
PROUD OF HELPING THIS FAMILY I
THINK EVERY PERSONAL WERE POORLY
CONTROL ASK MY THE SURF TO GET
HELP THE NEEDS TO LIVE A HEALTHY
LIFE.
ARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR US MY
PREVENTATIVE SERVICEABLE HELPED
TREMENDOUSLY -- THIS IS WHY I'M
HERE REPRESENTED THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA HAS MIKE WHATEVER T.
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DEATH CAM RANH ON HOW THE ACT OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMBER KING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI KELLY MAC MILLAN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY CARE
COALITION AND MEMORIAL HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GEN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE DEARBORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GALEANO CHILDREN NOW ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF SB TWO OH SEVEN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINDA TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
WORK ANOTHER CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW FROM THE MAP THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ALSO
A STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY WITH THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE OF QUESTIONS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAS THEIR
STONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S
IDEA -- AND AND YOUNG LADY --
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU FOR FOR
GOING OUT INTO THESE HOMES AND
AND GIVING THESE PEOPLE SOME
HOPE THAT -- THEIR ASTHMA CAN BE --
TAKING CARE OF THROUGH.
AVOIDING CERTAIN TRIGGERS AND
MAYBE EVEN TRYING THEM OUT A
USER AND HATERS CORRECTLY A LOT
OF PEOPLE DON'T NOT A USER AND
HATERS TO RESCUE THEM.
BUT CAN YOU TELL ME -- IN ALL
YOUR BUSINESS WHAT WHAT ARE THE
MOST COMMON TRIGGERS THAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN HOMES THAT ARE YOU
BEEN ABLE TO CORRECT.
YES ARE DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
TRIGGERS -- THERE IS MOST
COMMONLY SMALL -- INTO FAMILIES
THERE IS A LOT OF HUMIDITY AND
HOMES WHILE WE'RE IN THE HOME
VISITS I PROVIDE A MONEY TO YOU
MAY NEED TO MONITOR AND I THINK
THE PATIENT ROOM BY ROOM AND
CHECK THE TEMPERATURE -- THEM
THE HUMIDITY SO WE HAVE FIND
HIGH LEVELS OF HUMIDITY AND THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT
AND THAT'S ONE OF TRIGGER STILL --
MAINLY -- ENVIRONMENTAL MOLE
IMMUNITY AND POLLEN DUST WHICH
IS OUT OF THE HOME BY THE BRING
IT TO THE ALBUM WHEN YOU.
FIND SMOKING IN THE HOME -- HOW
DO YOU HOW DO YOU ADDRESS OUT
WITH THE PARENTS AND?
ARE YOU ABLE TO CONVINCE THEM
THAT-- THE SMOKE IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR CHILDREN
THOUSAND NIGHTS BEST THE SMOKE
OUTSIDE IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DOING IT -- TIDY MITIGATE THAT
YES OUR I PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEM --
BASICALLY YOU UP BY EXPLAINING
THE SECONDARY EFFECTS AND ALL
THE SMOKE AS THEY GO HAND -- AND
ONE OF THE COMMISSION WILL BE IF
THEY WERE TOO SMALL TO SMOKE
OUTSIDE THE HOME THEY ALWAYS
WERE LIKE A JACK CAN MAKE IT
THAT THEY CAN LEAVE OUT SIGHING
AND WASH OUR HANDS BEFORE COMING
INSIDE THE HOME.
AND ALWAYS WILL PROVIDE LIKE --
NOT SMOKING CESSATION FLYERS.
POURED INTO YOU KNOW IF THEY
EVER TAKE THE INITIATIVE TO
LOCAL AND COLTON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK
YOU HOME WITH THE BONUS OF
CORPORATE APPRECIATE TO BRING
FORWARD OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO.
THANK YOU -- I ALSO WANT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I HAVE
A SISTER WHO WAS IN THE HOSPITAL
MANY TIMES DURING HER LIFETIME
DUE TO SEVERE AUS MINE IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN REALLY -- INSTRUMENTAL
TO HAVE HAD SOMEONE COME OUT AND
TELL MY PARENTS HOW DO WE
MITIGATE SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
THE CAUSES AND OF COURSE WE
DIDN'T AND SHE'S AN ADULT AND
STILL SUFFERS FROM VERY SEVERE
ASTHMA.
I STILL THINK YOU THANK YOU AND
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED THANK
YOU.
HE'S SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS I WANT
THANK YOU SIR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR SOMEONE TO ACTUALLY I
USED TO CO CHAIR THE PEDIATRIC
ASTHMA PROGRAM UC DAVIS.
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
ACTUALLY GOT THE COMMUNITY IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT TALKING TO PEOPLE
IN THE CLINIC SO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING THE BILL -- THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR STONE I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AND HER
DAUGHTER.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS MOVE BY CENTER
STONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AND I AND II STONE.
STONE ONLINE THE RAZA
[inaudible]
GROWTH.
HER TADO.
I HEARD TOTO AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO BY.
THE BILL HAS SIX BUT IT'S ENOUGH
TO GET IT OUT WILL BE HOLDING
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
LET'S MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
TWO SIXTY THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB TWO SIXTY
THE BILL AIMS TO HELP EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS AVOID COVERAGE GAPS
WHEN THE UNDERGO LIFE CHANGES
THAT TRICKLED LOSSES AND
COVERAGE.
IN MY DISTRICT ARE FOR COUNTIES
FRESNO KERN KEANE'S AND TULARE
ALMOST HALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE ON MEDI CAL.
MANY OF THEM WILL UNDERGO LIFE
EVENTS LIKE GETTING JOBS ARE
ANYMORE AT THEIR JOB AT THEIR
JOBS WHICH CAN CAUSE THEM TO
LOSE MEDICAL COVERAGE AND BECOME.
BOND YOU KNOW ELIGIBLE FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THIS HAPPENS PEOPLE CAN
EXPERIENCE A GAP IN COVERAGE AND
IF THEY ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE?
SB TWO SIXTY MAKES IT EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO GET CONNECTED TO
COVERAGE.
FIRST THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS TO
TRANSFER LIST OF PEOPLE WHO LOSE
COVERAGE FOR ANY REASON TO COVER
CALIFORNIA SO COVERED CALIFORNIA
CAN DIRECTLY.
OUT REACH TO THOSE CONSUMERS AND
HELP THEM GET ENROLLED IN A
HEALTH PLAN.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD ENSURE
PEOPLE LEAVING MEDI CAL AND
OTHER DH CS ADMINISTER PROGRAMS
CAN SEAMLESSLY AND ROLE AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA WITHOUT GAPS
IN COVERAGE BY AUTO ASSIGNING
THEM INTO LOWER COST SOBRE TEAR
HEALTH PLANS.
AND CORPORATE CALIFORNIA SB TWO
SIXTY BUILT UPON THE GREAT WORK
THAT OUR STATE HAS ALREADY DONE
TO ENSURE CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS.
TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY AND
COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE IN THE
SIMPLEST AND MOST STREAMLINED
WAY.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
STRESS OVER FINDING AN AND
ROLLING AND YOU COVERAGE AND
THEY SHOULD NOT RISKS BEING
UNINSURED.
SB TWO SIXTY AIMS TO PREVENT
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE GAPS
PENSION A SMOOTHER TRANSITION
BETWEEN MEDI CAL AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS.
TODAY HAVE CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
JUNE AT DS WHAT HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA GEN FLORI WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DONNA WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAMBERS
AND JDS HERE FOR HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA THE SEE WHAT
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB
TWO SIXTY WHICH WOULD ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS KEEP THEIR COVERAGE.
AND ALSO TO PREVENT THEM FROM.
EXPERIENCING GAPS IN COVERAGE
WHENEVER DAY EXPERIENCE LIFE
EVENTS THAT CAUSE THEM TO
ACTUALLY LOSE HEALTH INSURANCE.
EVERYDAY WHENEVER CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE LIFE EVENTS LIKE
LOSING THEIR JOBS CHANGING JOBS.
BECOMING A WIDOW GETTING MARRIED
OR EVEN TURNING THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX THAT COULD TRIGGER A
LOSS AND HEALTH INSURANCE WHICH
COULD THEN TRIGGER A COVERAGE
GAP.
SB TWO SIXTY BILLS ON EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW THE ALREADY
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO PROVIDE A NOTICE TO
CONSUMERS OF AVAILABILITY OF
COVERAGE THROUGH MEDICARE ALL OF
OUR COVER CALIFORNIA.
REGARDLESS OF THEREASON AS TO
WHY THEY LOST THE COVERAGE.
SENDING A NOTICE IS A GOOD FIRST
STEP BUT SB TWO SIXTY TAKES OF
STEP FURTHER BY MAKING IT EASIER
FOR COVER CALIFORNIA TO ENGAGE
WITH THOSE CONSUMERS.
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT THEIR PLAN
OPTIONS AND ALSO POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
AND AS WELL AS HOW THEY CAN
ENROLL IN THAT COVERAGE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT SB TWO
SIXTY AND NOW ALL NOW TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEGE AND FOR A
WHOLE TALK ABOUT THE MEDI CAL TO
COVER CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN FLOORS
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- THAT PART IN FROM
MOVING FROM MEDICAID TO COVER
CALIFORNIA SLIGHTLY MORE
TECHNICAL -- AS SOME OF YOU
RECALL THE SOME OF THE EARLIEST
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHICH SOME
OF YOU WERE INVOLVED IN.
WE ENVISIONED A SYSTEM WHERE A
SUBSIDIZED HEALTH PROGRAMS WOULD
BE LINKED SUCH THAT WHEN SOMEONE
WAS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR ONE
PROGRAM THEY WOULD BE
AUTOMATICALLY EVALUATED FOR THE
OTHER AVAILABLE PROGRAM SO THEY
COULD AND I QUOTE.
MOVE BETWEEN PROGRAMS WITHOUT
ANY BREAKS IN COVERAGE AND
WITHOUT BEING REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE ANY FORMS DOCUMENTS OR
OTHER INFORMATION OR UNDERGO
VERIFICATION THAT'S DUPLICATIVE
OR OTHERWISE UNNECESSARY.
THIS IS THE CURRENT LAW.
MOST OF THIS IS WORKING WHEN
SOMEONE'S INCOME GOES UP SUCH A
THEY ARE NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL THE COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS DO INDEED DETERMINE IF
THAT PERSON IS ELIGIBLE FOR
COVER CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION.
THEY PUT THAT PERSON IN THE
ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM IN THE COVER
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
THE COULD THE ELIGIBILITY SYSTEM
CAL HERE'S KNOWS WHAT THEIR
INCOME IS AND KNOWS HOW MUCH
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE ARE
AVAILABLE.
FOR HOWEVER BECAUSE OF HOW THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS INVOLVING
PLAN SELECTION OVERLAY WITH OUR
STATE LAW REGARDING TIMELY
NOTICE WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR MEDI CAL
OFTEN HAVE LESS THAN TEN DAYS
INCLUDING WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS.
TO AFFIRMATIVELY SELECT A PLAN
OR THEY WILL FACE A GAP IN
COVERAGE OF AT LEAST A MONTH.
PLAN SELECTION MAY NOT SEEM LIKE
AN INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIER BUT
PEOPLE OFTEN DO NOT KNOW WHERE
TO GET HELP OR UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY MUST DO TO EFFECTUATE THEIR
COVERAGE.
PROVIDER NETWORKS BETWEEN MEDI
CAL AND COVER CALIFORNIA DON'T
ALWAYS MATCH.
SADLY WE HAVE ALSO SEEN A NUMBER
OF CONSUMERS WHO ENDED UP IN THE
E. R. DURING THAT GAP PERIOD AND
CURRENT MEDICAL BILLS THAT THEY
COULDN'T PAY.
SOME OF THEM HAD ALREADY
ENROLLED IN COVER CALIFORNIA BUT
THEIR COVERAGE WOULDN'T BE
EFFECTIVE TILL THE NEXT MONTH.
SB TO SIXTY IS MERELY THE
TECHNICAL FIX IT THREADS THE
NEEDLE BETWEEN THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW BY SPLITTING UP THE
ENROLLMENT DAY IN A PLAN TO
AVOID THE GAP IN COVERAGE AND
EFFECTUATE IN OUR PAYMENT DATE.
TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE TIME TO MAKE
THE RIGHT CHOICE FOR THEM AS AS
PERMITTED BY FEDERAL LAW.
SB TWO SIXTY REQUIRES COVER
CALIFORNIA TO ENROLL EOPLE
COMING FROM MEDI CAL INTO THE
CHEAPEST SOBRE PLAN AS A PLACE
HOLDER TO AVOID THE GAP IN
COVERAGE.
THEY WILL THEN SEND A NOTICE
TELLING PEOPLE IF THEY LIKE THE
PLAN HAS BEEN THAT HAS BEEN
CHOSEN WHEN THEIR PAYMENT IS DUE.
IF THEY DON'T WANT THAT PLAN
THEY CAN USE THE REMAINDER OF
THEIR SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIOD
TO CHANGE TO A DIFFERENT PLAN OR
IF THEY PREFER NOT PAY AND NOT
ENROLL IN ANYTHING AT ALL.
THIS BUILDS ON A SYSTEM THAT
COVERED CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
USED TO HELP PEOPLE RENEW WHEN
THEIR CURRENT PLAN IS NOT
AVAILABLE.
CONSUMERS WILL STILL HAVE ALL
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM TODAY
BUT THE DEFAULT WILL BE THE T.
CHEAPEST PLAN WITH THE MOST
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN
COVER CALIFORNIA ARE NOT ONLY
GETTING PREMIUM ASSISTANCE.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
THE ADDITIONAL OUT OF POCKET AND
IT'S PARTICULARLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING OUT OF THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM THAT NEED ALL OF THIS
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ISSUE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- WITNESSES SUPPORT
BACK MIKE FROM -- FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
ON A MOUNTAIN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
LINDA TO NARROW ITS CALIFORNIA
PAN AT THE CALVET WORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
OF WITNESSES OPPOSITION --
ACTUALLY A MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE POSITION ON
THE BILL.
WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR ABOUT THE INTENT OF
THE BILL WE THINK IT'S LAUDABLE --
AVOIDING COVERAGE GAPS COULD
ACTUALLY HELP THE MARKET AS WELL
AS CONSUMERS.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO WORK OUT OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE IDENTIFIED SOME
OPERATIONAL ISSUES -- AND
THERE'S ONE COMPONENT OF THE
BILL THAT WE BELIEVE
UNNECESSARILY INCREASES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LOAD ON PLANNED
SO -- WE'VE HAD A GOOD FIRST
CONVERSATION WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
THAT DIALOGUE AND AND TRY TO
RESOLVE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS AT SAYING NO OTHER
WITNESS ANY WITNESS OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND DAY HERE
AT DOUBLE MOTION I CAME IN
FIGURE WHO WAS FIRST SO.
OKAY WELL IT THE SENSOR RUBIO OF
THE SECOND ALL RIGHT.
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS US --
TADA WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ABOUT A
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S EXCELLENT --
MOVING FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER RUBIO SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AND NIGHT AND I STONE.
STONE ONLINE DORADO.
GROWTH HER TADO.
A TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING THANK MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I THE BILL AS FIVE IT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR ABOUT SIX MINUTES
OKAY SO DEFINITELY ENOUGH TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE -- SEE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB [inaudible]
THREE THIRTY ONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN I AM HERE
TO PRESENT SB THREE THREE ONE
WHICH WILL REQUIRE ALL
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TO DEVELOP A
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIC
PLAN.
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ADOLESCENCE.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED A CONSTANT RISE
AND DEATHS BY SUICIDE.
ALARMINGLY YOUTH SUICIDE AND
SELF INFLICTED INJURY ARE ON THE
RISE.
AND IS THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH AMONG YOUTH AGES
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR IN THE U.
S..
IN CALIFORNIA ALMOST 20% OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING SUICIDE IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
ALMOST ONE HALF 49% OF LGBTQ
STUDENTS REPORTED SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS MORE THAN THREE TIMES
THE ESTIMATE FOR THEIR ST PEERS.
AND FRESNO COUNTY ALONE FOR EACH
TEEN WHO DIES BY SUICIDE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY YOUTH WERE
TREATED IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT FOLLOWING.
SELF INJURY.
AND MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
ADOLESCENTS THOUGHT SERIOUSLY
ABOUT AND IN THEIR LIVES.
AND FOR YOUNG WOMAN SUICIDE
RATES AMONG TEENAGE GIRLS HAVE
HAD A FORTY YEAR HIGH.
STUDIES SHOW THAT PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION EFFORTS CAN
HELP AVOID A SUICIDAL CRISIS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS
FROM PAPER SECTORS LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HEALTH CARE YOUTH
JUSTICE PUBLIC SERVICE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING TO HELP FORM
STRATEGIC PREVENTION ORIENTED
PLANS.
WHEN COUNTIES IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIC SUICIDE PREVENTION
PLANS THE RESULT IN FEWER
SUICIDE DEATHS AND THEIR COUNTY?
FOR EXAMPLE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH HAS HAD A CONCERTED
SUICIDE PREVENTION EFFORTS SINCE.
TWENTY TEN HAS SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN SUICIDE
DEATHS.
HOWEVER SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
ONLY SEVEN OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE ADOPTED
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIC
PLANS.
MORE PROACTIVE ACTION IS NEEDED
TO HELP ADDRESS SUICIDAL
BEHAVIOR AND PREVENT TEEN
SUICIDE.
INCLUDE ANY PARTICULAR FOCUS ON
SUICIDE PREVENTION FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH.
SB THREE THREE ONE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES ARE TAKING THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO HELP PREVENT
TEEN SUICIDE.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME AGING
SHELTON WITH THE STATE BURKE
INSTITUTE TEND TO FORMER SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SUPERVISOR VIC.
THE DOCUMENT SIDE.
OKAY CLOSE OKAY TO TESTIFY ON SB
THREE THREE ONE THANK YOU HE
CENTER TADA WITNESSES SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADRIN SHELTON WITH THE
STEINBERG AND CITY WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL.
THREE THREE ONE SB THREE THREE
ONE PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK TO
COORDINATE SUICIDE PREVENTION
EFFORTS AND EXPAND UPON THEM.
WE BELIEVE AS A STATE WE NEED TO
BE MUCH MORE PROACTIVE AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO REVERSE
THIS ALARMING INCREASE IN
SUICIDES.
ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA FROM
EARLIER THIS YEAR'S SUICIDES IN
THE U. S. ROSE BY 33% FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NEARLY FORTY THREE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS DIED BY
SUICIDE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS
IS A 50% INCREASE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THIS IS
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST FIGURES
FROM THE US CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND FOR PEOPLE UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTY FIVE SUICIDE IS
THE SECOND.
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOLLOWING
UNINTENTIONAL INJURIES.
SB THREE THREE ONE REQUIRES THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN.
FORMING A COUNTY SUICIDE
PREVENTION TASKFORCE AND WRITING
A SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN CAN
HELP IN IDENTIFYING GAPS WERE
MISSING ACTIONS AND BETTER
PROMOTE AND COMMUNICATE SUICIDE
PREVENTION ACTIONS.
COUNTIES THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLANS HAVE
REPORTED TO US BUT THE PLANS
HAVE HELPED THEM TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND SUICIDE IN THEIR
COUNTIES. TO HELP GET BETTER
GUIDE COUNTY EFFORTS DONE IF I
GOALS AND BE ABLE TO MEASURE
PROGRESS.
WE BELIEVE THIS FRAMEWORK AND SB
THREE THREE ONE WHICH REQUIRES A
MULTIFACETED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM WILL
SUPPORT OUR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
SUICIDE.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
SO FOR THE RECORD I'M VICO
JACKIE AND I MANY FORMER PALO
ALTO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND
MAYOR.
WHEN I WAS IN OFFICE ONE OF MY
CHILDREN KILLED HIMSELF?
STILL NOT EASY TO SAY -- BUT I
ALSO LIVE IN A CITY THAT IF SOME
OF YOU KNOW WE'VE EXPERIENCED TO
TEEN SUICIDE CLUSTERS.
SO I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK OVER
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS --
NATIONALLY IN THIS STATE
REGIONALLY IN IN MY LOCAL AREA
ABOUT SUICIDE PREVENTION.
BUT THIS BILL I THINK IS ONE OF
THOSE SEMINAL BILLS AND WHY DO I
THINK THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE SOME
LEGISLATION PASSED.
IN THIS.
THIS CAPITAL IS FOCUSED ON
PARTICULAR ON GROUPS ARE
PROFESSIONS AND SOME SPECIFIC
ACTIONS THIS ONE'S A MORE
PERVASIVE ACTION WILL AFFECT THE
WHOLE STATE.
ON THE AND IF.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE STATE WILL LET ME STEP
BACK FOR SECOND.
FROM IF YOU DIDN'T GET MY LETTER.
A LEAVE COPIES HERE.
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME.
TOM SOME YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN
THIS ARTICLE IT SHOWS THAT.
A LIFE EXPECTANCY IN THE UNITED
STATES IS GOING DOWN WHY IS IT
GOING DOWN BESIDES DRUG USE IT'S
SO SITES.
ARE CAUSING THAT TO HAPPEN.
IS IT A PROBLEM THAT
CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS
REPORT THAT CAME OUT IN TWENTY
ELEVEN SAID THAT AT LEAST FIFTY
ONE POINT 2% OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE HAD THEIR LIVES IMPACTED BY
A SUICIDE.
IT'S THE MAJORITY NOT THE
MINORITY.
WHAT DOES THIS DOCUMENT CHAU?
IT SHOWS THE FIRST PAGE SHOWS
SUICIDE DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S THIS.
IT'S GOING UP EVERY YEAR AND HAS
BEEN.
IN THIS CASE FOR THE TEN YEARS --
SHOW. TO COMPARE THAT WITH.
WITH -- HOMICIDES.
THE CALIFORNIA IT'S DOUBLE.
WE HAVE A FAR BIGGER PROBLEM
WITH SUICIDE CAN WE DO WITH
HOMICIDES -- IN THIS IS FOR THE
REASON WHY WE WANT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WE THINK THAT.
IT'S IT PROVIDES THE ABILITY TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED FRANKLY A
LONG TIME AGO -- I TOOK AN OATH --
I HAD A SAYING THAT WAS
CONSTANTLY I HAD TO LOOK AT WHEN
I WAS VOTING ON LEGISLATION LIKE
YOU AND IT SAID I HAD TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT MY RESIDENTS
HEALTH.
WELFARE AND SAFETY EVERY COUNTY
HAS SEVERAL SPOTS ABILITY FOR
THE THE RESIDENTS EVEN IF THEY
WANT TO SAY THAT THEY DON'T
BECAUSE IF THEY WANT TO SAVE IT
SUICIDE.
ISN'T THERE -- RESPONSIBILITY --
IN SUPPORT OF CENTER HURT HER
TODD DOES COMMENTS.
WHAT'S THIS CHART IT SHOWS THE
LAST TEN YEARS OF YOUTH DEATH.
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT DID CHAU IT
SHOWS THE LAST THREE YEARS THOSE
NUMBERS ARE GOING UP UP UP
INCLUDING THE LAST REPORTABLE
YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN IS THE
HIGHEST YEAR.
MAYBE THE HIGHEST YEAR WE'VE HAD
BUT IT'S THE HIGHEST THE LAST
TEN YEARS. ONE OF THESE LAST.
TWO PAGES SHOW WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THEM.
IT SHOWS WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHERE I CO
CHAIR.
THAT EFFORT ON OUR DESKS ARE
GOING DOWN INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH
SO YOU GOT NE THING GOING LIKE
THIS AND THE OTHER ONE GOING
LIKE THIS.
SO IT SHOWS THAT DOING THIS TYPE
OF WORK IF IT'S PERVASIVE AND IF
PEOPLE -- CAN STRUCTURE CULTURE
BUT YOU CAN HAVE AN IMPACT.
THIS REPORT CARD ISSUED ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO IT'S FROM.
CALIFORNIA -- DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN IT'S CALLED
PREVENTING VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT'S IT SAY WELL ONE OF THINGS
IT SAYS FIRST OF ALL I GUESS TO
THE CREDIT OF WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IT SHOWS US
IS HAVING THE FAR LOWEST RATE OF
ANY COUNTY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO SHOWS AGAIN THAT THERE WERE
TWICE AS MANY SUICIDES TO
HOMICIDES IN THIS STATE.
IN THEY HAVE AN INTERESTING --
FACT THAT THEY CITING HERE AND
THAT IS BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE WILL
TALK ABOUT THE COST OF DOING
SOME OF THIS WORK.
THE SHOW THAT OF THE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS SPENT ANNUALLY
ON VIOLENCE -- DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION OF THAT IS.
DEALING WITH SUICIDES.
IT'S THE LARGER NUMBER YEAH AND
THERE'S AN ABILITY TO SAVE MONEY
FOR A COUNTY BY PUTTING THIS
PLAN IN PLACE I'M NOT GONNA
LEAVE THIS DOCUMENT.
YEAH BUT I QUICKLY PUT TOGETHER
THIS A RESOURCE LIST IT IT
DOESN'T PUT IN ALL OF THE
TYPICAL THINGS JUST TOOL KITS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE OUT THERE
[inaudible]
ALL FREE.
BEYOND ANYBODY CAN TAKE SOME OF
THESE AND IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM.
SO WITH THAT I HOPE YOU SUPPORT --
SB THREE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT.
MY SECOND FALLS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND A PREVIOUS CITIZEN
WHO GREW UP IN FRESNO STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MADELINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL -- I WANNA ALSO A
PRE SEE OUT THERE FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS -- I KNOW AS AN
EDUCATOR IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THAT I TODD YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN A SPIKE IN IN NOW SUICIDE
AND ATTEMPTED SUICIDE AND AS A
COUNCIL MEMBER YOU KNOW OUT NOT
SO LONG AGO WE HAD TO RESPOND.
TO A MAN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PARK IN OUR CHILDREN WALKING BY
GOING TO SCHOOL AND WHO HAD TO
WITNESS YOU KNOW A TRAGEDY BUT
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO US SOME TENNIS YOU KNOW I
WORRY ALSO THE LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBER OR LOCAL LEADER IT YOU
KNOW.
THE INITIAL THING WE'RE ALWAYS
THINKING OF HOW TO IMPLEMENTED
COST AND AND I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ALREADY.
BEEN SUCCESSFUL WITH
IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM AND I YOU
KNOW THIS IS JUST A A SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD.
ASK THAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER
MAYBE HAVING A SHARED.
WEBSITE OR OR SOMEWHERE WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THESE COUNTIES
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE PLANS THAT
ALREADY WORK THERE ALREADY IN
PRACTICE CELL.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL AND IT DOESN'T SEEM SOUL --
CUMBERSOME TED TO PUT IN PLACE
SO I DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
AND BUT THAT I'M WITH THE BILL.
THANKS THEIR MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ELSE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IN. TO THE
LOSS SIR AND APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO TRYING TO PROTECT
OTHER FAMILIES FROM.
SUFFERING SIMILAR TRAGEDIES. FOR
ANY OF YOU I GUESS THE QUESTION
BECOMES WITH THESE TRENDS THAT
CONTINUE TO GO UP PARTICULARLY
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHAT DO WE UNDER SUPPORT PUTS
THE COURSEWARE MORE YOUNG PEOPLE?
TURNING TO SUICIDE.
AN OUNCE MULTI FACTOR OWN MAYBE
NOT AN EASY QUESTION TO ANSWER
BUT WE'RE LIVING IN TROUBLED
TIMES THERE'S LOTS OF PRESSURES
OUT THERE ON ALL FRONTS BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IN YOUR RESEARCHER.
IF YOU'RE SEEING ANY TRENDS SIR.
COP ABILITIES THAT LEAD TO THIS.
SO THAT'S A DIFFICULT QUESTION
TO ANSWER -- EVEN IN SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WITH VARIOUS AGE GROUPS
IT'S A DIFFICULT QUESTION TO
ANSWER -- THE WHAT WE TRIED TO
DO WAS WHOLE FOCUS GROUP
MEETINGS.
I'M USING A THIRD PARTY
PROFESSIONAL TO CALL OUT FROM
PEOPLE WHAT'S GOING ON WE SAW A
BIG EFFECT WITH THAT WHEN WE DID
IT WITH -- MIDDLE AGED WHITE
ADULTS WHICH ARE THE GOOD WHICH
IS THE CATEGORY THE MOST TAKES
THEIR LIVES -- WE SAW
SIGNIFICANT -- HOW COME FROM
THAT?
SO THERE'S A LOT OF I'LL CALL IT
SPECULATION IT'S BEEN GIVEN
ABOUT WHY.
YOUNG PEOPLE TAKE THEIR LIVES --
MY PREFERENCES AND DO WHAT WE
DID IN OUR COUNTY -- A GROUP OF
PEOPLE LED BY SOME FOLKS FROM
STANFORD -- DEVELOPED A TOOL KIT
IT'S CALLED THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE TO SUB PREVENTION TOOL
KIT AND THEY GO OUT FOR FREE.
THE END OF WORKING SCHOOLS TO
TRY AND REDUCE SUICIDE
[inaudible]
CREATE.
ONE AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING IN THE SUCCESS.
SHOWN IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE
DO NEED TO REPLICATE THIS
STATEWIDE AND NATIONALLY.
I MEAN THE TRAGEDIES OF THE LAST
FEW WEEKS RELATED TO MASH
SHOOTINGS.
THE PARENT OF ONE OF THE VICTIMS
IN SANDY HOOK I THINK A
CLASSMATE FROM PARKLAND -- WERE
LIVING IN A THE NEW ABNORMAL IN
THIS COUNTRY OF VIOLENCE IN
PRESSURES.
I'M ALSO READ OF THE CYBER
BULLING OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN YOU MAY KNOW OF THIS THERE'S
A YOUNG MAN WHO'S DEVELOPED AN
APP. FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO WHO ARE.
TROUBLED MOM.
CAN I DON'T HAVE MORE DETAILS
BUT IS SOMETHING WE CAN PROBABLY
GET HE'S A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I THINK THEY LOST SOMEBODY
IN THEIR HIGH SCHOOL.
IN HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE
DEVELOPED AN APPLICATION THAT
NOW ANYBODY CAN DOWNLOAD ON
THEIR PHONE SO THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING ELSE WE COULD HELP.
POPULAR RISES THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
THANK YOU IN THAT THE
PROGRAMMATIC.
BE.
GLAD TO MOVE THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK OF A TWO
PEOPLE MOVING IT ALREADY --
THANK YOU I IT'S FIVE SAID FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR
PRESENTING AND FOR SHARING YOUR
PERSONAL STORY AND NINE OF SAID
AT A CAN'T SAY I KNOW BUT I'D.
I UNDERSTAND HOW THAT THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT AND I APPRECIATE YOU
SO WE COME HERE TO SHARE THAT --
AND THANK YOU CENTER DOT OF FOR
BRING THIS BILL FORD -- DEAL
SUICIDE IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH ACTUALLY WE TALK ABOUT
TEENS -- THAT'S AT THE TOP AND
SO WITH THAT -- THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY BOTH CENTERS RUBIO
AND MINING -- WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SO -- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS BILLS BEEN --
MOVED -- BY CENTERS RUBIO AND
MINING SECTORS THIS CALL THE
ROLL.
AND I AND I STONE STONE I DORADO.
GROWTH HER TADO.
TOTO I'D LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MONNING THANK MONNING AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
I THE LAST SIX VOTE SO WILL THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT.
SIR SONY READY.
OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE NINETY I
CENTER STONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR.
WHAT TIME IS A?
FOUR FIFTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT SB
FIVE NINETY I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION IS A MAJOR
PART OF CONTEMPORARY AMERICAN
LIFE HOWEVER ALCOHOL DEPENDENCE
AND ABUSE IMPOSES AN ENORMOUS
BURDEN ON INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
AND OUR STATE.
ALCOHOL ABUSE HAVE SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
HYPERTENSION DIABETES LIVER
DISEASE FEEL ABNORMALITIES AND
CANCER.
AND UNITED STATES ABOUT 5% OF
ALL DEATHS ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO
ALCOHOL MISUSE.
IT IS ALSO ESTIMATED THAT A
WHOPPING A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION IS SPENT
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ON ALCOHOL RELATED RELATED
ILLNESSES.
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES MOTOR
VEHICLE CRASHES CRIME AND OTHER
SOCIAL COSTS MORE CLOSE TO HOME
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ABOUT
19% OF CALIFORNIANS REPORTED
EITHER BINGE DRINKING OR CHRONIC
DRINKING.
SB FIVE NINETY PROVIDES JUST
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
TRY TO HELP THOSE WHO SUFFER
WITH CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
THIS BILL AMENDS A LANTERN MEN
PATRICK SHORT ACT TO INCLUDE
THOSE SUFFERING FROM ALCOHOLISM
IN THE EXISTING SCREENING
PROCESS.
THIS INCLUSION WOULD THEREFORE
ALLOW ANY PERSON INCLUDING A
PARENT SIBLING OR SPOUSE TO
PETITION A COUNTY DESIGNATED
ENTITY TO HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL OR
A LOVED.
ONE WHO IS SUFFERING FROM
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR TO OTHERS OR IS
GRAVELY DISABLED TO BE SCREENED
AND APPROPRIATELY ASSESSED.
THIS A VIOLATION WITH US
INITIATE A FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND
TENS OF TREATMENT OR
CONSERVATORSHIP IF NECESSARY.
SB FIVE NINETY IS A SMALL CHANGE
IN AN ALREADY EXISTING FRAMEWORK
OF THE LAW. TO GIVE HOPE TO
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WERE SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM.
SB FIVE NINETY GIVES HOPE TO
SAVE ONE MORE LIFE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR HEIGHT
BOAT.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESS SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NONE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED A SCENE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS I DON'T THINK
YOU CENTER SEVEN FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND FOR BRING THIS
OF ROOM FOR BILL FORD WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE YES I'M ALSO GOING TO
THINK YOU'RE STAFF FOR HELPING
US OUT WITH THIS BILL IN.
A PRESS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND IT'S BEEN -- MOVE
BY -- CENTER LEYVA SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AN HI AND I STONE.
STONE I DORADO.
GROVE HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I THINK YOU COLLEGE
RESEARCHER OKAY THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS FIVE VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL -- PUT
THE BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND CENTER STONE I THINK -- AS
SINCE THE SENATE MITCHELL ISN'T.
WILL BE RETURNING LE LATER A
HAND THE GAVEL TO YOU AND I HAVE
TO BILLS TO PRESENT [inaudible]
FOUR THREE WELCOME MISTER
CHAIRMAN I I ASSUME YOU WANT TO
TAKE THESE AND FILE ORDER SPCS
CORRECTLY THANK YOU.
WITH PERCY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- SB THREE
FORTY THREE IS A BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL HEALTH PLANS AND
HOSPITALS HAVE TO PLAY BY THE
SAME RULES AND DOES SO BY
REMOVING EXEMPTIONS AND THE LAW
THAT ALLOW KAISER PERMANENTE A
TO REPORT.
LESS INFORMATION TO REGULATORS
AND OTHER HEALTH PLANS AND
HOSPITALS.
TRANSPARENCY LAWS LIKE RATE
REVIEW AND HOSPITALS --
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES WERE COME
CREATED TO HELP PURCHASERS AND
REGULATORS MANTRA COSTS THAT
DRIVE HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUM
RATES.
ALL OTHER HEALTH PLANS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE WHAT THEY EXPECT.
WHAT THEY CALL THE MEDICAL TREND
FACTOR OR THE INCREASING COSTS
THAT WILL BE FOR THE NEXT PLAN
YEAR?
THESE ARE HOWEVER DOESN'T NEED
THE PROJECT AHEAD FOR COSTS IN
THE COMING YEAR WHICH IS WHAT
PREMIUM INCREASES ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE BASED ON INSTEAD -- KAISER
EARLY REPORTS REPORTS WHAT THE
COST EXPERIENCE WAS IN THE PAST
YEAR SO THEY'RE JUST TELLING US
WHAT HAPPENED DID NOT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN BUT YET OTHER
EVERY OTHER HEALTH PLAN HAS TO
DO THAT.
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY KAISER ALSO
DOESN'T BREAK OUT PRICES BY
CATEGORY LIKE OTHER ALL OTHER
HEALTH PLANS REQUIRED TO DO.
AND SO WHERE US OTHER PLANTS.
REPORT -- THE EXPECTED PRICE
INCREASE FOR HOSPITAL INPATIENT
HOSPITAL OUTPATIENT PHYSICIAN
SERVICES PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
LABORATORY AND RADIOLOGY KAISER
LUMPS ALMOST ALL OF THAT INTO A
SINGLE HOSPITAL INPATIENT NUMBER.
WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS THE
ONLY OTHER CATEGORY REPORTED
SEPARATELY.
WITH REGARD TO HOSPITAL
REPORTING COSTS CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE REQUIRED TO
INDIVIDUAL HOSPITAL.
EYES ARE ON THE OTHER HAND
REPORTS THESE FINANCIAL FIGURES
FOR ALL OF ITS NORTHERN OR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS IN
AGATE SO YOU GET A NUMBER FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND A NUMBER
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW HEISER HAS
MANY FACILITIES -- WITHIN EACH.
NOW.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND KAISER'S
LEVEL DIFFERENCE.
BUT THIS SPECIAL TREATMENT
OBSCURES IMPORTANT NOBLE
KNOWLEDGE -- ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON TO A VERY SIGNIFICANT PLAYER
IN THE HEALTHCARE MARKET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT ALSO DOES PROVIDE CERTAIN
ADVANTAGES THE KAISER AND
PREVENTS OUR LAWS FROM BEING
IMPLEMENTED AS THEIR INTENDED.
SO AS I MENTIONED AT KAISER
REPRESENTS ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS MORE THAN 40% OF
INSURED CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE.
SO THIS BECOMES AN INFORMATION
GAP THAT MEANS THAT STATE
REGULATORS LACTAID ON THE
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
HEALTH CARE MARKET.
AND AS HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE
TO RISE POLICY MAKERS PURCHASERS
AND CONSUMERS NEED ACCESS TO THE
SAME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
DRIVING COST INCREASES THAT
KAISER'S THEY DO AT EVERY OTHER
HOSPITAL AND HEALTH PLAN.
AND SO I WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE
THAT -- WE WANT TO WORK WITH
KAISER.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
THE KIND OF INFORMATION AT THE
RIGHT KIND OF GRANULARITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON AND
SO MANY WAYS -- WELL KAISER
CERTAINLY WILL BE.
EXPLAINING WHY THEY'RE OPPOSED --
I WOULD POINT OUT ITS BECAUSE
KAISER SO IMPORTANT AND THEY DO
SUCH IMPORTANT WORK THAT WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON SO
I HAVE WITH ME MICHELLE COMPARE
WITH SCA YOU CALIFORNIANS
SPONSORED THIS BILL TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHELLE GOT IT I WITH THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION AND AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUED
TO OUTPACE WAGES AND INFLATION.
AND PUT A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON
WORKERS.
WE REPRESENT WORKERS FROM BOTH
ACT HEISER AND ALSO NUMEROUS
KAISER MEMBERS IN BOTH THE
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE SECTORS.
AND ARE SPONSORING SB THREE
FORTY SIX THREE FORTY THREE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT ALL
INSURERS AND HEALTH PLANS.
AND HOSPITALS NEED TO BE ON A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
HEALTH CARE COST DRIVERS.
AT THIS POINT KAISER HAS A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO A TRANSPARENCY WITH
RESPECT TO OTHER PLANS AND ALSO
VIS A VIS LARGE PURCHASERS WHO
HAVE TO NEGOTIATE WITH KAISER
FOR THEIR RATES -- TODAY'S LARGE
GROUP RATE REVIEW REPORTING
SCHEME IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND I WOULD
LOVE TO DEMYSTIFY IT INSURERS
ROLL ALL OF THEIR COSTS UP INTO
A SINGLE AGGREGATED.
RATE FOR THE ENTIRE STATE IN THE
LARGE GROUP MARKET AND AS DOCTOR
PAN MENTIONED THEY HAVE THEIR
REQUIRED BY LAW TO BREAK IT OUT
IN SIX CATEGORIES INCLUDING.
WHAT HOUSE PHYSICIANS -- KEMP
ARE A COMPONENT OF THEIR RATE
HOW.
INPATIENT AND OUTPATIENT
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND THEN ALSO
LAB IN RADIOLOGY THAT'S IT FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ROLL ALL OF THAT UP INTO ONE
NUMBER.
AND KAISER HAS NOT DONE THAT FOR
THE LAST THREE YEARS THAT WE'VE
HAD LARGE GROUP RATE REVIEW IN
CALIFORNIA -- TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S DRIVING IN THE RATE
INCREASES FOR FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE LAST.
THREE YEARS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
EVERY YEAR YEAR OVER YEAR THOSE
RATE INCREASES ACCORDING TO WHAT
THEY HAVE SUBMITTED ARE BASED
ENTIRELY ON COSTS GOING UP NOT
ON ANY FACTOR OF UTILIZATION
AMONG KAISER'S MEMBERS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW US TO
UNCOVER WHAT'S DRIVING THOSE
RATE INCREASES.
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER INTEGRATED
HEALTH PLANS IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OTHER EXAMPLES WHERE
INSURERS WHO ARE ALIGNED WITH
THEIR PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITALS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE STATE AT
TO THE REGULATORS.
WE'VE ALREADY GIVING KAISER SOME
LATITUDE TO DO ITS BEST GIVEN
ITS INTEGRATED MODEL TO MEET THE
SAME STANDARDS AS THOSE OTHER
INSURERS.
AND WHAT THEY'VE GOTTEN AWAY
WITH IS SHIRKING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND A CLEANING AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THEY VALUED --
TRANSPARENCY THIS IS NO SMALL
MATTER -- ALTHOUGH THERE 40% OF
ALL INSURANCE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE 65% OF THE LARGE GROUP
MARKET WHICH IS A HUGE CHUNK TO
HAVE MISSING I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY REPORTS I'VE READ.
WHETHER IT'S HEALTH AFFAIRS
ARTICLES OR CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION REPORTS
THAT HAVE THE ASTERIX THAT SAYS.
THIS IS A REPORT ON HEALTHCARE
COSTSIN CALIFORNIA.
EXCEPT FOR KAISER AND GIVEN HOW
DOMINANT THEY ARE THAT'S A HUGE
HOLE THERE IN EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLAR ORGANIZATION WITH THIRTY
ONE HOSPITALS THEY MUST HAVE
SOME UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MUCH.
THESE COMPONENTS ARE COSTING AND
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW -- THE
HOUSE SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONTROL
THE PRICES AND AND AND BE ABLE
TO EXPLAIN THEM -- BECAUSE THEY
FAILED TO REPORT THESE FINANCIAL
DATA WE HAVE NO IDEA IF THEY'RE
SERVING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
MEDIC HOW PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T KNOW -- WHETHER OR NOT
IT AT THE REGULATE A LEVER LEVEL
THERE APPROPRIATELY MEETING
THEIR MEDICAL LOSS RATIO
STANDARDS AND WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BEHIND ALL OF
THIS SO FOR ALL THESE RECENT
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SB THREE FORTY THREE TO SHINE A
LIGHT.
ON KAISER'S COST DRIVERS AND
INCREASING INSURANCE RATES THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
LOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YES MEAN PILOT FOR
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE
STATE WIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE FORTY THREE MEMBERS HEALTH
ACCESS WAS THE SPONSOR OF THE
ORIGINAL RATE REVIEW LEGISLATION
WHICH SB THREE FORTY THREE A
MAN'S WE DRAFTED THE SENTENCE
THAT REQUIRES KAISER TO DISCLOSE
ACTUAL EXPERIENCE USING BENEFIT
CATEGORIES THAT ARE SIMILAR.
TO THOSE USED BY OTHER PLANS IN
OUR VIEW KAISER HAS IGNORED THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS LAW AND THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION LET THEM
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THE RATE REVIEW LAW REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO SAY HOW MUCH
THEY SPEND ON TEN CATEGORIES
PHYSICIAN SERVICES INPATIENT
HOSPITAL CARE OUTPATIENT
EMERGENCY CARE LABS IN IMAGING.
MEMBERS DOES KAISER KNOW HOW
MUCH POSITIONS POSITION SERVICES
COST SEPARATED OUT FROM HOSPITAL
SERVICES DO THEY HAVE A BUDGET
FOR THE COMPANY THAT SEPARATES
LAB SERVICES FROM X. RAYS AND
CAT SCANS MRI AND OTHER IMAGING
COSTS.
HOW ARE THEY PROVIDING CARE TO
ALMOST NINE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
IF THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THEY
SPEND ON DOCTORS COMPARED TO
HOSPITALS?
WE KNOW FROM OUR WORK ON OTHER
RATE REVIEW BILLS THAT KAISER
PROVIDES LARGE PURCHASERS MUCH
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ON
UNIT COSTS AND UTILIZATION FOR
TYPES OF CARE.
AND THEY DO IT QUARTERLY YET IN
THEIR RATE FILINGS KAISER SAYS
THEY CANNOT PUBLICLY EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY SPEND ON DOCTORS
HOSPITALS LABORATORIES AND
IMAGING.
AND THEY POINT TO THE SENTENCE
THAT SB THREE FORTY THREE
DELETES AS THE REASON THAT THE
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE THEM.
TO THAT IS NOT WHAT THE SENTENCE
SAYS T IS NOT WHAT IT MEANT THE
FAILURE OF THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION TO ENFORCE THE
LAW AS WRITTEN IS NO EXCUSE.
KAISER IS A MAJOR PART OF OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM YET THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME REVIEW AS
OTHER HEALTH PLANS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE CANNOT DETERMINE
WHETHER KAISER.
KAISER IS RATES ARE REASONABLE
OR JUSTIFIED BECAUSE KAISER
REFUSES TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THE LAW REQUIRES.
WE SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY THREE
BECAUSE IT DILUTES THE SENTENCE
THE KAISER HAS USED AS AN EXCUSE
FOR AVOIDING COMPLIANCE WITH
RATE REVIEW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL NOW HEAR FROM OTHER
OPPONENTS IF YOU LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO AMEND WE'D
APPRECIATE IT [inaudible] FOR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA'S THEIR FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M OUT OF ASK IS I'M A KAISER
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN ON GINNY'S WISDOM
KAISER ROSEVILLE CONTRACT
SPECIALIST IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
TERM.
CHRISTOPHER GRAY PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN KAISER LINK IN.
STRONG SUPPORT.
THE LIZ GRIGSBY RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS THAT ROESER RIGHT
GEYSER ROLES BILL I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KELLY MCALLISTER ROSEVILLE
CHITRE IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA GARDNER KAISER WESTLEIGH
AND ONCOLOGY NURSE IN STRONG
OTHER THAN ABOUT AIDAN I'M A
KAISER PERMANENTE EMPLOYEE AND
ALSO COLLECTORS SO I DO SEE WHAT
THEY CHARGE -- AND DEFINITELY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S P. JIMENEZ I EXCUSE ME
EMPLOYEE AT KAISER FRESNO
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND I AM A
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RARE WHERE THE KAISER PERMANENTE
EMPLOYEE AND I WORK AT THE
APPOINTMENTS AND ADVICE CALL
CENTER WHERE WE HEAR FIRSTHAND
FROM THE PATIENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TO KILL LOTS WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A FAMILY
MEDICINE MEDICAL ASSISTANT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL JOHNSON SACRAMENTO
RADIOLOGY CT TECHNOLOGISTS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
SERENA DEAN MARTINEZ KAISER
VALLEJO APPOINTMENT AND CALL
CENTER AGAIN WE ALSO YOUR FIRST
HAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DELIVER SANKO KAISER BACK OF
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
A YES MY NAME IS JANICE WILLIAMS
I'M A THIRTY FIVE YEAR KAISER
EMPLOYEE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND LAIMS ADMINISTRATION AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
WHEN I GREW UP IN SOUTH
SACRAMENTO LABORATORY TWENTY SIX
YEAR EMPLOYEE AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
GEN FLORI WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MATT BROWN WITH THE TEAMSTERS
UNITE HERE MACHINE S. I. P. T.
LOCAL TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M LINDA COKER A THIRTY FIVE
YEAR EMPLOYEE AT KAISER
PERMANENTE A IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
THEN SUPPORT I'M SORRY IN THE
ORANGE PARK.
IT'S GETTING IT'S GETTING.
LATE.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE SOME.
I'D LIKE TO CALL OF THE
OPPONENTS OF THE PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THAT.
BY THAT ONE AND THEN IT WOULD
NOT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
THERESA START WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE A AND WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL WE HAVE HAD -- A
COUPLE OF OF LENGTHY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR
AND AND WE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THAT
COMMUNICATION UNFORTUNATELY WE
DO.
I STILL HAVE STRONG CONCERNS
WITH THE MEASURE AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD OF THE BILL DOES ONLY
IMPACT KAISER PERMANENTE NAY.
AND WHILE WE ARE ALWAYS GLAD TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR FIGURE UNIQUE HIGH
QUALITY INTEGRATED DELIVERY
SYSTEM -- WE DO FEEL THIS BILL
IS IS MISGUIDED AND SHORT
SIGHTED.
I DO WANT TO CORRECT -- SEVERAL
ACTUALLY MIS CHARACTERIZATIONS
ABOUT ABOUT CURRENT LAW IN THE
BILL IT IS IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND
WE ARE NOT EXEMPT -- FROM EITHER
OF THE LAWS THAT ARE THE SUBJECT
OF THIS MEASURE AND ALL ALL
EXPLAIN THAT MORE THERE ARE.
NO EXEMPTIONS NO EXCEPTIONS --
AND AND THE CHARACTERIZATION
THAT KAISER IS NOT THAT
DIFFERENT ANYMORE -- IS ACTUALLY
IT COULDN'T BE FURTHER FROM THE
TRUTH -- AND REALLY I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE FATAL FLAW
WITH THE BILL -- KAISER
PERMANENTE A I'M STILL IS VERY
UNIQUE -- AND I THINK THIS
DEMONSTRATES KND OF A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH OUR MODEL WE
ARE AT THE KAISER FOUNDATION
HEALTH PLAN THE KAISER
FOUNDATION HOSPITAL.
AND THE PERMANENTE MEDICAL
GROUPS TOGETHER IN ONE SYSTEM
THERE'S AN EXCLUSIVE CONTRACTING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT IN THAT
SYSTEM AND THOSE ENTITIES WORK
SEAMLESSLY TO PROVIDE CARE FOR
IT FOUR NINE MILLION MEMBERS.
OUR MODEL IS INTEGRATED IN EVERY
WAY NOT JUST CLINICALLY BUT
FINANCIALLY ELECTRONICALLY
ADMINISTRATIVELY GOVERNANCE AT
CETERA.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE LIKE KAISER
PERMANENTE A PERIOD.
JUST BECAUSE KAISER FILE SOME
INFORMATION DIFFERENTLY WITH OUR
REGULATORS THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THAT INFORMATION IS
INCOMPLETE OR INFERIOR IT IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE WE ARE
DIFFERENT.
AND I DO HAVE TO QUARREL WITH
THE THE CHARACTERIZATION I WAS
ACTUALLY AROUND WHEN -- SB
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE WAS MOVING
THROUGH AND WE DID NEGOTIATE
THAT LANGUAGE -- AND IT WAS VERY
CLEAR THAT THAT WAS AN
ACCOMMODATION FOR US ON THE
HEALTH PLAN REPORTING SIDE TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLY IN AN ACCURATE
WAY WITH REPORTING ARE COST
TREND.
BECAUSE WE ARE DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OF OUR INTEGRATED MODEL WHEN IT
COMES TO CALCULATING TREND WE
JUST DO IT DIFFERENTLY THAN
OTHER PLANS AND WE WHEN WE BUY
CARE WE BY KAREN YOU IN NOT IN
UNITS AND SEGMENTS WE ACTUALLY
BY CARE -- ON A POPULATION BASIS
A TOTAL COST OF CARE BASIS OF
GLOBAL BUDGET BASIS -- OUR COST
STRUCTURE IS DIFFERENT AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT IT IS DIFFICULT
FOR US TO SLICE AND DICE INTO
THOSE SEGMENTS -- BACK.
THE LENO BILL CALLED FOR IN SO
WE SIMPLY ASK.
FOR A VERY SMALL PROVISION THAT
IS A AN ACCOMMODATION FOR US SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY FILE IN A
WAY THAT IS AN HONEST AND
ACCURATE REFLECTION.
OF OUR MODEL SO IT'S IT'S IT'S
COMPLETELY INACCURATE TO SAY
THAT WE PLAY BY DIFFERENT RULES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RATE REVIEW
WE GO THROUGH THE SAME.
VERY RIGOROUS RATE REVIEW
PROCESS -- THAT EVERY OTHER
HEALTH PLAN DOES AND I WILL ALSO
CORAL THAT THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION THEN LET US GET
AWAY WITH ANYTHING SO I THINK
THAT IS AN UNFORTUNATE MIS
CHARACTERIZATION OF OF THE THE
PRIOR IN ACTUALLY CURRENT
LEADERSHIP OF THAT DEPARTMENT --
WE GO THROUGH A VERY RIGOROUS
PROCESS OVER THERE AND AND WE'RE
NOT EXEMPT -- WE JUST SIMPLY
SHOW ONE PART OF OUR RATE
SUBMISSION A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY -- THAN OTHER PLANS
BUT WE ARE FULLY COMPLIANT WITH
THAT -- I WANT TO SPEND A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME ON THE HOSPITAL
PART OF THE BILL THAT THE
SUPPORTERS DIDN'T REALLY FOCUS
ON THAT AND THAT'S FRANKLY THE
MORE PROBLEMATIC.
PORTION OF THE BILL -- AGAIN
THEY THE LANGUAGE IT'S IN THAT
STATUTE WHEN IT COMES TO
REPORTING TOSH POT IS NOT AN
EXEMPTION WE FILE ALL OF THE
SAME ANNUAL AND QUARTERLY
QUARTERLY REPORTS AS OUR
HOSPITAL COLLEAGUES.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE KAISER FOUNDATION
HOSPITALS ARE ORGANIZED
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY OTHER
HOSPITAL AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW WE STARTED IN
CALIFORNIA DECADES AGO THAT'S
HOW WE GREW UP.
WE HAVE THIRTY SIX HOSPITALS INCALIFORNIA.
AND THEY ARE OWNED AND OPERATED
BY THE REGIONAL K. FH
ORGANIZATION THEY ARE NOT
INDIVIDUAL STANDALONE FINANCIAL
ENTITIES AND SO SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY REQUIRE.
REQUIRE US TO SUBMIT
SPECIFICALLY THAT THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION -- THE BALLOT SHEET
THE INCOME STATEMENT THE
STATEMENT OF CASH FLOW THAT
DOESN'T EXIST AT THE FACILITY
LEVEL IT JUST DOESN'T OUR
INDIVIDUAL HOSPITALS ARE ASSETS
OF THE REGIONAL ORGANIZATION.
SO WE ACTUALLY DO FILE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION IN THE OCCUPIED
REPORTING AT THE FACILITY BASIS
AND WE'RE TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
DO. TO DO MORE AND TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT IN THAT SPACE
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT WITH RESPECT TO
THOSE FINANCIAL STATEMENTS THE
INFORMATION.
LITERALLY DOESN'T EXIST AND SO
WE FILE -- THE CONSOLIDATED
REPORT -- AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
SO.
I I THINK AT THE MEMBERS IN BOTH
OF THESE THESE LAWS AGAIN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT WE SEND IS THE TRUTH.
IT IS AN HONEST AT AN ACCURATE
REFLECTION OF OF OUR OUR
OPERATING MODEL IN AND HOW WE DO
BUSINESS IRONICALLY.
THIS BILL WILL ACTUALLY IS
ACTUALLY ASKING US TO BE LESS
TRANSPARENT TO ACTUALLY OBSCURE
THE TRUTH AND CANGE THE STORY
THAT IS THE STORY AND AND SPEND
A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY DOING IT.
UP FOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE WERE
WERE NOT CLEAR WE WOULD ACTUALLY
PREFER TO SPEND MONEY ON ON
HEALTH CARE -- INSTEAD OF ON
ADMINISTRATION.
MY FINAL THOUGHT -- MEMBERS BUT
BESIDES SORT OF THE THE NUTS AND
BOLTS CONCERN OF THE BILL I
THINK WHAT WHAT FRUSTRATES US
ABOUT THE BILL IS.
THAT IT REALLY IS TAKING THE LAW
BACKWARDS AND AND HEALTH CARE
EXPERTS HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS AND SENATOR PANDAS HAVE A
HEARING ON THIS WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CHANGE AND TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM
INTO.
A VALUE BASED SYSTEM AND NOT A
VOLUME BASED SYSTEM -- WE WANT
TO SEE WE WANT TO MAYBE THINK A
LITTLE BIT BIGGER EXPAND OUR
THINKING A LITTLE BIT AND SO HOW
DO WE USE THE STATUTE INSTEAD OF
GOING BACKWARDS AND TINKERING
WITH.
A TEN YEAR OLD LAW HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ASPIRATIONAL HOW DO WE LOOK AT
THE STATUTE AND SEE HOW WE CAN.
REUSE POLICY TO LEVERAGE THE
KIND OF CHANGE WE WANT TO SEE IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO REALLY
REWARD AND INCENTIVIZE THE KIND
OF OF A FINANCIAL ALIGNMENT THAT
WE WANT TO SEE TO CREATE THAT.
THAT VALUE BASED CARE AND REALLY
BEGIN TO BEND THE COST CURVE.
YES SO I I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
FRUSTRATING US IS IT ACTUALLY
TAKES US BACKWARDS WE ACTUALLY
THINK THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO TO
ACTUALLY -- ENCOURAGING
INCENTIVIZE THESE KIND OF
PAYMENT MODELS SO HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO TO TALK TO SENATOR
PAN BUT WE'D LIKE TO BE HAVING A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT IS --
OPPOSED TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
SENATORS YES SUCCESS THANK YOU --
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IF
I MAY.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I KNOW THAT
JUST I JUST HEARD KAISER HOME
STATE THEY HAVE A UNIQUE
INTEGRATIVE MODEL ARE THERE ANY
OTHER HOSPITALS THAT HAVE THE
SAME MODEL. FOR SIMILAR MODEL OR
ARE THEY MOVING TOWARDS THAT
MODEL.
SO WITH THAT SAID IT THIS WAY --
THE TERMS OF YOUR HOUSE KAISER
UNIQUE AND AS IS POINTED OUT --
BY A THE REPRESENTATIVE -- WHAT
THEY DO HAVE THIS IS THEY HAVE
YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A HOSPITAL
RIGHT FOUNDATION ALSO THAT
HEALTH PLAN THEY HAVE A MEDICAL
GROUP BRIGHTEN THEIR ALL TIGHTLY
INTEGRATED SO THEY ALL DIRECTLY
CONTRACTING CONTRACTING WELL SO?
SO THAT IS SOMEWHAT UNIQUE IN
THAT SENSE BUT I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT -- THERE RE
OTHER INTEGRATED SYSTEMS THEY
MAY NOT BE AS TIGHT WITH THEIR
HEALTH PLAN THAT AT THE ME HAVE
YOUR HEALTH PLAN A CONTRACT WITH
A NOTE SO FOR EXAMPLE -- UC
DAVIS YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
CAPITATED RACE AGO CROSS
HOSPITALS.
IT IS IT IS SO BUT AND WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH THIS BILL
IS SAYING THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT TAKE THAT A PART IN ANY WAY --
BUT THAT YOU CANNOT YOU YOU DO
YOU CAN AND YOU ACTUALLY.
DO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON THE
INDIVIDUAL PIECES RIGHT.
AS ALWAYS YOU CAN'T EVEN RUN
YOUR SYSTEM IF YOU DON'T KNOW
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT'S GOING ON
YOUR HOSPITAL.
HOW MUCH YOU'RE SPENDING ON
RADIOLOGY VERSUS WHAT YOU'RE
SPENDING ON -- THE OTHER
COMPONENTS THEN HOW DO YOU EVEN.
RUN YOUR SYSTEM AND HOW DO YOU
DECIDE WHAT PREMIUM YOU'RE
CHARGING WHEN YOU'RE NEGOTIATING
WITH -- WITH WHATEVER GROUP IN
FACT ACTUALLY WHAT WE DO HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THE ALL KINDS
THAT'S WELL KNOWN WE NEGOTIATE
WITH SOMEBODY WE CAN ACTUALLY
HEAR THEM LOT MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION.
AND AND THEY DO AND AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT -- BUT WHAT WE
DON'T GET AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT FOR EXAMPLE I SAID MORE
GRANULARITY AND I APPRECIATE NO
MORE WORK WITH KAISER ABOUT THIS.
BUT FOR EXAMPLE THE HOSPITALS
AND I I UNDERSTAND YOU GOT YOU
KNOW WHAT AND TAX ID NUMBER
SOMETHING FOR THE WHOLE THING
BUT IT'S ALL OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NOW TELL YOU KAISER'S
BIG IN SACRAMENTO IT'S BIG IN
THE BAY AREA.
THEY'RE ENTIRELY EVERY THEIR
CLOTHES BUT THEY'RE DIFFERENT
HEALTHCARE MARKETS AFFECT EVEN
COVERED CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THINGS CARVE TELL DIFFERENTLY
RIGHT.
SO THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS IS WE
DON'T HAVE ALL WE HAVE IS ALL OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON BUT
LIKE IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
THE PEOPLE SHOULD RUNNING THE
SYSTEM.
GO OH YEAH WELL WE REALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH IS GOING ON THE
SACRAMENTO SIDE OF THINGS VERSUS
THE BAY AREA SIDE OF THINGS
VERSUS THE YOU KNOW WHATEVER
OTHER.
AREAS THEY HAVE IN THAT AND AND
THAT THAT THAT PUZZLES ME A BIT.
THERE TOO SO I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A LOT MORE GRANULARITY SO
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
FOR THE REGULATORS RIGHT OF IT
ALL IN ON CALIFORNIA'S THE SAME.
I THINK THAT'S A BIT.
DIFFICULT YEAH THAT THAT THAT.
DOESN'T SOUND CREDIBLE SO -- SO
I THINK WE WILL WE WE NEED TO WE
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY -- WE ARE
REGULATORS THE YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON I THINK OUR PURCHASERS
NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
FRANKLY HAVE A KAISER HAD AND I
AGREE KAISER HAS A GREAT YOU
KNOW WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE BASS
PURCHASING WE HAVE AN INTEGRATED
MODEL -- BUT THERE'S ALSO OTHER
INTEGRATED MODELS AS WELL AND WE
EXPECT THEM TO REPORT AND ART
EXACTLY SEEMS KAISER NO.
BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF THE KIND
OF THINGS ARE ASKING THE REPORT --
I'D ANYTHING KAISER CAN DO A LOT
MORE THAN THEY'RE DOING NOW AND
BECAUSE IF NOTHING ELSE I'M SURE
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO
THEMSELVES IN ORDER TO RUN THEIR
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU -- AND THE REASON I
WAS ASKING OUT IS THAT -- YOU
KNOW BECAUSE I HEAR THAT THEY
HAVE A CARVE OUT. FOR THEM.
AND I'M HEARING FROM YOU THAT
THERE'S OTHERS MOM THE OTHER --
HOSPITALS THAT HAVE INTEGRATED
MODELS MAYBE NOT IN THE SAME WAY
BUT I THINK IT BOILS DOWN -- TO
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE AND AND
HAVING EQUITY -- AND IN THE
MARKET AND SELL I JUST WANT TO
JUST HEAR FROM -- FROM KAISER.
THEN I UNDERSTAND AND I HEARD
YOU SAY THIS IS A TEN YEAR MODEL
I'M SORRY LAW THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON I JUST WANT TO HEAR.
IF -- IT MAY BE COMPLICATED IS
IT TIME THAT YOU NEED TO TRY AND
COMPLY WITH THIS.
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT THANK YOU
CENTER WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW TO BE
CLEAR -- BOTH FLAWS TO MEAN THAT
THE OCCUPIED THE WHOLE FOR THE
HOSPITAL REPORTING HAS BEEN IN
THE LAW FOR DECADES.
AND OUTPUT HAS NEVER HAD ANY
ISSUES WITH OUR REPORTS THE RATE
REVIEW -- PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN
IN THE LAW FOR FOR TEN YEARS AND
WE'VE BEEN FULLY COMPLIANT SO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT
IT A LACK OF COMPLIANCE IT IS
AGAIN.
YEAH THERE ARE A COUPLE OF OF
BLANK BOXES ON A FORM BUT I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT THAT'S A FLAW
IN THE FORM AND NOT WITH OUR
REPORT SO.
SO AND I THINK JUST IT TO TO
KIND OF GRAB ONTO YOUR ACTUALLY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
IS THERE MORE THAT WE CAN DO IN
EITHER OF THESE PROBABLY --
WE'VE DONE A LOT IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS WE'RE REALLY -- MAKING
GREAT STRIDES WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPARENCY IT HAS NOT BEEN OUR
STRONG SUIT IT HASN'T BEEN AND
PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF OUR
MODEL WE ARE SO TIGHTLY
INTEGRATED.
AND BECAUSE WE DO LOOK AT THE
TOTAL COST O CARE OUR COST
STRUCTURE IS DIFFERENT OUR
BUDGETING IS DIFFERENT WHICH IS
DIFFERENT.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
MARKET AND ARE PURCHASERS -- OUR
LARGE GROUP PURCHASERS ARE ARE
LARGE YOU KNOW CALPERS AND COVER
COME HAVE BEEN PUSHING US THEY
WANT TO UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT'S
UNDER THE HOOD WHAT'S DRIVING MY
RATES WHAT IS YOU KNOW HELP US
UNDERSTAND AND SO WE UNDERSTAND
THE MARKET IS IS IS PUSHING US
ON THAT -- WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S VALUE IN THESE
REPORTS TO RUN REGULATORS SO.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE --
THERE'S THERE'S SOME INFORMATION
IN HERE AS I MENTIONED WITH
RESPECT TO THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS THAT WE CAN'T DO
BECAUSE OF THAT THE STRUCTURE OF
OUR OSPITAL SYSTEM.
SO.
THERE MAY BE THINGS WE CAN DO TO
IT.
TO YOU KNOW BUT AGAIN.
AS WE START SLICING AND DICING I
WANTED HER TO GET BACK TO IS
THAT REALLY WHERE WE WANT TO GO
WITH WITH POLICY.
DON'T WE WANT TO REALLY LOOK AT
THAT GLOBAL BUDGET BECAUSE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE HOSPITALS AND I
THINK DOCTOR PAN WITH WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT.
A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SORT OF IS THE OLD WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT HOSPITALS MAKING
DECISIONS BASED ON ON ON
FINANCES AND MONEY AND VOLUME
AND HEADS IN BEDS AND AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO GET AWAY FROM.
OUR HOSPITALS THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE BOTTOM LINE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT VOLUME
THERE ONLY FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
GOOD CARE AND IT'S ACTUALLY IN
PART. TO THE FOLKS THAT THE
SPONSOR REPRESENTS WE HAVE GREAT
HEALTH CARE TEAMS THAT ARE
BETTER.
KNOCKING THOSE QUALITY SCORES --
OFF THE CHART BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT FOCUSED ON WHETHER
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE BUDGET THIS
YEAR THOUGH I I WOULD ASSERT
THAT THAT'S THE DIRECTION WE
WANT TO TAKE HEALTHCARE AND GO.
TO LOOKING FOR OUTCOMES AND
VALUE AND QUALITY -- INSTEAD OF
WHAT IS THE FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
SAY TODAY.
WELL.
CAN I JUST SAY ONE BECAUSE OF AN
EVER SAID THAT KAISER WAS
VIOLATING THE LAW THE REASON
WE'RE HERE AND DOING A BILL IS
BECAUSE OF LAW AS IT CURRENTLY
IS IS NOT.
ACHIEVING THE RESULTS THAT WE
DESIRE TERMS OF TRANSPARENCY.
I WAS GONNA ADD TO THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK YOU
MISUNDERSTOOD MY QUESTION I
WASN'T IMPLYING BY ANY MEANS
THAT YOU HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLAINING THE LAST TEN YEARS I
DO.
THAT.
CLEARLY YOU USED TO REPORTING IN
A CERTAIN WAY WHICH IS THE LONG.
AND THE NOW WITH THE CHANGES
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
HERE IN THIS SITE LEGISLATION I
WAS TRYING TO SEE WE CAN.
BRIDGE THE GAP TO ALLOW YOU AT
LEAST TIME IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEEDED.
TO DO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO -- BUT
I DID HEAR YOU JUST SAY RIGHT
NOW THAT YOU'RE NOT CONCERNED
WITH THE BOTTOM LINE HOWEVER I
HEARD YOU JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO
THAT.
THAT YOU CAN DO IT BUT IT WAS
GOING TO COST A LOT OF MONEY AND
YOU WHAT RATHER USE THAT MONEY
TOWARDS HEALTH CARE SO THERE IS
SOME CONCERN WITH THE BOTTOM
LINE -- BUT AGAIN I WAS JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP SO THAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
LEGISLATION YOU WOULD HAVE THAT
TIME OR TRY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT TIME BUT I
NOT SURE THAT TIME IS WHAT YOU
NEED -- BUT THANK YOU THAT
ANSWERS MY QUESTION THANK YOU
DOCTOR SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU -- THIS IS COMPLEX.
AND I THINK KAISER IS A UNIQUE
ANIMAL.
AND I THINK -- YOU KNOW THE
OLDER SAY TO MOLD THE CREATIVE
THE WHOLE HMO MODEL WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENT KIND
OF MOTIVATION YOUR BUSINESS.
IT'S BEEN A WE GET THAT BUT
THERE'S A DIFFERENT.
KIND OF MOTIVATION IN TERMS OF
PREVENTIVE HEALTH SERVICES AND
THAT OTHER HOSPITALS DON'T
NECESSARILY HALF AND SO I GET
THAT AND SO WHEN I STRUGGLE WITH
THIS EXPECTATION PERHAPS ON OUR
IN.
THAT THERE WOULD BE THAT THERE
EVEN CAN BE AN APPLE TO APPLE
COMPARISON FOR REGULATORS I
WONDER HOW REALISTIC THAT THAT
IS.
AND AS OPPOSED TO TRYING TO
DRIVE TO AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON. TO GET TO THE ROOT
ISSUE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING. TO
TO TO FIX OR IDENTIFY -- THE
KAISER WHEN YOU SAY THAT YOUR
REGIONAL YOU KNOW HOW MANY
HOSPITALS ARE PER REGION IS IT
LIKE.
DOCTOR PAN SAID THAT THAT THAT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHI CHI'S IN
NORTH IS EVERY HOSPITAL IN
KAISER NORTH YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU
DEFINE YOUR REGION'S BECAUSE OF
THE REGIONS ARE.
SMALL ENOUGH THERE ARE FEWER
ENOUGH HOSPITALS IN IT.
WHILE IT WON'T BE AN APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON IT MAY BE
EASIER TO EXTRAPOLATE THE KIND
OF DATA.
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR SO HOW
MANY HOSPITALS PER REGION YEAH
IT SO THERE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION IN SOUTHERN CAL IS ALL
ONE WRONG SO BUT AGAIN BUT
THAT'S THE LEGAL STRUCTURE.
K. FH NOR RIGHT OWNS THE
HOSPITALS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT THEY ARE ONE THEY ARE THAT
THEY ARE THE ASSETS OF KAISER
FOUNDATION HOSPITAL THEY'RE NOT
STANDALONE FINANCIAL AND I GET
YOUR THE I GET IS RIGHT.
SO I THINK IN INTO YOUR POINT
ABOUT THE APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON I THINK YOU REALLY
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD BECAUSE
I THINK IT IS MISLEADING. TO SAY
THAT THERE CAN BE AN APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON HERE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT AN APPLE I GET IT
WE'RE ACTUALLY MORE LIKE AN
APPLE PIE ACTUALLY HIT -- BUT
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE YEAH GIVE
THOUGH THE GOAL.
WHAT TO DROUGHT WITH THAT GIVEN
THE UNDERLYING MOTIVATING FACTOR
WHICH IS TO GET HAVE A SENSE OF
HOW WE MEASURE [inaudible]
COST.
IT MAY NOT BE AN APPLES TO
APPLES BUT BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO KIND OF PLAY
IN THE SANDBOX IN TERMS OF
SHEDDING SOME LIGHT. TO THE
REGULATORS ABOUT WHAT INFORMS
YOUR DECISION MAKING AROUND HOW
YOUR COSTS ARE.
DECLARED AND SO IF NOT THIS WAY
THEN WHAT YEAH NO I THINK ON THE
ON THE COST CHARGE REVENUE SIDE
YEAH I THINK THERE'S THERE'S
ROOM THERE FOR US TO TALK MORE
ABOUT HOW WE CAN REPORT THAT IN
A MORE GRANULAR BASIS.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE CAN DO
AGAIN AND THAT WAS MY POINT
ABOUT WE WOULD NEED TO INVEST
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND AND
HIRE.
ACCOUNTANTS AND ACTUARIES IN
ORDER TO DO THAT BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS REVAMPING ITS
REVAMPING OUR ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS
BUT IT'S IT'S DOABLE.
ON THAT I I THINK I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
THAT.
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE OWNERSHIP
OF THE HOSPITALS THAT
INFORMATION JUST.
DOESN'T EXIST AND WE DON'T WANNA
MAKE IT UP SO I THINK THERE IS
ROOM TO BE MORE TRANSPARENT AND
OPEN.
ABOUT THE THE REVENUE AND AND
CHARGE ASPECT OF IT WHEN WE CAN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AND THE
LET'S GET CLEAR ABOUT WHY THAT'S
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE A HOW.
MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES ARE KAISER
PATIENTS I MEAN I THINK THE THE
THE ROLE WE PLAY IN IT IS GIVEN
THE SHEER VOLUME OF STATE
DOLLARS.
THAT ARE FUNNELED THROUGH.
NORTH OR SOUTH OF ME SO THAT'S
WHY WE'RE IN THE CONVERSATION
GENERALLY.
AND I AND I WOULD ASSUME IN ALL
FAIRNESS THE OTHER HOSPITALS
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE TO
CHANGE YOUR SYSTEM ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE PERSONNEL IN PLACE. TO
ADHERE TO ALL OF THE REGULATORS
IN ALL THE LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
ALL OF OUR ASK -- FOR SO IN
FAIRNESS SHINGLES ACOSTA BORN
ALL BE THEY DIFFERENT -- IN IN
THE OTHER HOSPITAL SYSTEMS -- TO
AND I WOULD VENTURE TO ASSUME
THAT WITHOUT A VEHICLE GOING
THROUGH.
THE THE CONVERSATION -- WOULDN'T --
HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF
MOTIVATION.
AS IF THERE WERE NOT INTERFERE
TODAY YEAH IN TERMS OF THESE
REPORTS PROBABLY BUT AGAIN AS AS
I STATED YOU KNOW TRANSPARENCY
IN WANTING TO UNDERSTAND MORE
WHAT WHAT'S UNDER THE HOOD IS IS
A IS.
A CONVERSATION ARE PURCHASERS
ARE WANTING OF US APPROPRIATELY --
AND WE'VE WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO MORE ABOUT THAT
SO I THINK THAT IS CHANGING US
INTERNALLY A LITTLE BIT WE WANT
TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO THAT
BUT YEAH THIS THIS BILL IS IS.
ADDITIONALLY CHALLENGING RIGHT
SO LET ME SAY DOCTOR PAN THAT
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
YOU KNOW HOW WE LIKE TO DO THESE
CABBIE OUT MOST SUPPORTED TODAY.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS FAIR TO
WITH KNOWLEDGE THE KAISER HE IS
A DIFFERENT ANIMAL AND THAT
ISN'T TO SUGGEST THAT IT'S BAD.
THEY WERE THE FIRST THEY CREATED
A CERTAIN MODEL BUT MANY HAVE
FOLLOWED -- AND SO I THINK WE DO
HAVE TO WORK TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE GET TO THE REAL CRUX OF THE
QUESTION.
IN ALL AND AN APPLES TO APPLES.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR
EXPECTATION OF IT IF THERE IS A
WAY TO GET THERE -- AND I
BELIEVE THE VEHICLES PROBABLY
NECESSARY TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION ALONG WHICH IS WHY
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT -- BUT
BUT I THINK THAT THAT WE NEED TO
ALSO BE FAIR IN TERMS OF IT MAY
NOT LOOK EXACTLY LIKE THE OTHER
HOSPITAL APPLES -- BUT HOW DO WE
GET TO THE CRUX THE CORE ISSUES
THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT FOR OUR
ABILITY TO MANAGE AND PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT.
IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN DO THAT.
IN THE MAY I JUST SAY ACTUALLY I
AM FULL AGREEMENT WITH YOU
CENTER I TO CHILL AND WHILE THE
BILL IS IN ITS CURRENT FORM
WE'RE STILL WAITING TO HAVE.
THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE AN
APPLE THE APPLE BUT IT'S GOT TO
BE.
BASICALLY WE HAVE TO GET THE
KIND OF DATA WE NEED TO ACHIEVE
OUR GOALS SO I UNDERSTAND MAY BE
SIMILAR NOT IDENTICAL GIVEN THE
STRUCTURE.
BUT WE BUT THAT IDEA THAT WELL
SORRY YOU KNOW WE HAVE A REPORT
THAT SAYS IT BLANK BLANK BLANK
BLANK AND IT'S ALL ROLLED UP
INTO ONE NUMBER.
ISN'T ENOUGH PLANET GRANULARITY
YEAH I GET IT MAYBE AND MAYBE
IT'S A CUT MAYBE IT'S AN ISSUE
OF AT LEAST INITIALLY LE
CONVERSATIONS WITH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
IF THERE CAN BE SOME KIND OF
AGREEMENT ON WHAT -- THE SHARED
GOAL IS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CENTER LEYVA AND CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE.
SO MY FIRST START OFF BY SAYING
LOVE KAISER I DON'T PERSONALLY
HAVE THEM BUT WHEN I WAS WITH
YOU OF CW X..
ONE WHEN I WAS AT THE U. OF C.
W. -- WE NEGOTIATED CARE FOR OUR
MEMBERS WHO LOVE THEM -- AND I
HAVE TO SAY AS I SHARED WITH YOU
ALREADY THERESA IT WAS A BIG
POINT OF FRUSTRATION FOR US AT
THE BARGAINING TABLE.
BECAUSE WE COULD NEVER GET TO
THE ROOT OF HEALTH ACTUALLY
CALCULATE THE RATES -- WE WERE
ALWAYS TOLD THAT WAS IN THE
BLACK BOX AND WE TO SAY PLEASE
OPEN THE BLACK BOX WE'D LIKE TO
GET INSIDE AND SEE.
AND IT MADE IT DIFFICULT FOR US
AS NEGOTIATORS WHEN WE'RE
NEGOTIATING -- PLANS WITH KAISER
WITH BLUE CROSS PPO WITH WHOEVER
WE'RE NEGOTIATING WITH WE COULD
SEE A BREAK DOWN WE UNDERSTOOD
OUR EXPERIENCE RATE WE KNEW
WHERE THE COST INCREASES ARE
COMING FROM.
BUT WE NEVER KNEW WITH KAISER SO
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS -- ONE
I WOULD THINK THAT YOU HAVE A
TEAM THAT PROCESSES CLAIMS.
AND THEY WOULD ENCOUNTER DATA.
COULD THEY NOT USE THAT DATA OR
USE THOSE CLAIMS TO EXTRAPOLATE
OUT HOW MUCH IT COSTS FOR
CERTAIN.
VISITS AND CERTAIN THINGS THAT
HAPPEN [inaudible]
SO ACTUALLY.
THAT'S NOT TRUE WE BEGIN DON'T
HAVE A CLAIMS DEPARTMENT PAID
WHAT WE DO NOW BECAUSE SOME OF
OUR OUTSIDE SERVICES ARE CLAIMS
BASED RIGHT BUT OUR MODEL.
THE THE CORE STRUCTURE OF HOW WE
FUNCTION IS IS A PREPAID RISK
BASED SYSTEM RIGHT SO THAT SO
IT'S A PM PM.
THERE ARE NO CLAIMS ARE OUR
PHYSICIANS DON'T BILL THE HEALTH
PLAN THE HOSPITALS DON'T BILL
THE HEALTH PLAN IT IT'S IT'S
IT'S THAT SORT OF TOTAL TOTAL%
COST O CARE BUDGET RIGHT.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT AGAIN THE
CLAIMS DATA IS WHERE THE
TRANSPARENCY COMES FROM AND WHAT
OUR PURCHASERS WANT TO SEE AND
SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY AGAIN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN WORK
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS -- TO TO
CREATE THAT CLAIMS DATA WERE
ACTUALLY.
MANUFACTURING THE CLAIMS DATA
WHICH IS WHICH IS THE THE
ENCOUNTER DATA TIMES PRICE RIGHT
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT IT IS SO
WE'VE ACTUALLY WORKED SO HARD TO
SAY THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT HOW WE
DO IT.
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING THAT THAT
THAT.
TOTAL COST OF CARE APPROACH BUT
BECAUSE IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
CALPERS AND OUR LABOR TRUSTS AND
OUR OUR PUBLIC SECTOR PURCHASERS
WE ARE CREATING THAT DATA FOR
THEM SO THEY CAN SEE THAT --
IMPORTANTLY PROTECTING MEMBERS
PRIVACY -- WHILE WE'RE DOING
THAT BUT WE CAN ACTUALLY SHOW
THE UTILIZATION AND AND THE
ENCOUNTER INFORMATION NOW AND SO
THAT'S A BIG IMPROVEMENT WE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COME BACK IN AND
CHECK IT OUT WHEN I DON'T KNOW.
THOSE.
DAYS ARE OVER THANK YOU.
OKAY SO I WANT TO UNDERSTAND I
HAVE A PPO SO I GO TO MY DOCTOR
AND I HAVE A CHECK UP AND HE
SAYS -- CONNIE WE WANT TO CHECK
YOUR LIVER FUNCTION WALKED DOWN
THE HALL AND LET'S DO A SONOGRAM
GREAT WE DO THAT THEN HE SAYS --
WALK ACROSS THE HALL AND WE'RE
DRAW SOME BLOOD WORK OKAY GREAT
SO WE DO THAT WHEN I GET MY
STATEMENT.
IT SHOWS ME ITEMIZED WHAT I HAD
DONE WHAT THE COST WAS NOW MY
MOTHER IN LAW JOSEPHINE WHO HAS
KAISER AND MY HUSBAND I
SOMETIMES TAKE HER TO THE DOCTOR.
THE SAME THING HAPPENS TO HER
AND SHE GOES IN AND HE HAS HER
PHYSICAL AND THEN HE SAYS ALL
YOU KNOW WHAT JOSEPHINE WE WANT
TO CHECK -- Là -- FUNCTION GO
DOWN THE HALL WE WANT TO CHECK
YOU TAKE SOME BLOOD GO ACROSS
THE HALL.
WHEN SHE GETS A BILL IT'S NOT
ITEMIZED BUT I I THINK I'M JUST
HAVING A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
WHAT DOESN'T KAISER HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THAT SONOGRAM COST?
ANY IDEA WHAT THAT BLOOD WORK
COST BECAUSE I'M THINKING THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HIRE PEOPLE TO
DO THE JOB SO AT THE VERY LEAST
YOU WOULD KNOW WHAT THEIR SALARY
WAS.
I JUST THINK YOUR SALARIES OKAY
BUT THERE HAS TO BE SOME SORT OF
ACOSTA SIS SO TO MY MOTHER IN
LAW GOES AND HAS THOSE
PROCEDURES TO AND THAT WOULD
COST KAISER X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
BECAUSE SHE HAD THREE TWO THAT'S
REALLY THEM.
THAT'S THE RISK BEARING SO SO
THAT THE MEDICAL GROUP FOR
EXAMPLE.
MERRILY RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF
THAT CARE EVEN IN OUR HOSPITALS
RIGHT SO OUR PHYSICIANS PRACTICE
IN OUR HOSPITALS -- AND AND THAT
ACTUALLY CREATES EVEN AT A
TIGHTER AND TIGHTER INTEGRATION
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S A
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE PERMANENTE
MEDICAL GROUPS AND THE HEALTH
PLAN.
SUPER SECRET DOCUMENT BUT ALL OF
THAT IS IS IS IN THAT DOCUMENT
IT'S IT'S THE CONTRACT IT'S THE
MEDICAL GROUP IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
YOU'RE GONNA GET THIS AMOUNT PER
MONTH FOR ALL OF THESE MEMBERS
YOU'RE GONNA TAKE AS GOOD CARE
OF THEM AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN IF
THEY'RE HEALTHY GOOD FOR YOU
THAT'S UPSIDE RISK IF THEY GET
SICK.
BAD FOR YOU THAT'S DOWNSIDE RISK
AND THAT'S KINDA HOW IT HOW IT
WORKS FOR US AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY REALLY HARNESS THAT
MODELS IT TO EVEN MAKE IT DIDN'T
EVEN MAKE IT STRONGER SO.
THERE AREN'T THERE AREN'T BILLS --
THEY GO OUT -- FOR THE MOST PART
IT IT IS IT IS IT IS ALL PREPAID
AND IT'S A RISK BASED AND REALLY
THAT THE PATIENT IS NOT INVOLVED
IN THAT AND I I'VE BEEN A
BECAUSE REMEMBER. FOR FORTY
YEARS I'VE NEVER HAD A BILL AND
AND THAT'S BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
IT'S THE FOCUS ON ON THE THE
OVERALL PERSON -- IN DOING
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO KEEP THAT
PERSON HEALTHY WHICH IS THAT
VALUE BASED OUTCOMES BASED
STRUCTURE THAT WE REALLY THINK
WE NEED TO BE MOVING TO OKAY SO
YOU HAVE A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLANS RIGHT.
OKAY SO HOW DO YOU DETERMINE IF
YOU HAVE A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLAN
YOU'VE GOT A YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE
SOME IDEA OF WHAT THE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE GETTING NOW IS WE HAVEN'T
ALWAYS HAD HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
HEALTH PLANS THAT'S A RELATIVELY
NEW ADDITION TO OR BENEFIT
PACKAGE.
BUT AGAIN BECAUSE THE MARKET WAS
ASKING FOR THAT RIGHT SO FOR
THAT REASON WE DO TRACK VERY
CAREFULLY THE SERVICES SO THAT
WE CAN SET SO THAT WE CAN TRACK --
THAT THE COST SHARING AND THE
DEDUCTIBLE AND AND ALL OF THAT
SO THERE IS THAT THAT TRACKING
GOING ON AT THE AT THE PEOPLE
YOU GET IN THERE.
YEAH GET ME OUT ALL RIGHT WHICH
WILL GET YOU A LITTLE FARTHER
ALONG INTERSTATE.
BECAUSE I JUST I CAN'T EXPRESS
YOUR MEAN I'VE BEEN GONE FOR
FOUR YEARS NOW -- I DON'T
NEGOTIATE THOSE CONTRACTS
ANYMORE BUT I CAN'T SHARE WITH
THAT I CAN'T EXPRESS ENOUGH HOW
FRUSTRATING IT WAS.
AND HOW HARD IT WAS FOR US TO
NEGOTIATE BENEFITS FOR OUR
MEMBERS WITH EMPLOYERS WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO PAY A DIME
TOWARDS THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE
WHEN WE CAN'T WE DON'T HAVE GOOD
HONEST DATA AND INFORMATION.
SO THAT WE CAN SAY LOOK KAISER'S
ACTUALLY BETTER DEAL WHY DON'T
WE GO TO KAISER -- LOOK BLUE
CROSS PPO IS ACTUALLY BETTER
DEAL MAYBE WE SHOULD GO WITH
THEM.
IT JUST MAKES IT HARD TO DO
OTHER IT MAKES IT HARD FOR OTHER
PEOPLE TO DO THEIR JOBS.
WHEN YOU CAN'T BREAK DOWN THAT
DATA I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
DIFFERENT MODEL BUT I'M HOPING
THAT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS FOR A WHOLE
LOT OF PEOPLE AND MAYBE WE CAN
START FIGURING OUT A WAY TO FIND
THOSE NUMBERS?
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IN A RUNNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WON'T BELABOR THIS I ONLINE
MONEY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES -- I DO APPLAUD THE
WORK KAISER DOES IN TRYING.
TO I THINK IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT DIVISION
OF PROMOTING HEALTH IN NOT JUST
TREATMENT OF DISEASE AND ILLNESS --
WE NEED TO DO THAT SYSTEM WIDE
IN ALL SYSTEMS.
AND FORTUNE WE HAVE A HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WHERE THE MONEY
COMES FROM TREATMENT OF ILLNESS
AND DISEASE THE PROFIT OFTEN --
IN NOT IN THE PREVENTION.
THAT SAID IN WITH RESPECT TO THE
INTEGRATED SYSTEM THAT IS KAISER --
HAVE THREE GRANDCHILDREN ALL
BORN AT KAISER ONE WHO HAD AN
EMERGENCY APPENDECTOMY AND CAME
OUT JUST FINE SO.
WE'RE BIG FANS OF THE SERVICES.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORKERS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK.
COM IN THAT INTEGRATED SYSTEM
THERE'S PHYSICIANS BEING PAID AT
ONE LEVEL NURSES THAT ANOTHER
CUSTODIAN SAID ANOTHER -- I'M
SURE SOME SERVICES ARE
CONTRACTED OUT THERE'S
FACILITIES.
BUT SOMEWHERE SOMEBODY'S KEEPING
TRACK OF THE MONEY COME IN IN IN
THE MONEY GOING OUT.
AND EVEN IF IT'S A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM THAN A STANDALONE
HOSPITAL.
I WOULD HOPE THAT IN IN IN
YOU'VE BEEN CANDID AND
FORTHRIGHT TODAY OF THE EFFORTS
IN AREAS OF POSSIBLE IMPROVEMENT.
I WOULD HOPE THIS BILL THAT I
WILL SUPPORT TODAY DOES LEAD TO
SOME FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
RESPECT BY THE AUTHOR OF SOME OF
THE DIFFERENCES -- IN THAT IT
LEADS TO THAT APPLE PIE THAT YOU
REFERRED TO WHEN THIS BILL IS
FULLY BAKED BUT I I JUST THINK.
THE NUMBERS ARE OUT THERE.
LET'S CATCH HIM FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO ACHIEVE THAT LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY. FOR THE PATIENT
COMMUNITY FOR THE HEALTH
COMMUNITY FOR THE WORK FORCE --
I THINK WE CAN GET THERE SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
WILL SUPPORT THIS TODAY IN
WATCHES.
YOUR CONVERSATIONS MOVE FORWARD
TOWARDS THE APPLE PIE THANK YOU.
BIGGEST IN A MINING.
YES BUT IF I MAY WRAP IT UP AND
DOWN YOU KNOW AND I'VE HAD A
DISCUSSION WITH HIM PRIOR TO
COMING HERE BECAUSE IT WAS A
CONCERN OF MINE THAT.
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH KAISER
TWENTY SURE THAT -- YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE GET USED
TO DOING SOMETHING IN A CERTAIN
WAY IT TAKES LONGER TO GET THERE
SO PLEASE CONTINUE THAT
DISCUSSION THAT WE ALSO
DISCUSSED THAT I WILL.
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
MIND LATER BUT I WANT WITH THAT
I WANT TO MOVE THE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I JUST
HAVE A FEW QUICK QUESTIONS AND
HOURS GETTING LATE SO -- FOR THE
SEIU RAP -- DESI ARE YOU OPPOSE
THE COMEDY LANGUAGE THAT KAISER
REQUESTED IN THE ORIGINAL RATE
REVIEW -- OR ASHKHABAD STATUTE.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE -- WE DIDN'T
OPPOSE THEM.
AND THAT'S WHY HE DIDN'T OPPOSE
IT AT THAT TIME AND WELL THE
ASHRAM LANGUAGE I BELIEVE WAS
PUT IN PLACE IN THE SEVENTIES OR
EIGHTIES SO I'M.
THAT IS WAY BEFORE MY TIME AND
ALSO MY MY PREDECESSORS WIFE
CONNECTED WITH SO I COULDN'T
SPEAK TO THAT -- IN TERMS OF THE
RATE REVIEW PROCESS LANGUAGE I
THINK THERE WAS AN EXPECTATION
THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT'S IN
STATUTE NOW WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
KAISER TO DO ITS BEST AND I
THINK WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT'S BEEN
FILED THE LAST THREE YEARS AND
RATE REVIEW AND WE'RE SAYING.
HEISER IS FALLEN FAR SHORT OF
DOING ITS BEST IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S IN EXISTING LAW THEY GOT
A SPECIAL MENTION -- OVER THAT
TIME THERE'S THEY'VE SUBMITTED
ONE NUMBER FOR ALL THE SIX
BENEFIT CATEGORIES THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO TRY TO DO THEIR BEST
TO ACCOMMODATE THOSE SIX BENEFIT
CATEGORIES TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY.
WE DON'T THINK THAT ONE NUMBER
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GETS YOU THERE.
AND THEY'VE -- INCREASED RATES
EACH OF THOSE YEARS INCLUDING
THE MOST RECENT FIVE POINT 1%
RATE INCREASE AGAIN WITH NO
JUSTIFICATION OTHER THAN THE
PRICES ARE HIGHER THEY DON'T
TELL US WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
TERMS OF UTILIZATION AT KAISER.
AND SO WE DO THINK THAT THERE IS
THE NEED -- FOR YOU KNOW.
YES MEAN.
TESTIFIED VERY WELL TOO YOU KNOW
THERE.
MAYBE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME SOME
LAPSES ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
BUT THERE IS A NEED TO GET
KAISER TO A PLACE OF EQUAL
FOOTING WITH WHERE THE REST OF
THE MARKET IS.
AND IF THIS YEAR'S RATE INCREASE
PUTS THE BLUE SHIELD ON AVERAGE
PRODUCTS 12% TWELVE DOLLARS
EXCUSE ME LOWER THAN THE KAISER
PRODUCT ON AVERAGE YOU KNOW.
IS THAT TWELVE DOLLARS A FACTOR
OF ALL THOSE OTHER INSURANCE
PLANS AND ALL THOSE OTHER
HOSPITALS AND ALL THOSE OTHER
DOCTORS HAVING TO COMPLY WITH
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF REGULATION
AND TRANSPARENCY IT'S IT'S
SIMPLY NOT FAIR. TO SAY THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PRODUCE THE SAME
LEVELS OF INFORMATION AND
JUSTIFICATION AND THEN YOU CAN
CHARGE SO SLIGHTLY LOWER RATES
THAN SOMEBODY ELSE DOES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER AND
AND DOCTOR PAN PRESUMING THE
PRISM OF THE YOU BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH OCCUPIED -- ABOUT THE BILL
IN THEIR DATA COLLECTION IF ONLY
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- WHAT
ARE THEY SAYING ABOUT WITH THE
KAISER COULD EVEN PROVIDE THE
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS AT THIS
BILL WOULD -- MANDATE.
SO -- I I DON'T SPEAK DIRECTLY
FOR US I SPIED -- BUT THANK THE
THE ISSUES REALLY WHAT KAISER --
PROVIDES AND WHAT THEY FILE AND
I'VE EXAMS ON THE FILINGS AND
THERE'S A LOT OF WELL BLANKS
BASICALLY SAYING REFER TO THIS
ONE NUMBER.
AND I THINK THAT THAT THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC -- AND AND SO -- I I
DON'T I SPORTS MAINLY.
I START SELF IS MORE OF A DATA
COLLECTOR THAN ANYTHING ELSE I
MEAN I BUT I WOULD SAY IS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THE THE LEVEL OF
GRANULARITY OF INFORMATION WE'RE
GETTING IS -- IT IS NOT VERY
HELPFUL OR USEFUL RIGHT WHEN YOU
AG ALL OF THOSE IN CALIFORNIA
WELL GEE I MEAN I'M IN IN
SACRAMENTO MARKET I KNOW THIS
WILL EVEN MULTIPLE HOSPITALS AND
SECOND I CAN'T.
PULL OUT WHAT'S GOING ON
SACRAMENTO VERSES THE BAY AREA
VERSES.
AT PRESENT OUR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT THE AND YET YOU KNOW WHAT
EVERY OTHER HOSPITAL AND I'M NOT
SAYING YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE
THE APPLE IT IT'S NOT NOTHING ON
THE APPLE EXACTLY APPLE APPLE
BUT WE WE THERE'S A REASON WE
ASK THOSE OTHER INSTITUTE.
OTHER HOSPITALS AND OTHER HEALTH
PLANS FOR INFORMATION AS WELL
AND SO I THINK THERE IS ALSO AN
ISSUE OF FAIRNESS THAT COMES OUT
TO ABOUT WELL WHY DO THEY HAVE.
TO TELL US STUFF AND KAISER
DOESN'T AND WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE BUT IT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT'S IT COMES DOWN --
TO DO ARE WE GETTING THE KIND OF
INFORMATION TO REACH THE KIND OF
GOAL TO WANNA CHIEF FOR OUR
REGULATORS AND FOR OUR
PURCHASERS AND FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON OKAY.
THANK YOU -- AND THEN TO RESA
COUPLE THINGS A FIRST OF ALL I'M
ALSO A FAN OF KAISER -- THE
KAISER IN SAN DIEGO I HAVE TO
SAY I'M VERY IMPRESSED SAY MY
BROTHER LAWS LIFE WHO HAD TO
HAVE A A BIRD SEE CROWDED BYPASS
SURGERY AND CAME THROUGH WITH
FLYING COLORS.
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH YOUR OR
YOUR OPERATION -- SO WITH
RESPECT TO THE HOSPITAL
REPORTING OF THE BILL IF THIS
WERE TO PASS IN ITS CURRENT FORM --
BASED ON WHAT YOU YOU SAID HOW
WOULD YOU COMPLY YOU MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT IF YOU HAD TO
COMPLY THAT YOU THINK WOULD BE
LESS TRANSPARENT THAN THE
MECHANISM THAT YOUR YOUR YOU'RE
DOING TODAY COULD YOU ELABORATE
ON THAT YEAH I MEAN I THINK AS I
AS WE SORT.
OF CHATTED WITH WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL ABOUT THAT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE HOSPITAL
REPORTING THERE THERE IS
PROBABLY MORE WE CAN DO AT A
MORE GRANULAR GRANULAR LEVEL
WITH RESPECT TO THE THE CHARGE
INFORMATION HOSPITAL CHARGES THE
PATIENT REVENUE -- I FORGET IF
THAT'S THE ANNUAL REPORT OF THE
OR THE QUARTERLY REPORT -- THAT
IS NOT A CHEAP THING FOR US TO
DO SO I THINK AGAIN YOU KNOW
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND WE'RE
WE'RE WILLING TO DO THAT WORK IN
AND REALLY.
SORT OF FREAK REVAMP THE
ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS TO TO
ALLOCATE THAT AND FIGURE THAT
OUT FOR THIRTY SIX HOSPITALS YOU
KNOW INSTEAD OF TWO REPORTS
THERE WOULD BE THIRTY SIX
REPORTS THAT'S NOT.
THIS IS ALL MANUAL ENTRY AND WE
LOVE OUR SPOT BUT THEIR THEIR
TECHNICAL PLATFORM IS NOT GREAT --
SO THAT SO THERE'S AN INVESTMENT
THERE -- I WOULD SO WE CAN DO IT
IT'S DOABLE IT WILL BE DIFFICULT
AND COSTLY -- THAT IS IN IN
CONTRAST TO THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS -- WHICH THAT THE
BALANCE SHEET THE INCOME
STATEMENT -- IS IF YOU REFER TO
AS THE PANELS.
THAT AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE LEGAL
STRUCTURE OF THE ORGANIZATION
THAT LITERALLY DOESN'T EXIST AT
THE FACILITY LEVEL.
SO.
THE HOSPITALS ARE ASSETS OF
KAISER FOUNDATION HOSPITAL SO --
IF IF YOU OWN THREE TV'S IN YOUR
HOME I DON'T KNOW IF YOU DO BUT
IF YOU OWN THREE TV'S IN YOUR
HOME.
YOU THOSE ARE YOUR ASSETS YOU
OWN THOSE TV'S THE TV'S.
ARE INDEPENDENT FINANCIAL
ENTITIES THAT HAVE THEIR OWN
ASSETS AND LIABILITIES SO IT.
IT'S HARD TO KIND OF WRAP YOUR
MIND AROUND -- ACCOUNTING WAS A
LONG TIME FOR ME BUT SO WE IF
THERE'S MORE WE CAN PROVIDE.
THAT IS THAT IT'S THAT YIELDS
MEANINGFUL TRANSPARENCY AND
HELPS TO MOVE THIS CONVERSATION
FORWARD WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO
DO IT BUT THEY'RE SIMPLY
INFORMATION THAT THAT IS JUST A
NON STARTER THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
SO YOUR ACCOUNTING SOFTWARE FOR
BASICALLY FOR KAISER I'M SURE
WAS PROBABLY DESIGNED FOR KAISER
THAT.
SENDS ALL THE EXPENSES AND ALL
THE REVENUES TO ONE FEDERAL TAX
ID NUMBER AND YOU COME UP WITH
WHAT THE RATE THAT IS
IMPLEMENTED. FOR IT FOR YOU TO
DO WHAT'S BEING OUSTED.
WHAT IS A FAIR TO THIS TO SAY
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO HIRE
FORENSIC ATTORNEY ACCOUNTANTS TO
COME IN?
AND TO DISASSOCIATE FROM THE
MASTER ACCOUNTING.
OF THE ACCOUNTING RELATED TO
EACH RESPECTIVE HOSPITAL
QUESTION ONE QUESTION.
TWO IS IT FAIR TO SAY WITH YOUR
THIRTY TWO HOSPITALS SUGGEST
SOME HOSPITALS THAT ARE MUCH
MORE PROFITABLE THAN OTHERS AND
MAYBE SOME OF THE HOSPITAL'S
ACTUALLY.
KERRY OTHER HOSPITALS.
AND IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR TO SAY
THAT IF YOU DID THE ACCOUNTING
OF EACH RESPECTIVE HOSPITAL
WOULD YOU SEE DIFFERENT RATES A
COULD BE MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
CERTAIN AREAS.
AND LESS EXPENSIVE IN OTHER
AREAS.
YES SIR TWO TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION I I CERTAINLY CAN'T
SPEAK TO WHO WE WOULD NEED TO
HIRE AN AND HOW MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE WE WOULD NEED TO HIRE I
DO KNOW THAT THE MY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ON THIS BILL HAVE
BEEN VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT.
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE FOR US TO ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW REPORT DECEMBER WEEK WE
HAVE IT WE CAN DEVELOP BUT A
METHODOLOGY A SYSTEM TO TO
REPORT THAT BUT THAT IS NOT A
SMALL THING.
I I DON'T KNOW YOU KNOW BUT
AGAIN THE NUMBER OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WAS WAS THROWN OUT IN
AND I WILL ADMIT WE HAVE NOT.
SAT AND DONE THAT YOU KNOW VERY
CAREFUL MATH -- BUT IT WOULD BE
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND IT
MIGHT BE WORTH IT THERE MIGHT BE
VALUE IN THAT INVESTMENT BASED
ON ON WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY --
WITH RESPECT.
TO HOSPITALS THAT ARE MORE
PROFITABLE IN THERE THAT THAT'S
JUST NOT HOW WE THINK -- CAR OUR
HOSPITALS ARE ACTUALLY BEING
FORCED TO THINK THAT WAY WELL WE
THINK IN A WAY WHERE I THE FACT
THAT OUR HOSPITALS ARE ARE ARE
ESSENTIALLY ONE ENTITY IS
ACTUALLY A GOOD THING WHEN IT
COMES TO COSTS WHEN IT COMES TO
QUALITY SO FOR INSTANCE.
KAISER FOUNDATION HOSPITAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THEY BY ALL
OF THE DRUGS.
RIGHT SO WE KNOWTHE ISSUES WITH
WITH PHARMACEUTICAL PRICING WE
HER UP A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
BUYING EQUIPMENT WHEN YOU'RE
BUYING MATERIAL WE'RE NOT JUST
ONE HOSPITAL YOU KNOW BUYING
THESE THINGS WE ARE LEVERAGING
THE SIZE OF THE ORGANIZATION AND
ACTUALLY THAT'S CREATING VALUE
AND EFFICIENCIES AND KEEPING
PRICES LOW.
SO I DON'T THE I DON'T THINK WE
EVEN HAVE LOW PERFORMING
HOSPITALS IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU
HOW YOU DEFINE THAT THE QUALITY
SCORES REALLY SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES THE QUALITY SCORES
FOR HOSPITALS ARE OFF THE CHARTS --
WE HAVE MEDICARE FIVE STAR
HOSPITALS AND AND AND PLAN HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S I THINK
HOW WHAT WE HAVE TO BE LOOKING
AT IS IS THE QUALITY.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE OF AFRAID OF
YOU KNOW ANYTHING BAD SORT OF
SHOWING UP IN THE DATA WE'RE
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF IF YOU'RE.
GETTING US TO TO SPEND THAT
MONEY WE WANT TO BE SURE WERE
TELLING THE TRUTH WE WANT TO BE
SURE IT'S AN ACCURATE REFLECTION
OF OF OUR MODEL.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTIN BY
CENTER RUBIO SOUNDS LIKE -- YOU
DOCTOR PANDER TO HAVE MORE
COMMUNICATIONS TOGETHER -- AND
SO WITH A DOCTOR AND IF YOU LIKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK.
THE COMMITTEE -- FOR SOME VERY
THOUGHTFUL DOC CONVERSATION --
WITH WITH EVERYONE HERE -- BUT
BUT I I DO I DO I MAKE SEVERAL
POINTS AND REALLY TO OFF OF WHAT
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW CENTER MONEY
YOU YOU YOU BE MENTION LIKE OF
COURSE THEY HAVE TO KNOW.
HOW MUCH THEY'RE SPENDING I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU MANAGED TO
ORGANIZATION WHEN YOU DON'T HOW
DO YOU DECIDE HOW MUCH FOOT
PREMIUM YOU CHARGE RIGHT?
AND WHAT YOU NEGOTIATE.
FOR AID THE ON THE ANALOGY SAY
THREE TV'S AT SAY FOR EXAMPLE
THAT I AND I AM NOT RICH ENOUGH
TO TO TO DO THIS BUT IT SAYS YOU
HAVE THREE RENTAL PROPERTIES
OKAY.
YOU HAVE THREE RENTAL PROPERTIES
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH EACH TENANT IN
EACH PROPERTY YOU MAY BY THE
TOILET PAPER FOR ALL THREE YOU
KNOW I COSCO BUT YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH TOILET PAPERS GOING TO EACH
HOUSE ARE AND HOW OFTEN THEY'RE
BEING USED.
SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO RUN THE
ORGANIZATION.
OKAY SO YES ALL HOSPITALS MAY BE
UNDER ONE TAX ID NUMBER BUT I'M
SURE THEY MUST HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING.
OF FOR EACH HOSPITAL WHAT
THEY'RE SPENDING HOW MUCH HOW
MANY PATIENTS ARE IN THERE HOW
MUCH THEY'RE SPENDING PER BED
ICU BED OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
AND YET IN THE REPORT.
EVEN FOR ALL THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE GET WELL BLANK
BLANK BLANK BLANK AND IT'S ALL
ROLLED UP INTO INPATIENT OKAY SO
I I DO THINK THAT IS.
A BIG PROBLEM I APPRECIATE THE
THE CENTER LEYVA YOU ASKED YOU
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PLANS WELL SOMEBODY
HAD TO COME UP WITH THE
CALCULATION FOR HOW IF YOU ME
WHEN YOU'VE MET.
THAT DEDUCTIBLE.
RIGHT SO SOMEBODY HAD TO THERE
HAS TO BE IN EXIST NOT NOT WE GO
SPEND A MILLION DOLLARS LATER.
WE HAVE A PROCESS RIGHT NOW TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN YOU HIT YOUR
DEDUCTIBLE WHEN NOW YOU KNOW
THAT YOU THAT YOU'RE NOT PAYING
OUT OF POCKET WITH THAT CENTER
SO THERE'S A MECHANISM AND THEN
I THINK.
YOU'LL MENTION CLAIMS AND YES
YOU KNOW PART OF THAT THE CLAIMS
DEPARTMENT MAYBE THE CLERK
CLAIMS IF YOU GO TO ANOTHER E.
R..
BUT I UNDERSTAND THERE'S AN
INTERNAL CLAIMS DEPARTMENT TO
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S SO AND AND
THEY HAVE TO SIGN SOME KIND OF
PRICE THAT SOMEONE'S FIGURED OUT
FOR OKAY SO FORTH. TO TRACK
WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION SO AGAIN THIS IS THE
DATA THAT'S BEING STE -- USED
WHEN THEY NEGOTIATE AND ONE YES
WHEN YOU SEE ALL THESE AS WHAT
WE ARE NOT UNDER THE HOOD OKAY
FINE WE'LL SHOW YOU A LITTLE BIT
AND SO TEY HAVE THIS INTERNAL
CLAIMS PROCESS TO INVADE EVEN
TALK TO PEOPLE WORKED IN THEIR
CELLS.
THEY SAY YEAH WE HAVE THINGS
THAT WE COULD RE TRACK AND IT'S
SO I I MEAN.
I APPRECIATE THAT KAISER IS A
SYSTEM THAT YOU KNOW SAYS OKAY
LOOK YOU KNOW WE'RE CAPITATED BY
LIKE THERE ARE OTHER SYSTEMS ARE
CAPITATED.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND SO WAS A
CAPITATED SYSTEM YEAH WE ARE
TRYING TO COME UP THE BEST VALUE
IN IN KAISER REALLY IS A MODEL
SYSTEM IN MARY VETS NOW IT'S
IT'S IT'S THE PIONEERS A MODEL
SYSTEM.
AND AND AND WE WHAT I SEE WHAT
PEOPLE TO LOOK MORE PEOPLE LOOK
LIKE KAISER.
SO IN TERMS OF THE CLINICAL
ORGANIZATION AND THAT'S GOOD --
BUT I I IT TO ADMIT THAT I AM A
LITTLE YOU KNOW THE SURPRISED
ABOUT SAYING THAT WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
AN INSIDER ORGANIZATION.
NOW I AGREE CENTER MITCH I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
AND ALSO THROUGH THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT.
OKAY IT MAY NOT BE EXACTLY THE
SAME BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU YOU
YOU IT'S IT'S NOT YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT SENDING BILLS TO HEALTH AND
THE TO A TO A TO A HEALTH PLAN
BECAUSE IT'S PART OF OUR
INTEGRATED SYSTEM BUT YOU
DEFINITELY.
YOU KNOW THE COST THAT YOU HAVE
A COMPANY RIGHT YOU KNOW YOUR
LINES OF BUSINESS RIGHT YOU KNOW
WHO HE IS SO IT'S IT'S THE YOU
CAN'T I CAN'T IMAGINE YOU SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S ALL
ONE BUSINESS SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BETWEEN THIS
LINE.
AND THAT LINE AND THAT LINE OF
BUSINESS YOU YOU THAT YOU KNOW.
ARE YOU DON'T USUALLY PRETTY BUT
YOU GET ON THE BANKRUPT SO SO
ANYWAY I I'M LOOKING FOR TWO
WEEKS A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE
WITH KAISER BECAUSE I HAVE A
TREMENDOUS ADMIRATION FOR KAISER
AS AN ORGANIZATION -- BUT I ALSO
KNOW YOU KNOW I'VE WORKED WITH
OTHER HEALTH SYSTEMS AND AND SO
FORTH.
AND I A AND I THINK THAT WHAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO DO IS TO ACTUALLY
TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL THAT I
THINK -- CENTER MITCHELL SO
ARTICULATELY AT SOAP SO PROPERLY
DESCRIBE THIS LIKE WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS WE WANT TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION AT THE
RIGHT GRANULARITY THAT ALLOWS US
TO ACHIEVE OUR HEALTH OUR AIMS
IN TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S
REGULATORY ARE TRANSPARENCY SO
THAT.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND AND
THE PURCHASERS AND AND
REGULATORS.
KNOW WHAT NOT CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON AND THAT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY FAIRNESS ACROSS THE OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM -- TO IT SO
THAT -- WE CAN TRY TO ACHIEVE
OUR AIMS AND SO I'M ALWAYS OPEN
TO THAT CONRAD YEAH I'VE I WANT
TO THE REASON THE BILLS IN THE
FORM IT'S NOW IT'S COME STILL
WAITING TO GET THAT.
DIALOGUE INVOLVED WE CAN LAND
SOME LANGUAGE WITH KAISER TO SAY
OKAY NOW WILL COME TO AGREEMENT
ABOUT THE STUBBLE GRANULARITY
ETCETERA.
AND AND I CAN'T SPEAK AS TO HOW
MUCH WILL COST KAISER TO DO THAT
BUT THERE'S A PART OF IT ALSO
SAYS THERE THEY HAVE SYSTEMS TO
TRACK INFORMATION NOW YOU KNOW
IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE SAYING IN
THE LITERAL SENSE OF THE BILL
RIGHT NOW MAYBE NOT BUT OKAY.
FINE LET'S TWEAK IT BUT SO WE
CAN GET THAT EQUIVALENT
INFORMATION.
IN A WAY THAT'S NOT OVERLY
BURDENSOME A COSTLY TO KAISER
BUT THEN ALSO PROVIDES THE KIND
OF INFORMATION THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE FOR SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PLAYER IN A HEALTH
CARE MARKET WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT BUT
YOU CENTER PAN WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR RUBIO.
THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AN BY AND I STONE NO STONE NOW
DRAWS -- DRAWS -- I GROW HER
TADO LEYVA.
THEY WERE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SIX SIX VOTES SIMPLY THE
ROLE OPEN DOCTOR BROWN AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO YOUR OF FILE
NUMBER NINE SB.
THREE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SB.
SIX SB THREE SIXTY THREE WILL
REQUIRED DATA FOR REPORTING
ON STAFF A FACILITIES RUN BY THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
CALIFORNIA THE PART OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
THERE ARE DOCUMENTED INCIDENTS
OF VIOLENCE THAT PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION FOR WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION HOWEVER THE
AGGREGATED DATA REGARDING
ASSAULT OF STATE EMPLOYEES IN A
MOST CHALLENGING AND VIOLENT
STATE WORK SITES IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT REALLY
AVAILABLE.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE AND ENSURE
SAFETY FOR EMPLOYEES AT THESE
FACILITIES WE NEED A CONFERENCE
OF ASSESSMENT OF WHERE VIOLENT
INCIDENTS ARE HAPPENING.
HOW OFTEN AND TO WHICH EMPLOYEES
THE STAKEHOLDERS A STATE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE DATA REPORTS
ON A MONTHLY AND ANNUAL BASIS
RESPECTIVELY TO MONITOR THE
CURRENTS?
VIOLENT INCIDENTS INVOLVING
STATE EMPLOYEES AND THE STATE
WOULD INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
OCCURRENCES FOR EACH FACILITY
JOB CLASSIFICATION PLEASE
ASSAULTED BY A PATIENT OR INMATE.
AND THE DATE OF THE ASSAULT BY
ENSURING THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE RESPECTIVE CHAIRS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEES.
RECEIVE THESE REPORTS ANNUALLY
THE THIS LEGISLATION TAKES A
LOGICAL STEP IN MITIGATING STAFF
ASSAULTS INTERSTATE.
FACILITIES BY UTILIZING THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT TO
COLLECT DATA THAT COULD BE USED
TO EXPLORE FUTURE POLICIES ARE
REGULATIONS THAT PROMOTE A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT FOR BOTH STAFF.
PATIENTS ARE INMATES -- I AM
OFFERING -- MINUTES TO ADDRESS
POLICY COMMENTS RAISE AN
ANALYSIS THESE AMENDMENTS TO DO
THE FOLLOWING ONE REQUIRED A
THREE DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE THE
REPORTS TO THE BARGAINING UNITS
RATHER THAN INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES THAT MAKE THE REPORTS.
WE ARE CHANGING TO CHANGE THE
TERM VIOLET INCIDENT TO ASSAULT
AND A CROSS REFERENCE TO THE
DEFINITION OF THAT TERM IN
EXISTING LAW.
AND THREE ADDED DEFINITION
FACILITIES FOR PURPOSES A BILL
TO PROVIDE CLARITY AND PREACHY I
HAVE HERE TODAY WITH ME -- ABDUL
JOHNSON A CHAPLAIN AT VALLEY
STATE PRISON AND COOLING --
STATE HOSPITAL AND DOCTOR HAYLEY
WILLIAMS A FORENSIC PSYCHOLOGIST
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
WHO ARE HERE TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
UNDERGROUND THE THE VICE CHAIRS
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL.
I THINK HIS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
PROBABLY HERE SO WITH THAT I'M
ASKING IF YOU KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE.
RED LIGHT ON OKAY GOOD EVENING
HI MY NAME'S HAYLEY WILLIAMS I
AM A STAFF PSYCHOLOGIST AT C. S.
P. SACRAMENTO.
ON HERE AS A MEMBER OF ASKED ME
LOCAL.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY THIS BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME STAFF
CITIES VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AS I
THINK IT IS EVERYONE WHO WORKS
IN THIS DEPARTMENT -- STAFF IS
ASSAULTED DAILY I'M IT'S
ALARMING RATE WITHIN THE SYSTEM --
WE ARE.
ASSAULTED PHYSICALLY VERBALLY
SEXUALLY -- SOMETIMES MULTIPLE
TIMES A DAY TO THE SAME PERSON.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NOT A
GREAT WAY TO TRACK THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THIS BILL FROM THE
AUTHORS BECAUSE IT WILL PROVIDE.
A WAY TO TRACK THE STATISTICS IN
IS REALLY VITAL -- BY TRACKING
THE STATISTICS AS WE KNOW
HISTORY DOES HAVE A CHANCERY
PEDIA ITSELF AD BY TRACKING IS
APPROPRIATELY NOT ONLY CAN WE
SEE THESE NUMBERS WILL ALSO
HOPEFULLY HELP.
PEOPLE PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN AND AGAIN -- BECAUSE AS OF
RIGHT NOW THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT READILY AVAILABLE -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME ON SEVERAL FOR
SEVERAL REASONS BUT MAINLY
BECAUSE I SEE THIS HAPPEN ALL
THE TIME IT'S HAPPENED TO ME.
I WANT TO BRIEFLY SHARE ONE OF
MY EXPERIENCES -- ABOUT A A
BRIEF.
BRIEF OKAY ABOUT A YEAR AGO -- I
WAS GAS THAT'S A TERM THAT WE
USE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE -- HAVE
SOMETHING JUST THROWN ON THEM AS
I WALK INTO A ROOM I HAD A FULL
CUP OF URINE THROWN IN MY FACE
AND MY EYES IN MY MOUTH -- THIS
IS BEFORE I COULD EVEN GET ONE
WORD OUT TO THIS IN MAINE WHO
HAS A VERY VIOLENT HISTORY OF
VIOLENT RECORD -- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT.
HAPPENS OFTEN TO STAFF AND THEN
WE ARE EXPECTED TO RESUME OUR
NORMAL DUTIES AND GO BACK TO
WORK THE NEXT DAY AS IF NOTHING
HAPPENED I THINK IT IS --
IMPORTANT ATTRACT THESE
STATISTICS FOR EVERYBODY -- IS
NOT VOTE.
IT'S NOT NICE FOR THIS TO HAPPEN
IS NOT PLEASANT FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN AND I'M HOPING THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN PREVENT
THIS FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE OTHER PEOPLE.
THANK YOU FOR CUSTOMER SORRY FOR
THE EXPERIENCES THAT YOU HAD A
SURE OKAY.
THE BILL JOHNSON PRESIDENT OF
AFSCME LOCAL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- I WILL I
RESPECT KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF --
I DO WANT TO BRING.
ATTENTION TO THE ASSAULT A COMMA
WAS THE NEXUS FOR THIS BILL WAS
A SEVENTY THREE YEAR OLD SOCIAL
WORKER -- WHO WAS RAPED AND
ASSAULTED?
AT HER DESK AT CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL FACILITY -- IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THIS DATA
BECAUSE IT GOES THE FACT THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME YOU ALL
ARE HEARING ABOUT IT -- IS IS A
CONCERN FOR US -- SO AS WE MOVE
FOR WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YES
VOTE -- ON SB SIXTY THREE SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY.
BOB IS THE CHAIR BY SHARE
MEMBERS SIDE BRIAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ARE PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION ALSO WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT -- BY JUST ONE
OUT HIGHLIGHT THE EXCELLENT WORK
DONE BY THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
ON AND IN WORKING WITH US TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE LANGUAGE IS APPROPRIATE --
AND WE'LL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TO NOT VOTE NATURE TO
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THE TERM MOTION [inaudible]
CENTER LEYVA.
AND WE HAVE TO FIRST HEAR FROM
THOSE ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL.
BECAUSE OF THAT MOTION IS COOL.
THANK YOU BYE SIR -- ADRIN
MOHAMMED WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
WE REPRESENT THE DOCTORS AT CDC
ARE THE SHN DD -- SAID WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE THINGS FOR
YOUR SERVICE.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS HEIDI TOTAL ANIMUS I
CAN'T A TECHNICIAN I WAS
ASSAULTED IN VICTIM I WAS STOP
SEVERAL TIMES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE IN
BEING -- WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE BILL.
EXCERPTED STONY.
A MERRY NVIDIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS BARGAINING UNIT
EIGHTEEN I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
YOU'LL CHOICE PSYCHOLOGIST AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS PATTON I HAVE TWO
POINTS TO MAKE.
ONE WE AT THE STATE HOSPITALS
WHAT WITH THE MOST DANGEROUS
PATIENT POPULATION ACROSS
HOSPITALS.
AND HEALTH FACILITIES IN THIS
NATION.
OUTSIDE OUR GATES OUR PATIENTS
ARE TRANSPORTED IN HANDCUFFS AND
LEG AND BODY SHEKELS BUT INSIDE
THE HOSPITAL WE WHAT WITH THEM
WITH NO BARRIERS AND WITH JUST.
PERSONAL ALARM FOR OUR SAFETY.
AND YOU'VE HEARD SOME PAST
PERSONAL TESTIMONIES OF OUR
STAFF WHO HAVE BEEN PERSONALLY
INSULTED.
I HAVE TWO OTHER STATEMENTS FROM
A PSYCHOLOGIST IN ANOTHER
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN I WON'T
GO INTO THEM.
AT MY SECOND POINT IS I ALSO
REPRESENT THE SAFETY COALITION.
A BARGAINING UNITS AT PATTON
STATE HOSPITAL.
IT'S A COALITION OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT BARGAINING UNITS AT
REPRESENTING EMPLOYEES AT THE
HOSPITAL WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET THIS KIND OF DATA FROM
MANAGEMENT.
ABOUT ASSAULTS AGAINST STAFF AND
WE'VE NOT BEEN.
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING THIS
INFORMATION I THINK WE DO GET
SOME INJURY AND ILLNESS
INFORMATION BUT NOT A SOUL
INFORMATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY.
ON A CALL UP ANY ONE OPPOSED TO
SB THREE SIXTY THREE ANYONE
OPPOSED.
SING ON DOCTOR PAN IF YOU LIKE
CLOSE WE HAVE MOTION BY A US
HUNDRED LEYVA THANK YOU.
I I DO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES WHO TOOK TIME TO
TRAVEL HERE AND I APOLOGIZE BUT
YOU KNOW -- WE DO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT ON THE
COMMITTEE OF WHICH I HOPE WILL
BE EXPRESS QUICKLY IN THIS VOTE
SO THANKS VERY MUCH IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
OKAY THIS IS TO PASS AMENDED TO
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT.
WE COULD CALL ROLE.
DRUGS SO.
DRUGS -- I'D GROVE FOR TADO.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO BY.
THAT'S UP WITH SEVEN ZERO THAT
OF WORLD OPEN.
UP AND SENATOR GRAHAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
JUST.
I THANK.
YOU [inaudible]
THE NUMBER.
MITCHELL MEDICAL. FOR USE --
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL --
WILL ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU.
IS EVERYBODY BRIGHTENED FRESHEN
BRIGHT EYED BUSHY TAIL YOU WANNA
STRAP CAN THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT MOVE AROUND AROUND AROUND.
AND MY COMMITTEE STATEMENT SAYS
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WELL THAT'S NOT TRUE.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE MEMBERS FOR POLLS ON PAGE
FOR THE BILL ANALYSIS THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
SENATE BILL THREE SIX ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE HEALTH HOMES PROGRAM IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE ORIGINAL LAW PASSED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN CARRIED BY YOURS
TRULY.
BACKGROUND THE BILL SB EXCUSE ME
AB THREE SIX ONE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF THE
HEALTH HOMES -- PROGRAM WAS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE ENHANCED
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN
COORDINATION FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WITH MULTIPLE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESSES.
THE PROGRAM IS ALSO INTENDED TO
SPECIFICALLY TARGET PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
IT WAS INTRODUCED.
THAT INCLUDED A TWO YEAR SUNSET
PRIMARILY DUE TO BUDGET
LIMITATIONS AT THAT TIME.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- WAS WORK AND
IMPLEMENTATION ROLL OUT FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME MUCH
LONGER THAN WE ORIGINALLY
ANTICIPATED FIVE YEARS.
ON THE DEPARTMENT IS JUST START
THE ROLL OUT IN THE COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO -- THAT DELAY WITH
THE X. EXPONENTIALLY GROWING
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA WE
DETERMINED THAT THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL CONTINUES AND WE'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE THE WORK. THREE
THREE SB THREE SIX NE AIMS TO
STRENGTHEN THE INTENT OF AB
THREE SIX ONE FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY.
TO DOING TWO THINGS MAKING THE
PROGRAM IT PROGRAM AN ONGOING
PROGRAM BY REMOVING THE SUNSET.
OF THE STATE FUNDING.
AND IT TO INCREASE PART OF THE
PROGRAM OUT REACH TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WE'VE HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TIERED RATES FOR HEALTH HOME
PROVIDERS AND ARE WORKING WITH
INVESTED PARTIES.
SPECIFICALLY THE HEALTH PLANS
ASSOCIATION TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT SO WE ARE IN PROCESS.
HEALTH HOMES PROGRAMS ARE
ROLLING OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS I REMEMBER US TALKING ABOUT
IT YOU SPENT SOME TIME.
IN YOUR PAST LIFE DOCTOR PAN --
IT MINISTRY THIS VERY PROGRAM
OTHER STATES INCLUDING MISSOURI
I'LL ALABAMA IN WISCONSIN HAVE
SEEN COSTS THERE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM MEDICAID NO STATES.
REDUCED AFTER THE H. H. P.
IMPLEMENTATION AND IT MADE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE HEALTH CARE
OF THIS HIGH RISK VOLATILE
POPULATION.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PEOPLE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE OUT WITH
IT HERE IT'S THE MEDICATION LINK
THEM TO PAY YOUR FAMILY SUPPORT
SYSTEMS AND PROVIDE HOUSING
TRANSITION SERVICES AMONG OTHER
SERVICES.
WITH ME TODAY OF COURSE THIS
YEAR AND RAPOPORT WHO WE WORKED
WITH PREVIOUSLY WHAT THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING.
AND LINDA WAY WITH THE WEST
INSTEAD OF LAW AND POVERTY I ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL
WITNESSES THE PORT.
GOOD EVENING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING -- STUDY AFTER STUDY
DOES SHOW THAT MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH COSTS --
AND THAT CONNECTING
BENEFICIARIES BOTH HOUSING AN
INTENSIVE SERVICES TO PROMOTE
HOUSING STABILITY REDUCE THOSE
COSTS SIGNIFICANTLY USUALLY
BEYOND THE COST OF THE SERVICES
AND A HOUSING -- AND ONE EXAMPLE
IS THE JOURNAL OF AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION A STUDY THAT
HAD A CONTROL GROUP THAT FOUND
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR.
SAVINGS IN MEDICAID -- COST PER
MONTH BY MOVING CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS BENEFICIARIES AND
HOUSING AND PROVIDING --
SUFFICIENT SERVICES.
WITH THESE DATE IN MIND WE WERE --
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MITCHELL FOR
INTRODUCING AB.
THREE SIXTY ONE WHICH INCLUDED
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
HOME PROGRAM WOULD SERVE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS --
BENEFICIARIES.
IN A REPORT TO CONGRESS THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICAID MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES REPORTED
MEDICAID HEALTH HOME PROGRAMS.
DID RETURN SIGNIFICAN UP AND
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IN MULTIPLE
STATES -- AND WELL -- DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS
IMPLEMENTED THE HEALTH HOME
PROGRAM IN A WAY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
BENEFICIARIES WE STILL HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT POPULATION IS SERVED -- SB
THREE SIXTY ONE WOULD REMOVE
BARRIERS TO SUSTAINING THIS
PROGRAM OVER THE LONG TERM AND
IMPLEMENT LESSONS LEARNED FROM
HEALTH HOME PROGRAMS AND OTHER
STATES.
AND AS THE SENATOR MITCHELL
IDENTIFIED THERE'S SEVERAL
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
GIVE PRIVATE PROVIDERS
INCENTIVES TO SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
IT WILL ENSURE PLANS AND
PROVIDERS REACH BENEFICIARIES --
WHO ARE ON THE STREETS AND IT
WILL CONNECT HOMELESS
BENEFICIARIES THE HOMELESS
SYSTEMS -- WE CONTINUE TO
APPRECIATE CENTER MISSILES
INCREDIBLE DEDICATION TO
ENSURING THIS POPULATION GETS
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND
DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT'LL
IMPROVE CARE FOR MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS.
HOMELESS AND HAVE A CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITION IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT ARE CHEN AYE VOTE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JESS CAM RANH ORTHODOX OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MINUTES NOW IT'S CALIFORNIA
PANTING HELP THE ORGAN REPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THURMOND THERE'S A MOTION ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAYING UNDER THE MOTION
BY SIR SON -- SO MUCH I WANT
THANK YOU FOR FOR BRING THIS --
FOR AND AND YOU'RE A PREVIOUS
WORK ON THIS WE NEED TO CONTINUE
THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU OKAY SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IT WAS A BUSH
MOVED BY CENTER STONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND I AND I
AND STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
DRUGS SO I GROWTH HER TADO.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING NAY MONNING
AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
AT THE SEVEN ZERO THAT'S ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS -- SO
THIS IS GENERAL NOW SO WE'RE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO
THIS CHAMBER I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND START FOR THOSE WHO
ARE READY HERE.
I GOING THROUGH THE BILLS BUT US
OF AGAIN -- PLEASE FOR
EVERYONE'S MONITORING PLEASE GET
YOUR ABSENT MEMBER HERE OKAY SO
WE'LL JUST GO THROUGH THIS IN
ORDER -- SO WE'LL START WITH THE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY FOUR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS MORNING.
MORNING I OKAY SO THAT BILL IS
ACTUALLY OUT SEVEN TWO THANK YOU --
NEXT IS -- I NUMBER TWO SP ONE
SIXTY THREE BY CENTER PORTANTINO
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HOW?
I APOLOGIZE MONNING [inaudible]
MONNING AYE.
SHE'S NOT.
SHE'S NOT COMING BACK.
WHICH IS A OKAY.
SO THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER THREE
SB TWO OF SEVEN SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DORADO.
DRAWS A I GROWTH [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL I THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU -- NEXT IS --
S. S. B..
TWO SIXTY ITEM FOR SB TO SIXTY
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS RAZA.
THROWS A I GROW.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I THAT BILL OUT.
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEMS I NUMBER
FIVE SB TWO EIGHTY NINE BY
CENTER ARCHULETA SIXTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MONNING [inaudible]
OKAY.
A SIMILAR OKAY SO -- THAT BILL
IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY -- ACTUALLY SEE
CAN.
HELLO.
ALL RIGHT OKAY THAT THE NET
BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER SIX SB THREE
THIRTY ONE VICE -- SERVER TADO
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DORADO.
I GROWTH MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I THE BILL WAS OUT --
EIGHT ZERO OKAY NEXT BILL IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB THREE FORTY
THREE BY.
MYSELF A SACRIFICE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE HER TADO [inaudible]
I TWO THREE FOUR FIVE EIGHT THE
BILL WAS OUT EIGHT ONE OKAY
NEXUS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR MITCHELL
SIX OF THESE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE.
HER TADO HER TITLE I YEAH.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO
SIX ITEMS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
SIX THREE SIXTY THREE BY CENTER
PAN.
MYSELF -- BUT WE HOPE THAT IS AT
THEY GET THE WRONG [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
AT SOME.
OKAY SO ACTUALLY.
GOT BACK UP ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
THREE FORTY THREE IS OUT.
SEVEN ONE OKAY NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER -- NINE NINE SB
THREE SIXTY THREE BY PAN -- SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH HER TATO.
HER TITLE BY.
THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY CENTER BATES
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS TORONTO.
TORONTO FIVE GROVE.
THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO NEXT
ENDS AYE NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE
NINETY BY CENTER STONE SECTOR
THESE CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME
MEMBERS ARE ALSO.
DRAWS -- I'D GROWTH HER TADO
TOTAL AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL I SIX EIGHT ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT -- EIGHT ZERO FINALLY
OF ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB SIX
OH FOUR BY CENTER BASIC THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS DORADO.
DRUGS SO I GROW.
THAT BILLS OUT -- EIGHT ZERO
FIFTY NINE NOT CALL WHEN THE
EARLY ONES BECAUSE IT IN THE
GLOVE ON OKAY.
LABOR OUT [inaudible]
OUT.
I TWENTY SURE BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT I ACTUALLY CALLED.
THANK YOU COUNTY SAN.
BECAUSE I THINK THEY JUST
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
EIGHT AND AT A NUMBER.
EIGHT I BET ON ITEM AND EIGHT
YES SHE DID NOTHING.
I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE THEN OKAY
SO BE SURE PORTANTINO'S BECAUSE
I DIDN'T KNOW GROW WITHOUT DAY
NOW [inaudible]
A RUGGED.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THIS
INCLUDES THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH --
THIS HEARING IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU